afternoon I'm calling to order
this hearing of the Senate
committee on health and I want
to welcome everyone here today
-- we have eighteen items on our
agenda -- there are three items
that are -- that we will not be
hearing today -- items number
sixteen A. B. thirteen sixty
by taking item number seventeen
eighty fifteen fifty by Bonta
and I am item number eighteen AB
seventeen eighty five Carillo so
essentially the last three items
we do have for bills on consent
-- it's item number four eighty
three twenty by quirk item
number seven AB five twenty six
by patched McCarty Norris item
number thirteen by eight AB ten
thirty seven by summer Gipson
and I am number fourteen AB ten
ninety eight by some members
AND SO WITH THAT -- HIGH SEAS --
SIMILAR COOPER HERE IF YOU WANT
TO COME UP -- SO LET'S START
WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE AB ONE AND
AS HE COMES UP JUST A REMINDER
OF OUR RULES WE WILL GIVE EACH
OF THE PROPONENTS AND THE
OPPONENTS -- UP TO SIX MINUTES --
FOR TESTIMONY HERE AT THE TABLE
AND AND AFTER IS IT AFTER EACH
ONE WITH AND DO THE ME TO USE
WHICH IS NAME ORGANIZATION THAT
POSITION -- AND OF COURSE I ALSO
MAKE NOTE THAT -- NO SIDE NEEDS
TO USE ALL THEIR SIX MINUTES SO
THEY CAN MAKE MAKE THE POINTS
AND LSS THAN THAT BUT IT'S
ALWAYS APPRECIATED AS WELL --
AND SO -- WITH THAT SIMILAR
COOPER WELCOME WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE TILL
WE GET A QUORUM GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE NXT STANDARDS
FOR YOUTH TACKLE FOOTBALL.
CONSISTENT WITH SAFETY STANDARDS
THE HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL LEVEL.
THE BILL OF ITS GAMES BE CONTACT
DURING YOUTH TACKLE FOOTBALL
PRACTICES. TO THIRTY MINUTES PER
DAY TWO DAYS A WEEK AND
IMPLEMENTS THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE SET OF SAFETY
STANDARDS IN THE COUNTRY FOR
YOUTH FOOTBALL.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL REQUIRES
CONCUSSION EDUCATION COACH
TRAINING.
INJURY TRACKING.
AND THE PIN OBSERVATION OF
PRACTICE THE MEDICAL PERSONAL
GAMES FOR ALL YOUTH TACKLE
FOOTBALL LEAGUES WITH ME TODAY.
MEMBERS THE CALIFORNIA FOOTBALL
ALLIANCE ALONG WITH DOCTOR
DOCTOR AARON RENTALS IN AMY
MCINTYRE.
WELCOME WITH THIS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE IN GERMAN MY NAME IS JOE
RAFTER AND I AM PLEASED TO
SPONSOR AB.
ONE IN PARTNERSHIP WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER AND AND A HALF AGO
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA FOOTBALL
LINES.
THE SCIENCE OF THE BRAIN IS A
HOTLY DEBATED TOPIC IN OUR
SOCIETY.
AND FOOTBALL IS A SPORT THAT
BEARS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
LEADING THE WAY TO IMPLEMENT
SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS.
THE TRUTH IS THAT EVERY PARENT
ONE SEARCH AB ONE PROVIDES THE
THE MOST ROBUST SET OF STANDARDS
IN THE COUNTRY AS RELATES TO
SAFETY AND YOU TACKLE FOOTBALL.
THERE BY CREATING THE MOST
CONSISTENT ENVIRONMENT IN THE
STATE FOR YOU TACKLE FOOTBALL
PLAY.
AB ONE IS INSPIRED INFORMED AND
ALIGNED WITH PREVIOUS
LEGISLATIVE DECISIONS OF
CALIFORNIA. TO BE SURE WERE
CONSISTENT WITH OUR LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTION AND FRANKLY TO ROLE
MODEL THE ALLIANCE'S COMMITMENT.
TO SERVING OUR STATE GOVERNMENT
WITH THE CONTINUAL IMPROVEMENT.
WE SEE THIS AS AN HISTORICAL
MOMENT. FOR ALL THOSE WHO WANT A
SAFER FUTURE FOR YOUTH GET TO
COME TOGETHER.
IN A CONSTRUCTIVE MANNER TO
ADVANCE SAFETY.
STARTING WITH TACKLE FOOTBALL
AND ULTIMATELY ALL SPORTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE LOVE OUR KIDS AND WE SHOW
THEM THAT WE LOVE THEM THROUGH.
TEACHING AND TACKLE FOOTBALL.
OUR GREATEST ACHIEVEMENTS AS A
SOCIETY COME.
WHEN WE OVERCOME ADVERSITY?
AND CREATE A CONSTRUCTIVE
RESPONSE TO FEAR.
OUR COUNTRY EVOLVES ON WHEN WE
PURSUE GROWTH.
THAT IS FUELED BY LOVE FOR EACH
OTHER AND MAKING THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE.
FOOTBALL PLAYS A CHARACTER
BUILDING ROLE.
IN OUR SOCIETY ACROSS A LARGE
AND DIVERSE.
SET OF STAKEHOLDERS.
WE OWE IT TO OUR CURRENT AND
FUTURE FOOTBALL PLAYERS. TO GIVE
THEM THE BEST POSSIBLE
ENVIRONMENT.
AB ONE IS BACKED BY MEDICAL
RESEARCH AS DOCUMENTED IN OUR
DOCKING HERE WE SHARED WITH ALL.
ALL OF YOU ARE.
PRIOR TO HEAR.
EARLIER THIS YEAR WE LAUNCHED A
MEDICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
OR MAC THAT MAC WILL PROVIDE
INDEPENDENT EXPERT MEDICAL
ADVICE TO THE ALLIANCE IT WILL
GUIDE POSITIVE CHANGE.
BY CONTRIBUTING MEDICAL AND
SCIENTIFIC INSIGHT.
ARE THE SAFETY ADVANCES POLICIES
PROCEDURES AND BEST PRACTICES
ARE RECOMMENDED BY THE ALLIANCE.
IT IS CHAIRED BY BOSTON
UNIVERSITY IN TRIPLE BOARD
CERTIFIED NEVER PASS ALLERGIST
DOCTOR PIERRE COMICS.
INCLUDES A ROSTER OF NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED DOCTORS WITH
NEUROLOGY PEDIATRIC ORTHOPEDICS
SPORTS MEDICINE CARDIOLOGY AND
I WANTED CHAIR WHY I'M HERE
TODAY DOING THIS.
I'VE COMMITTED A LOT OF MY LIFE
TO YOU TACKLE FOOTBALL.
GROWING UP.
I WAS REALLY PROBABLY JOHNNY.
IN THE SPORT.
IS WHERE I FOUND MYSELF I FLOOD
EQUITY.
THE CHAIRMEN OF MAN WHO SITS
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY.
VOLUNTEERING MY TIME TREASURES
IN TOWNS.
ON BEHALF OF FUTURE GENERATIONS
SO THAT THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
BENEFIT FROM THE SPORT.
IN OUR MEETINGS WITH YOUR
OFFICES MANY V. OF YOUR STAFFERS
SHARED THAT.
THE ALLIANCE IS MODERN DEMOCRACY
IN ACTION.
WE ARE GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION
WITH COMPETENCE AND PASSION AND
WE'RE HERE TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE ADVANCEMENT OF YOU
TACKLE FOOTBALL IN CALIFORNIA.
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE.
DR.
ERIN REYNOLDS A FOUNDING MEMBER
OF OUR MAC.
A MOM AND A PARTNER IN HELPING
MAKE A BETTER FUTURE FOR OUR
STATE.
HE GOT TWO MINUTES LEFT
REMAINING SPEAKERS.
OKAY I'LL BE FAST THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN PAN -- MY NAME IS
DOCTOR AND REYNOLDS IN THE
CLINICAL SPORTS INTEREST THAT
COLLEGES FROM FRISCO TEXAS I AM
A MEMBER OF THE MAC AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE MAC AND I'M
ALSO A MOTHER OF TWO ATHLETES TO
PLAY -- CONTACT SPORTS AND I'M
HERE TO ENDORSE AB -- ONE AS A
SPORTS NOR A PSYCHOLOGIST I HAVE
DEVOTED MY CAREER TO TREATING
SPORTS CONCUSSIONS I'VE DONE
THAT SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
WE'VE COME A VERY LONG WAY IN
TERMS OF TREATMENT IN THE
ADVANCEMENT THAT WE'VE MADE AND
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO BE.
MISINFORMED THAT CREATES A LOT
OF FEAR SO I'VE I'VE DEDICATED
MY CAREER TO YOU KNOW FOCUSING
ON MY LOCAL COMMUNITY IN TEXAS
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
TALKING ABOUT EARLY
IDENTIFICATION OF INJURY
TREATMENT OF INJURY AND HOW WE
CAN KEEP KIDS IN YOUTH SPORTS --
ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF OUR
MEDICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE AGREE
THAT AB ONE IS A MAJOR STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE ALLIANCE -- TO YOU KNOW
LOOK AT SCIENTIFIC INQUIRY TO
HELP JOE AND HIS COLLEAGUES AS
THEY CONTINUE TO EVOLVE THE
SAFETY OF YOUTH TACKLE FOOTBALL
AND RECOMMEND ADDITIONAL CHANGES
AS TIME GOES ON I DO BELIEVE
THAT IF CALIFORNIA PASSES THIS
BILL IT WILL BE THE FIRST STATE
OF MANY. TO ADOPT SIMILAR
LEGISLATION AND I'VE MADE IT MY
LIFE'S WORK TO TREAT CONCUSSIONS
AND TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
IMPORTANCE OF YOU SPORTS.
AND I FEEL THAT AB ONE IS JUST
THE BEGINNING OF A VERY POWERFUL
MOVEMENT TO MAKE YOU SPORTS A
FOR MY NAME'S CHRIS.
TIRE HI.
ON FOOTBALL MOM I'M GONNA CUT
THIS TO NOTHING -- FOOTBALL
CHANGED MY SON'S LIFE IS FIFTEEN
YEARS OLD HE'S AN EXCELLENT
STUDENT HE'S A RUNNING BACK FOR
HIS HIGH SCHOOL VARSITY TEAM
WHEN HE ASKED ME IF HE COULD
PLAY FOOTBALL WHEN HE WAS EIGHT
YEARS OLD -- WE LET HIM AND FROM
DAY ONE I HAD A KID THAT NEVER
MISSED CLASS PRACTICE A GAME --
SPOKE ONLY IN TERMS OF WE AND
ETHICS TEAM WORK JOY THE THE THE
MAGIC THAT THIS TEAM THAT THIS
SUPPORT IGNITED AND MY SON --
WAS EXTRAORDINARY AND HE HAS A
CHARACTER AND ON AMBITION AND
OPTIMISM TOWARDS LIFE THAT I
BELIEVE -- FOOTBALL.
IGNITED IN HIMSELF THANK GO GO
AB ONE GO FOOTBALL GO CALIFORNIA.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES A SUPPORT NAME
RESERVATION POSITION AT THE
MICROPHONE PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE I AM
KATHY HALL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RON
WHITE NINE THE VP OF THE
ALLIANCE MOST OF THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF COLD EMPIRE FOOTBALL
IN BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA WE
STAND IN SUPPORT WITH FIVE
THOUSAND FAMILIES IN THE CENTRAL
PART OF THE STATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
BURKE I'M A RESIDENT OF ANTHONY
THIS CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO THE
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER FOR
LIGHT HOME IT'S A COMPANY
DEDICATED TO MANUFACTURING
FOOTBALL HELMETS AND SAFETY HAD
YEAR. FOR OTHER CONTACT SPORTS
AND WE ARE EMPHATICALLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MY NAME IS SARAH SEGAL I AM A
PARENT TO ELEVEN YEAR OLD BOY
WHO IS IN HIS FOURTH YEAR OF
PLAYING FOOTBALL.
AND I AM SUPPORT OF AB
[inaudible]
ONE THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S CHRIS FOR ON
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
COACHES ASSOCIATION.
OUR ASSOCIATION IS IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
BY CITY FOR ME ON A CO FOUNDER
OF THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH FOOTBALL
ALLIANCE ALSO REPRESENTING APPLE
VALLEY YOUTH FOOTBALL OVER FOUR
HUNDRED PLAYERS FROM MY
COMMUNITY NAPA VALLEY CALIFORNIA.
AND I HOPE FOR A YES VOTE ON AB
ONE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
JEFF TAYLOR ATHLETIC DIRECTOR
SOUTHERN MARIN YOUTH FOOTBALL.
PARENTS ARE TO BE FREE TO HAVE
THEIR CHILDREN PLAY THIS SPORT
IF THEY FEELS TO BENEFIT THEM IN
THE LEGISLATURE.
IS IN A POSITION TO MAKE SURE
IT'S DONE SAFELY THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
WELCOME HI MY NAME'S MAKE RAFTER
AND I'M FROM LARGE FOR
CALIFORNIA I HAVE THREE BOYS TWO
OF WHICH PLAY FOOTBALL.
AND WE HOPE YOU SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY OKAY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY COMMON TABLE PLEASE.
MR MEMBERS PAT RAN WITH THEIR
ARENA SOCIO TROUBLING THE
CALIFORNIA CLICK TRAINERS
ASSOCIATION. FOR SOME IS THAT
WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO THE BILL WE
HAVE A SUPPORT IF AMENDED WE
THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL -- WE
SUPPORT ALL BILLS THAT PROMOTE --
THE SAFETY OF ALL ATHLETES
WHETHER THEY'RE YOUTH THEIR
PROFESSIONAL OR OR OR COLLEGIATE.
IN FACT THAT'S WHAT WE DO THE
CALIFORNIA PLAY TRAINERS
ASSOCIATION ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTS THREE THOUSAND
ATHLETIC TRAINERS -- IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHO ARE TRAINED TO SPECIFICALLY
DEAL WITH -- THIS -- POPULATION
OF OF INDIVIDUALS -- THEY WORK
AT THE PROFESSIONAL LEVEL THEY
WORK AND THEY WORK FOR EVERY
PROFESSIONAL TEAM IN THE STATE
THEY WORK AT EVERY COLLEGE -- IN
THE STATE EVERY JUNIOR COLLEGE
THEY WORK IN SOME HIGH SCHOOLS A
WORKING CLINICS THEY WORK FOR
THE NAVY SEALS -- DISNEY.
TESLA FRITO LAY -- IN ALL TYPES
OF SETTINGS -- THIS IS -- THEIR
TRADITIONAL SETTING OF COURSE IS
ON THE ATHLETIC FIELD THE WAY
THE BILL AS DRAFTED [inaudible]
PRECLUDES CERTIFIED ATHLETIC
TRAINERS.
FROM WORKING YOU SPORTS.
GAMES SPECIFICALLY --
SPECIFICALLY SECTION -- ONE TWO
FOUR TWO FOUR ONE EIGHT STATES A
MINIMUM OF ONE OF ONE STATE
LICENSED EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TECHNICIAN PARAMEDIC OR HIGHER
LEVEL LICENSE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONAL.
SHALL BE PRESENT DURING ALL
PRESEASON REGULAR SEASON.
AND POSTSEASON GAMES.
THE PROBLEM WITH US IS IT'S
LICENSED.
AT CERTIFIED ATHLETIC TRAINERS
ARE LICENSED BY THE STATE
UNFORTUNATELY THEY SHOULD BE BUT
THEY'RE NOT -- THIS LANGUAGE
PRECLUDES THEM.
FROM WORKING -- BUT YOU SUPPORT
[inaudible]
GAME.
WE FIND THAT.
IRONIC CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT
THEY CAN WORK FOR EVERY.
PROFESSIONAL TEAM IN THE STATE
EVERY COLLEGE IN THE STATE.
AND HIGH SCHOOLS -- SO OUR WE'RE
SEEKING IS THAT THEY BE ALLOWED
TO WORK THESE AS WELL.
BY EITHER AND YOU KNOW BY
AMENDING THEM IN INTO THE BILL --
THAT IS OUR CONCERN WE THINK
IT'S A GREAT BILL WE HOPE IT
MOVES FORWARD THERE'S NO WAY YOU
KNOW WE'RE NOT HERE TO ASK YOU
TO HOLD THE BILL IN AMENDED OR
ANYTHING WE THINK IT'S A REALLY
GOOD BILL -- IT PROMOTES YOU
SAFETY AND IN SPORTS BUT WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO CUT OUR
MEMBERS OUT FROM WORKING IN A
FIELD.
IN WHICH THEY'RE TRAINED.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION -- QUESTION COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CENTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
SOME WOMEN COOPER THANK YOU FOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I I
PLAYED FOOTBALL AS A YOUNG BOY.
POP WARNER FOOTBALL I PLAYED
JUNIOR HIGH FOOTBALL I PLAYED
HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
EQUIPMENT BACK WHEN I WAS
PLAYING.
WAS PROBABLY MUCH MORE INFERIOR --
THAN THE EQUIPMENT THAT'S BEING
USED TODAY.
ANNA AND I REMEMBER -- THE
TOUGHNESS ESPECIALLY DURING WHAT
WE CALLED HELL WEEK.
AND I REMEMBER SOME OF MY
FRIENDS.
THAT WERE TAKEN SOME PRETTY
TOUGH SHOTS.
AND I REMEMBER A PARTICULAR CASE
WHERE.
A VERY CLOSE FRIEND OF MINE --
GOT A HORRIFIC HEADACHE AFTER --
HIT WAS -- HAD A LITTLE BIT OF
BLURRED VISION HAD A FEVER.
OF COURSE NOBODY RECOGNIZE CITY
HAD A CONCUSSION.
AND WHEN HE WAS COMPLAINING TO
THE COACHES THAT HE NEEDED SOME.
ASSISTANCE -- THEY THEY
CRITICIZED HIM.
STOPPING TOUGH ENOUGH YOU GOT TO
BE TOUGH TO PLAY FOOTBALL YOU
GOT A SUSTAIN -- SOME
DISCOMFORTS TO TO PLAY THE BALL
SO -- I THINK YOU'RE LEGISLATION-IS IS IS GOOD -- I THINK IT'S
GOING TO SAVE SOME SUPPLIES --
SPECIALLY WITH -- IN A COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENT -- IN THE MOST
EXTREME CASE OF PROFESSIONAL
FOOTBALL PLAYERS -- TAKING THEIR
OWN LIVES -- BUT A QUESTION FOR
OUR PROFESSIONAL.
CAN YOU TELL US HOW THE
TECHNOLOGY WITH HELMET --
CONSTRUCTION TODAY IS.
MORE ADVANCED AND DO WE HAVE A
STILL A LONG WAYS TO GO TO A
REALLY BUT FOR THE BRAIN IF YOU
WILL FROM.
SOME OF THESE UNEXPECTED HAD SET
UP ALL THE TRAINING IN THE WORLD
JUST YOU KNOW KINETICS IS
CONNECTICUT'S RIGHT SO -- WHAT
ELSE COULD WE BE DOING TO
PROTECT OUR KIDS?
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION CENTER --
SO COUPLE THINGS -- WHEN I START
WHEN I FIRST STARTED PLAN AS A
CHILD I WERE SUSPENSION ON IT?
TWO STRAPS.
WITH PLASTIC OVER TOP OF IT --
NOT RELEASED TESTED CERTIFIED
STANDARDS WERE ARE THE WILD WILD
WEST -- NOWADAYS THERE'S BEEN
INCREDIBLE ADVANCEMENTS IN THE
TECHNOLOGY OF THE HELMET --
VIRGINIA TECH HAS A FIVE STAR
RATING PROCESS THAT THEY RUN
INDEPENDENT.
AND IN THEIR LABS AND THAT
THAT'S REALLY THE GOLD STANDARD
FOR WHAT HOW MUCH SHOULD BE
PURCHASED OR NOT PURCHASED IT
CETERA -- THEY PUBLISH AT EVERY
YEAR THIS YEAR THEY ANNOUNCED
FOR THE FIRST TIME THEY THEY
ACTUALLY RAN A A CERTIFICATION
PROCESS SPECIFICALLY FOR YOUTH
HELMETS.
FIRST TIME THEY'D EVER DONE THAT
UP UNTIL THEN THEY THEY WERE
DOING IT AT THE VARSITY YEAR
THAT PROFESSIONAL LEVEL -- SO
THERE ARE A LOT TO CHOICES VERY
AFFORDABLE CHOICES -- FOR FOR
FOR FAMILIES -- TO THE BALLOT
TECHNOLOGIES IT'S QUITE ADVANCED --
BUT I ALSO WANT TO COMMENTED THE
HELMET IS THE IS THE LAST POINT
A DEFENSE.
IT'S IT'S REALLY IT'S IT'S IT'S
THE GOAL HERE IS TO EDUCATE
COACHES AND PARENTS EMPLOYERS.
ON HOW TO PLAY TACKLE FOOTBALL
SAFELY.
AND REMOVE THE HEAD FROM PLAYING
AND YOU DO THAT BY TEACHING
TECHNIQUES.
BLOCKING DEFEATING THE BLOCK
TACKLING TECHNIQUES THAT
MINIMIZE THE HEAD IMPLY.
RIGHT TO THE HELMETS TO HELMETS
GOTTEN A LOT BETTER AND IT'S NOT
WE'RE NOT COACHING OR TEACHING
THINGS LIKE DON'T WORRY YOU CAN
RUN HARDER IN THE END INTO
THINGS BECAUSE OF A BETTER
HELMET.
THE HELMET IS A LAYER OF
PROTECTION AND RELEASE IN
EDUCATION AWARENESS A CULTURAL
SHIFT THEY WERE DRIVING --
ACROSS CALIFORNIA -- THIS IS
REALLY GOING TO IT'S A
COMBINATION OF THOSE TWO PLUS
FOR STATE THINGS LIKE THAT THAT
REALLY GOING TO ARE GOING.
TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS OF THE ALSO --
ADDRESSING THE THE FACE CARDS --
WHAT WHEN I WAS PLAYING I WAS A
SPLIT AND SO I HAD JUST
BASICALLY A VERY SMALL FACE CARD
AND?
I ACTUALLY HAD A SIGNIFICANT
INJURY WERE -- I WAS A DEFENSIVE
AND IT HAD MADE A TACKLE AND
ENDED UP CRASHING THE RIGHT SIDE
OF THE CARTILAGE OF MY NOSE TO
POINT WHERE WAS FLAT AND I
ACTUALLY HAD TO GO IN.
FOR SURGERY TO HAVE IT FIXED NOW
THAT COULD'VE BEEN MUCH MORE
SERIOUS IF I WOULD TAKE A MORE
FRONTAL -- HIT AND IT WOULD HAVE.
LODGED INTO THE THE BRAIN OR OR
THE A MORE SERIOUS INJURY ALL
TOGETHER WITH THE BONE BUT I'M
HOPING THAT THEY'RE ALSO TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION THE THE THE
FACIAL EXPOSURE.
AND ENSURING THAT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PROTECT
THEIR THEIR FACIAL INTEGRITY AND
SENSITIVITY OF THOSE AREAS AS
WELL YES SO -- FACE MASKS ARE
THE COOL THING ON THE FOOTBALL
FIELD.
LOTS OF CHOICES LOTS A DIFFERENT
FACE MASTER.
ON HELMETS -- AND THE OTHER
THING I WOULD SAY IS THAT YOU
KNOW THERE'S THERE'S NEW
THERE REALLY LIGHT HELMETS.
RIGHT SO YOU CAN GET A FIVE STAR
RATING OF FOUR POUNDS YOU CAN
GET A FIVE STAR RATING HELMET
TWO POINT FOUR POUNDS RIGHT SO
THERE'S LOTS OF AFFORDABLE
CHOICES GREAT TECHNOLOGY THAT.
INCLUDING.
BALANCING AND CHANGING THE FACE
MASK TO BALANCE THE WEIGHT SO
THAT -- IT RESTS ON THE HEAD AS
AS EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE --
WITH ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT
CONFIGURATIONS OF THE FACE MASK
THAT GUARD THE ICE AS WELL AS
WELL AS CLEAR SHIELDS.
IN THURSDAY AND HAVE THESE WHEN
YOU AND I WERE PLAN BUT SHIELDS
YOU CAN GET FOR A LOT OF RUNNING
BACKS AND DEFENSIVE LINEMAN WILL
GET.
A CLEAR SHIELD.
SO THAT YOU CAN STILL SEE THE
EYES FROM A SAFETY PERSPECTIVE
BUT ELIMINATES.
ABOUT WHAT SOUNDS B. LIKE THE
INJURY THE U. SUSTAINED I KNOW
YOU AND I TALKED BEFORE AND I I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR PASSION
AND HELPING US GET HERE TODAY
AND I APPRECIATE.
THAT SOME WOMEN COOPER IS
CARRIED THE LEGISLATION THAT I
KNOW IS GOING -- TO EFFECTUALLY
BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE TO MAKE
THE SAVE THE SPORT A LOT SAFER
FOR OUR YOUNG KIDS.
TO PARTICIPATE IN AND HAVING TO
MOVE IT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
I THANK YOU I JUST COULDN'T MAKE
IT BRIEF PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENT WITH HER NEXT
QUESTION IS THAT FOR THE STAFF
WERE WATCHING WE ARE ONLY ONE
MEMBER SHORT OF A QUORUM SO I
KNOW MANY PEOPLE ARE AT OTHER
COMMITTEES BUT IF YOU HAVE THIS.
YEAR'S YOUR MEMBER HAPPENS TO BE
AVAILABLE PLEASE AND IN DOWN
HERE SO WITH THAT -- SIR
MITCHELL.
YOU ARE I'M CURIOUS -- THE
WITNESS TALKED ABOUT CULTURE
SHIFT AND IT'S CLEARLY GONNA
REQUIRE CULTURE CHEF I SUPPORTED.
A MORE AGGRESSIVE -- A BILL LAST
YEAR BUT MY MY QUESTION IS --
DOES THE BILL HAVE ANY TEETH IN
IT HOW ARE YOU GOING -- TO MAKE
SURE THAT IN IN IN IN THAT
INDEED PRACTICES ARE LIMITED TO
THIRTY MINUTES A DAY AND NO MORE
THAN TWO TIMES A WEEK WHAT
WHAT'S THE CONSEQUENCE.
IF THEY EXCEED THAT I WORK WITH
FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED COMPANIES
ALL OVER THE WORLD I WORKED ON
FIVE CONTINENTS IN HELPING THEM
RESPOND TO BUSINESS MODEL SHIPS.
DRIVE CULTURE CHANGE --
STRUCTURAL CHANGE LEADERSHIP
DYNAMICS ALL THAT -- FUN STUFF --
OUR BILL IS MODELED AFTER THREE
PREVIOUS BILLS -- AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY SEVEN WHICH THE COOLEY
ACT LIMITED FULL CONTACT IN HIGH
SCHOOL FOOTBALL.
AB TWO THOUSAND SEVEN WHICH WAS
CALIFORNIA'S VERSION OF ALLY
STATE LAW WHICH MANDATED
CONCUSSION EDUCATION AND AND
FACT SHEETS.
AND AB TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU WHICH WHICH
BASICALLY PROVIDED THE SAME
MANDATES AROUND HE ACCLAMATION.
TO OUR THERE THERE THERE IS NO --
PUNITIVE CLAUSE OR THINGS LIKE
THAT AND IN OUR BILL -- WE
MODELED EVANS WHEN PEOPLE EXCEED
THE THIRTY MINUTE PRACTICES IN
PRACTICE MORE THAN TWO TIMES A
WEEK SO.
THAT'S GOING TO BE -- THE
PARENTS.
WE HAVE AN INNOVATIVE DESIGN IN
OUR BILL.
THAT IS THAT EXCEEDS THE OF THE
THE PREVIOUS BILLS STANDARDS
AROUND OVERSIGHT AND THAT
INNOVATIVE STANDARD IS EACH
ORGANIZATION CALIFORNIA THAT
RUNS A FOOTBALL PROGRAM IS GOING
TO HAVE -- TO PUBLISH THEIR
COMMITMENT AB ONE THAT THEY ARE
COMPLYING WITH AB.
ONE WE'RE CREATING HEALTHY
TENSION THE MARKET.
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPETITION FOR
PLAYERS.
AND SO BY CREATING THIS HEALTHY
TENSION BY PUBLISHING ARE YOU AB
ONE A COMPLIANT OR NOT.
PARENTS OWN RESPONSIBILITY TO
TAKE PUT THEIR KIDS IN THE
SAFEST POSSIBLE SITUATION.
AND THE PARENTS ARE GONNA THEN
CHOOSE I'M GONNA GO WITH A BEAK
ARE COMPLIANT ONE PROGRAM ON
THIS SIDE OF THE STREET BECAUSE
ONE OF THE OTHER SIDE OF STREET.
IS IN COMPLIANCE AND WHAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN IS THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DON'T STEP
INTO SAFETY FROM A SECURITY
PERSPECTIVE THEY'RE GONNA WITHER
AND DIE.
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT GONNA HAVE
THE PLAYERS.
THANK YOU THE ICE NOTE THAT WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO SURGERY CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL HAND.
AND IS HERE STONE.
STONE HERE GONZALEZ GROVE.
GROWTH HERE HER TATO HER TITLE
HERE LEYVA LEYVA HERE MITCHELL
MITCHELL HERE MONNING RUBIO.
HEY WE HAVE A QUORUM OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
WITH THE BILL OKAY IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER SO SO -- COOPER
FIRST OF ALL I WANT I DO WANNA
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FORWARD
THIS BILL AND I KNOW THAT THIS.
IS THAT WHEN THE SWIMMING THIS
BILL PASSES -- THAT TO IT WILL
SET YOU KNOW -- STANDARDS THAT
BEYOND THAT BASICALLY SO.
PLACE CALIFORNIA LEADERSHIP ROLE
IN TERMS OF STANDARDS AROUND THE
YOUTH FOOTBALL -- A IS THAT I
WOULD WANT TO PUT A PERHAPS --
ONE CAT THE ODD WHICH IS IS THAT
EVEN THOUGH THESE WILL BE -- THE
LEADING STANDARDS I THINK IT'S
STILL IMPORTANT TO BECAUSE I
THINK WE STILL HAVE INCOMPLETE
INFORMATION ABOUT -- WHAT'S THE
LONG TERM IMPACTS OF YOU KNOW
I'M TALKING TO YOUNG PEOPLE.
IT WHO ARE PARTICIPATING IN A
CONTACT SPORT WHERE THEY MAY
DEVELOP INJURIES I APPRECIATE
THAT THERE WERE TALKING ABOUT
CULTURE CHANGE I'D REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THERE
WAS CONVERSATION ABOUT.
HOW THE HELMET IS REALLY THE
LAST TO LATER OF PROTECTION THAT
ACTUALLY THE FIRST THING IS WE?
KEEP THE HEAD OUT OF PLAY THAT'S
I THINK A VERY IMPORTANT THING
AND AND CERTAINLY ONE ALSO
RECOGNIZE WE HEARD FROM MANY OF
THE SUPPORTERS THE BENEFITS NOW
WE DON'T LIKE NOR THE BENEFITS
OF PARTICIPATING IN TEAM SPORT
PARTICIPATE IN FOOTBALL THE
MOTIVATION IT GIVES MANY USE AND
SO.
FORTH AND THE LESSONS THEY
LEARNED FROM FOOTBALL ITSELF --
BUT SO JUST TWICE A IS THAT IT'S
STILL IMPORTANT EVEN WITH THIS
BILL AND I APPRECIATE AGAIN THIS
IS A FORD BUT LOOKING BILL THAT
WE ALSO INSURE THAT WE HAVE --
THEY'LL CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE
HEALTH OF THESE -- THESE
CHILDREN AS THEY GROW UP AND IF
THERE'S FOR THE END OF THIS.
THERE'S FURTHER STEPS NEED TO BE
TAKEN TO PROTECT THEIR HEALTH
AND THAT -- WE STILL NEED TO BE
OPEN TO THAT SO.
I GUESS THE OTHER ISSUE I DID
WHY ASK ME QUESTION ABOUT WILL
WE DID HERE FOR THE OPPOSITION
FROM THE CATHOLIC TRAINERS OF
TWEENER FROM THAT THANK TRAINERS --
DIETERS IN WHAT THEY WHAT THEY
WANT TO BE INCLUDED THAT LESS
BUT WITH THIS BILL ACTUALLY
PRECLUDE ATHLETIC TRAINERS FROM
ACTUALLY BEING AT PRACTICE
THAT'S NOT HOW I READ THE BILL
BUT MAYBE YOU CAN CLEAR -- THAT
ISSUE -- IN TERMS OF THE ROLE OF
ATHLETIC TRAINERS AND USE OF ALL
THAT WAS BROUGHT BY THE
OPPOSITION.
PARTY WIENER I SHOULD SAY NOT
REALLY OPPOSITION IF I MAY STOP
THE PRACTICE AT C. ISSUE IT'S
THE GAME -- AT WHEN THEY SAY
SOMEONE HAS TO BE PRESENT AT THE
GAME IT'S A LICENSED -- RIGHT
INTENTIONALLY AT PRACTICE IS
SOMEONE WHO HAS FIVE OR SIX
HOURS OF TRAINING -- WISH IF
THAT OKAY OKAY WITH YOU BUT THAT
OKAY WELL I'M I DECIDE SO I DID
TO STAFF.
THE AUTHOR IS TO TRY AND REDUCE
YOUR DOCTOR PAN I'D READ THAT
WAY EITHER I WAS NOT AWARE OF
THEIR CONCERNS PLAY THIS MORNING
WE HAD HEARD FROM THEM.
AND THE SKILLS INTRODUCED BACK
IN DECEMBER SO IS THE FIRST I'VE
HEARD I WON'T HAVE DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE MISTER MORAN.
TO CONCERNS OKAY SELVES SO WILL
THE THE THE THE V. SOME FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THAT AND AGAIN
APPRECIATE WE TRIED TO THE BILL.
OKAY SO THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED NO
OTHER COMMENTS -- ITS BID THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SO I GUESS
GOES STRAIGHT TO THE FLOOR IS
THE NEXT STEP.
OKAY WELCOME AND I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY ONE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS.
IF YOU WANT TO START BY THANKING
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE AND THE SPONSOR.
I'M SUBMITTING AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT PHYSICIANS.
HAS DETERMINED THE PATIENT IS
STABLE AND APPROPRIATE FOR
TRANSFERRED TO THE PSYCHIATRIC
FACILITY.
AND THIS IS NOTED IN THE
PATIENT'S MEDICAL RECORD.
THESE A MAN'S ALSO CLARIFIED
THAT THE RECEIVING FACILITY HAS
AN AVAILABLE BED.
AND ADDS PSYCHIATRIC HELP
FACILITIES TO AN EXISTING
PROVISION OF A LAW PROHIBITING
THE RECEIVING FACILITY FROM
REQUIRING A PATIENT. TO BE ON A
FIFTY ONE FIFTY HOLD IF THEY ARE
VOLUNTARILY SEEKING PSYCHIATRIC
TREATMENT.
AB FOR FIFTY ONE WAS INTRODUCED
TO HELP AN INDIVIDUAL
EXPERIENCING.
AN EMERGENT MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
OBTAINS ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE
AND TIMELY CARE.
M. TALL -- WHICH WAS THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TREATMENT AND
ACTIVE LABOR ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE IS A FEDERAL LAW
THAT REQUIRES HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS TO MEDICALLY SCREEN
EVERY PATIENT TO SIX EMERGENCY
CARE.
AND TO STABILIZE FOR TRANSFER
THOSE WITH MEDICAL EMERGENCIES
REGARDLESS OF THEIR HEALTH
INSURANCE STATUS OR ABILITY TO
PAY.
FEDERAL LAW IMPOSES THIS
REQUIREMENT ON ANY HOSPITAL THAT
PARTICIPATES IN MEDICARE.
WE ALSO HAVE STATE AND TALLER.
THAT IMPOSES THIS REQUIREMENT ON
ANY HOSPITAL THAT OPERATES AN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
INDIVIDUALS AND A ENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS MAY SEEK CARE AT THE
NEAREST EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
AFTER AN EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
AFTER A VISIT.
BY PHYSICIANS JUST LIKE ME.
WE SEE INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY NEED
HIGHER LEVEL OF PSYCHIATRIC
SERVICES AND REQUIRE A
TRANSFERRED TO A PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITAL.
HOWEVER MERGING SEE POSITIONS
HAVE EXPERIENCED TROUBLE
TRANSFERRING PATIENTS TO
PSYCHIATRIC PERSONAL FACILITIES.
THAT DO NOT HAVE AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT.
THERE IS A CONCERN.
THAT SOME PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS
ARE USING LANGUAGE IN CURRENT
LAW.
WHICH ONLY APPLIES TO CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS THAT MAINTAIN AND
OPERATE AN EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
AS A WAY TO NOT ACCEPT ALL
PATIENTS.
THIS IS SOMETHING I'VE SEEN
FIRST HAND.
AND WHEN YOU'RE SEEING SOMEONE
WHO'S IN A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
RIGHT THERE IN FRONT OF YOU.
I THINK WE HAVE TO HELP TO SOLVE
THOSE PROBLEMS HERE TODAY.
AND THAT'S WHAT I BELIEVE THIS
BILL DOES.
BECAUSE OF PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS
AVOID TAKING PATIENTS IT LIMITS
ACCESS. TO CARE AND REDUCES
CAPACITY OF ALREADY SCARCE
RESOURCES.
THESE BEDS SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
TO ALL PATIENTS FACING A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS.
REGARDLESS OF AN INDIVIDUAL'S
INSURANCE STATUS OR ABILITY TO
PAY.
AB FOR FIFTY ONE REMOVES
BARRIERS AND CURRENT LAW SO AN
INDIVIDUAL WITH A MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION HAS TIMELY ACCESS TO
ADDITIONAL CARE AND SERVICES
THAT MAY BE NEEDED.
IT REQUIRES.
ONE PSYCHIATRIC UNITS WITH A
GENERAL ACUTE CARE HOSPITAL.
TO PSYCHIATRIC HEALTH FACILITIES
AND THREE ACUTE PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALS REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
IT MAINTAINS AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND CARE TO TREAT A
PERSON WITH THE PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CONDITION.
IF THEY THE TREATING PHYSICIAN
HAS DETERMINED THAT THE PATIENT
IS MEDICALLY STABLE FOR TRANSFER.
THAT THE FACILITY HAS AN
AVAILABLE BEDAND THAT THE
FACILITY HAS APPROPRIATE
FACILITIES AND QUALIFIED
PERSONNEL AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES OF CARE.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOR FIFTY ONE IS TO MATT AND
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS.
THANK YOU WITNESSES SUPPORT.
DOCTOR MEMBERS TO MADDEN REPS IN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THE MIRACLES
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS WE ARE THE
SPONSOR I THINK DOCTOR IN REAL --
EFFICIENTLY EFFECTIVELY OUTLINED
THE ISSUE THAT WE'RE RUNNING
INTO ON A SOMEWHAT REGULAR BASIS
I'LL MAKE MYSELF AVAILABLE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR IVAN.
OKAY THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES A
SUPPORT NAME ORGANIZATION OF
POSITION BACK MICROPHONE.
MORE SECONDS ALSO ME HALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS WE STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DANNY OFFER FROM PLASMIN VISORS
REPRESENT A NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON
MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO KNOWN AS
NAMI CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GENERALLY THE SIGN BURKE
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HEY ARE THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THIS COMMENT TO THE TABLE
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
TYLER IN THE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION -- FIRST OF ALL I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE ON AUTHORS
STAFF AND THE ON CHAIR AND CHAIR
STAFF TO FOR WORKING US ON NAM
ADDRESSING SOME OF OUR CONCERNS
ON THE BILL.
HOWEVER UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE
BEEN OPPOSING WHITES AMENDED
STILL ON THIS BILL -- THIS BILL
HAS GOOD INTENTIONS BUT SOME
SIGNIFICAN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN THE WAY THAT RE
READ IT -- BY AND REQUIRING
FACILITIES TO ACCEPT PSYCHIATRIC
PATIENTS EXPERIENCING A
PSYCHIATRIC CRISIS WITHOUT
CONSIDERATION OF ESTABLISH
COUNTY OR NETWORKS -- THIS WILL
CREATE SIGNIFICANT -- CARE
COORDINATION ISSUES TRANSFER
INTO VISUALS WITH THE NEXT
SERIOUS TURN ACUTE MENTAL
ILLNESS IN CRISIS OUTSIDE OF
COUNTY OR NETWORK.
CAN STREAM AT THE COORDINATION
OF TREATMENT WITH THE FAMILY AND
LOVED ONES CAN THE INCLUSION OF
THE OUTPATIENT CURRENT
OUTPATIENT PROVIDER.
AND THEN CREATES DIFFICULTY IN
TRANSFERRING THAT INDIVIDUAL
BACK TO THEIR COUNTY OR THEIR
PLACE OF RESIDENCE AT THE END OF
THEIR TREATMENT.
WITH ADDITIONALLY THIS
LEGISLATION AND I READ TO
CIRCUMVENT SETS A VERY CRITICAL
PART -- PSYCHIATRIC CARE IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED WITH THE INVESTMENT
A MENTAL HEALTH WELLNESS ACTIVE
TWENTY THIRTEEN CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNITS.
AND BY REQUIRING AN INDIVIDUAL
TO BE ACCEPTED FROM A IN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS WITHOUT
GOING TO A CRISIS STABILIZATION
UNIT.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS
CIRCUMVENTING A VERY CRITICAL --
PART OF THAT CARE CONTINUE.
ONE AND THAT CRISIS
STABILIZATION UNITS HAVE PROVIDE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN CARE TO
INDIVIDUALS IN CRISIS AND THAT
THEY HAVE REDUCE TOPS BUT
REALIZATION.
THEY REDUCE LAW ENFORCEMENT
CONTACT AND SAVES LIVES SO FOR
THESE REASONS WE REMAIN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED ON THIS
LEGISLATION AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AND LOOK FORWARD
TO HAVING CONTINUE DISCUSSION
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
XENON QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
TADO -- SO -- THE SUMMER RANDALL
I WANT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD -- ME PERHAPS
YOU WISH TO CAN YOU RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS EXPRESSED
BY THE THE OPPOSITION -- I SAT
DOWN WITH C. B. H. D. A. AND
SPOKE I BELIEVE WITH KERN
COUNTIES -- BEHAVIORAL HEALTH --
DIRECTOR AND I RECOGNIZE THAT
INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES MAY BE
EXCEEDING -- HOW THEY ARE
PROVIDING CARE BUT FOR THE VAST
MAJORITY OF COUNTIES THEY'RE NOT?
AND THE WAY FOR US TO CORRECT
THIS AS A STATUS TO DEAL WITH
THE CORE ISSUE WHICH IS STATE
I'M TALLER.
AND HOW WE MAKE SURE THAT IT
MATCHES FEDERAL IN TALLINN BRING
PARITY TO THIS.
I BELIEVE IF THESE WERE ANY
OTHER PATIENTS BUT MENTAL HEALTH
PATIENTS THIS WOULD ALREADY BE
SOLVED.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO TREAT THEM AS EVERY OTHER
PATIENT GETS TREATED AN
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CONDITION.
OKAY THANK YOU -- SO -- I I
WOULD NATIONALLY I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS ARE RATE
BY THE EVER HEALTH DIRECTORS --
AYE I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE AGAIN
WE'RE TALKING MEMBER JUST SEE
SITUATIONS -- SO I'D HEARD
SHELVE FURTHER DIALOGUE BUT I
THINK WE YOU KNOW I THINK
FUNDAMENTALLY THE ISSUE IS ABOUT.
HIS EMERGENCY SITUATIONS BE SURE
PEOPLE ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
CARE I'VE SEEN YOU KNOW PEOPLE
PILED UP IN EMERGENCY ROOMS.
TO NOT GETTING TO MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT THEY NEED BECAUSE
THERE'S NO PLACE FOR THEM TO GO
AND AND THE SO WE NEED TO FEET
FACILITATE -- THEM GETTING CARE
WITH THAT SO -- WITH THAT -- DID
YOU HAVE ANY FOR THE CLOTHES.
WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE OKAY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO IT'S BEEN
MOVED THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED RE -- REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS --
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND
I AND I STONE.
STONE AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
GROVE GROVE I HER TAUGHT IN OUR
TOTAL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA HI MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE
MONNING MONNING HI RUBIO
[inaudible] EIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER GILL AS EIGHT VOTES
THAT'S ENOUGH TO GET OUT THE
VOTE ON THE ROLE FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU -- I THINK WE ARE IN
FILE ORDER SO I THINK THE NEXT
ONE UP IS -- ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY
EIGHTY FIVE SIX AND BY CENTER
CALDERON -- BECAUSE I THINK --
SUMMER RIVAS YOUR BILLS A LITTLE
LATER SO.
WELCOME I KNOW SHE'S YOU PUT
YOUR YOUR FIRST OKAY.
NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY
SEVEN THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS HAPPY TO BE HERE TO
PRESENT AB. FIVE SIXTY SEVEN
WHICH ESTABLISHES A LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE TASK FORCE
CONVENED BY THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER COMMISSIONER THE
PURPOSES TO THROUGHOUT THE TASK
FORCE IS TO PROVIDE EXPERT
RECOMMENDATIONS.
ON THE COMPONENTS NECESSARY TO
ESTABLISH A STATE WIDE LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE.
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE CREATING IS AT THE TASK
FORCING LET LAST ABOUT TWO YEARS.
TO FIGURE OUT IF IT'S-APPROPRIATE FOR US TO CONSIDER A
PUBLIC OPTION WHEN IT COMES A
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE.
LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE COSTS
CONTINUE TO SKYROCKET BECAUSE
THE LACK OF PROVIDERS WHO USED
TO BE OVER A HUNDRED PROVIDERS
OF LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE.
CROSS COUNTRY NOW WE'RE CLOSER
TO TEN TO TWELVE PROVIDERS
THAT'S BECAUSE COSTS TO GO -- I
WORK ON THIS ISSUE FOR A LOT OF
DIFFERENT REASONS A BIG REASON
IS THAT I'M A MILLENNIAL.
IT WAS MY FAMILY THAT -- MY
PARENTS WENT THROUGH THIS
RECESSION IN A WAY THAT IMPACTED
IT'S GONNA HAVE A LONG TERM
IMPACT ON ME AND MY FROM MY
GENERATION I THINK ON ALL THIS
BUT SPECIFICALLY ON MY
GENERATION.
AND THAT IMPACT IS GOING TO BE
IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW MY MOM MY
STEP DAD WAS STARTING A BUSINESS
RIGHT WHEN THE ECONOMY WENT DOWN.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW LONG WAS
GOING TO BE THEY PUT ALL OF
THEIR RETIREMENT ALL OF THEIR
SAVINGS ABSOLUTELY EVERY SINGLE
PENNY AND TO KEEP IN THE
BUSINESS ALIVE.
THEY COULDN'T DO A LONG ENOUGH
TO NOT ONLY DID THEY LOSE ALL
THEIR RETIREMENT ALL THAT
RETIREMENT SECURITY THEY ALSO
LOST THEIR HOME.
SO YOU KNOW IF SOMETHING WERE TO
HAPPEN YEAH MY STEP DAD HE'S
GONNA BE WORKING THE DAY HE DIES
AND MY MOM.
SOMETHINGHAPPENS -- FALLS ON ME
AND MY MY SIBLINGS TO PICK UP
THAT.
OF RESPONSIBILITY WHICH WE
GLADLY WILL DO BUT IT'S IT'S
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT.
IN THE EVENT THAT -- YOU KNOW
THOSE CAN AFFORD SOME TYPE OF
INSURANCE TO PREPARE FOR ANY
ISSUES THAT COULD ARISE LATER ON
IN LIFE.
OF THEIR NEEDS TO BE AN
AFFORDABLE OPTION I THINK IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON US AT LEAST KNOW
WHAT WE'RE WALKING INTO.
AND THAT THERE BE SOME RESEARCH
IN TERMS OF ESTABLISHING A
PUBLIC OPTION ON I KNOW YOU'RE
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE SENATOR
PAN HERE'S MORE LONG TERM.
AND WE'RE THIS IS SHORT TERM AND
AND AND JUST FIGURING OUT THE
VIABILITY OF A OF A OF A PUBLIC
OPTION SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
IS ON WAR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
I THANK YOU WELCOME THE FIRST IS
A SPORT.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS --
AND MISTER CHAIR AS í
THE COMPANY'S GOING PLACES
ASSOCIATION AND I AM HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB -- FIVE
SIXTY SEVEN WE KNOW TRAGEDY CAN
STRIKE AT ANYTIME AND ANYBODY
CAN FIND THEMSELVES NEEDING LONG
TERM CARE -- WHICH CAN BE
DEVASTATING FINANCIALLY SO THE
LACK OF AN AFFORDABLE OPTION FOR
LONG TERM CARE IT'S A BIG
CONCERN FOR MY MEMBERS WHO ARE
AT THE LOWEST WORKERS ON IN OUR
SCHOOLS.
ON AVERAGE A FULL TIME
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE EARNS TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR AND
A PART TIME EMPLOYEE EARNS JUST
THIRTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR --
THE MAJORITY OF MY MEMBERS ARE
PART TIME EMPLOYEES AND SOME OF
THEM MUST WORK TWO THREE JOBS
JUST TO GET BY DATE. FIVE DAY
TODAY -- AFTER PAYING FOR THEIR
BASIC NECESSITIES A LONG TERM
CARE IS LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
IS SIMPLY NOT AN OPTION OR ARE
OUT OF REACH FOR MOST ABOUT.
ALSO -- MANY OF THEM JUST
ASSUMED THAT LONG TERM CARE IS
PART OF THE NORMAL HEALTH
INSURANCE THAT THE A MAY HAVE.
SO IT'S UNTIL THEY NEEDED THAT
THEY REALIZE IT'S NOT PART OF
THE REGULAR HEALTH INSURANCE AND
THEN THAT'S ALSO THE TIME IN
WHICH THEY LEARN HOW EXPENSIVE
LONG TERM CARE CAN BE -- IT'S
NOT UNCOMMON FOR LONG TERM CARE
TO COST UP TO SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH OR EVEN MORE AND
MANY.
MANY PEOPLE CANNOT AFFORD THIS
PRICE -- SO THEY END UP HAVING
TO USE A THEIR SAVINGS OR
DEPLETE ANY ASSETS THAT THEY
HAVE -- OTHER PEOPLE HAVE TO
RELY ON FAMILIES AND THE STATE.
TO TAKE CARE OF THEM.
HELLO IF THIS HAPPENS SO WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE SYSTEM IS
BROKEN AND THE THIS NEEDS TO BE
FIXED AND SO AB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN
IS THE FIRST AND NECESSARY STEP
IN ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE.
SO WE ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITH THIS IS A
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN PAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ON GEHRY PASSED
MORE FROM THE CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
WE BELIEVE IT COULD BE
CONSISTENT WITH YOUR BILL AS
WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
A GEORGE CANARY WAS SIX BEDS
REPRESENTING SMALL RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE THE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY AS A MOTION BY A CENTER
LEYVA.
CENA QUESTIONS CAN BE MEMBERS --
AT THAT NO IT'S NOT THANK YOU
SUMMER CALDERON FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD CLEARLY YOU
KNOW ACCESS TO LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE IS A CHALLENGE THE
MARKET ESSENTIALLY IS -- YOU
KNOW THIS.
WAS A NONEXISTENT BUT
ESSENTIALLY HAS -- HAS BEEN WITH
THE WAY WE NEED TO FIGHT FIGURE
OUT A BETTER APPROACH TO THIS
SAY I APPRECIATE THAT.
WHAT YOU'RE DOING THIS WHICH
SCORES MATCHES SOME THE
LEGISLATION I'M DOING AS WELL
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE THE SORT
THE LONGER TERM LARGER PICTURE
BUT WE NEED ALL THE PIECES
TOGETHER -- SO -- CERTAINLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL -- WHICH
LIKE THE CLOTHES THANK YOU
MEMBERS APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO THE
MOTIONS TO PASS REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
A SEPARATE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND I AND I STONE.
STONE NO GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I AM
GROW.
GROW BY HER TADO.
A TOTAL AYE LEYVA LABOR HI
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE RUBIO.
HI SEVEN ONE SO YOU HAVE SEVEN
THE VOTES CURRENTLY SEVEN ONE
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OF CONTRACTS
AND NUMBER THANK YOU.
SEE IS NEXT.
YEAH OKAY SO -- BLOOM YOUR NEXT
UP AND FOLLOW ORDER THAT YOU
SHOULD THE FURTHER THAN THAT
SOME MEMBERS.
GRAY.
WE DO GO FILE ORDER BUT WE'LL GO
AHEAD SO ITEM NUMBER.
TEN EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTY THREE
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS.
THANK YOU THE STAFF THAT WORK ON
THE BILL ALL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED TACTICAL
MOMENTS.
AB SEVEN SIX THREE MEMBERS
SIMPLE BILL THAT WILL.
INCREASE ACCESS TO SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN THE MEDICARE PROGRAM BY
STANDARDIZED FORMS COUNTIES
REQUIRE CONTRACTING PROVIDERS TO
USE THIS ALLOWS DOCSIS SPEND
LESS TIME DOING PAPERWORK AND
MORE TIME HELPING CHILDREN.
I HAVE ONE OF THE BEST
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS IN THE
COUNTRY -- RIGHT OUTSIDE OF MY
DISTRICT AND THAT'S HOW THIS
BILL CAME TO MY ATTENTION
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE BUT
WE HAVE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
YOU THAT SOME AWARENESS SUPPORT
THANK YOU MAYOR MARTIN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
INCLUDING DALY CHILDREN OUTSIDE
OF THE MEMBERS DISTRICT.
AND AND ALL OF OUR MEMBER
HOSPITALS HAVE CONTRACTS WITH
COUNTIES TO PROVIDE SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
CHILDREN IN THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM
AND WHEN WE STARTED REACHING OUT
TO THOSE FOLKS LAST YEAR TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT WHAT THEY
NEEDED.
IN THE PAPER ALL SPACE THE
PAPERWORK BURDEN ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT WORK QUICKLY ROSE TO THE
TOP OF THEIR LIST OF CONCERNS
THEY INDICATED THEY THOUGHT IT
TOOK ABOUT 4250% FOR OTHER
PROVIDERS TIME JUST TO FILL OUT
THE PAPERWORK ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS CARE.
BUT IT WAS ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS THAT THEY LOSE
PSYCHIATRISTS AND PSYCHOLOGISTS
ADD TO THIS WORK TO OTHER
RESOURCES -- AND A LOT OF THAT
IS JUST BECAUSE THERE'S SO MUCH
VARIATION AMONGST THE DIFFERENT
COUNTY SO YOU HAVE FIFTY SIX
DIFFERENT SETS OF COUNTY
PAPERWORK.
MOST OF OUR HOSPITALS WORK WITH
MORE THAN ONE COUNTY NOT
PAPERWORK EVEN FOR THE INTAKE
PACKET CAN RANGE FROM SIX OR
SEVEN PAGES UP INTO TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE PAGES -- AND OFTEN
IT'S NOT ELECTRONICS SO THEY
HAVE TO FILL IT OUT BY HAND --
AND BASICALLY THEY SAID IF WE
COULD JUST FIX THE PAPERWORK
PROBLEM WE COULD SEE 30% MORE
KIDS AND THAT KIND OF BLEW MY
MIND -- AND AT THAT POINT WE
SAID LET'S SEE IF WE CAN DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS AND WE WERE
GRATEFUL TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR TAKING THE ISSUE ON I THINK
ALSO I WOULD JUST ADD THAT NOT
ONLY IS IT ABOUT THE BURDEN OF
THE PAPER WORK BUT WE HAVE
ACTUALLY.
HEARD THAT A LOT OF THE
PAPERWORK DOES NOT NECESSARILY
INCLUDE THE APPROPRIATE STANDARD
FOR MEDICAL NECESSITY AND IT
IMPOSES ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS
THAT MIGHT CREATE.
INAPPROPRIATE BARRIERS TO CARE
THAT CHILDREN ARE OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE AND SO WE
THINK THAT AB SEVEN SIXTY THREE
WILL HELP ADDRESS ALL OF THOSE
ISSUES AND WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES REPORT
BACK MICROPHONE.
THAN FLORI ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
GIVEN THE MLA CALIFORNIA LINES
OF CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON WEST ON BEHALF OF
A SPEAR NET IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
GIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHECK THOMAS WITH
SENECA FAMILY OF AGENCIES WE'RE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IF AN ENEMY DOES NOT SEND OUR
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE LADEN WITH
THE CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED PEDIATRIC
SUB SPECIALIST IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
UNDER CLICK HARVEY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TURN MEMBERS
CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS WE HAVE A
CLARIFYING QUESTION BUT THE BILL
IS DEFINITELY MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
OKAY THANK YOU.
RIGHT BUT ANYWAY THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION.
WITHOUT SAYING NONE THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED THIRTY QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT SEEN NINE NIGHTS THE
THE THE REGRADE THANK YOU FOR
ANY BRING THIS BILL FORD
CERTAINLY TRYING TO SIMPLIFY THE
OVERHEAD AND PAPERWORK SO THAT
KIDS CAN GET ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH AND THAT 30% TO REALLY
HUGE NUMBER CELL.
WHICH LIKE THE CLOTHES.
CHECK FASTER AYE VOTE OKAY THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT SO THE MOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AM I AYE STONE STONE ON A
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROW.
GROVE EYEING HER TADO.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
RUBIO.
THE BILL HAS SEVEN VOTES SAID
IT'S ENOUGH TO GET IT OUT WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR THANK
CENTERS THANK YOU.
CENTER BLOOM WELCOME.
SO WE HAVE. FOR YOU -- ITEM
NUMBER
.
NINE EIGHTY FIVE NINETY EIGHT
AFTER ALL THESE SET PARENTS AND
CHILDREN TESTIFIED IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL IT'LL GET NOTICEABLY
QUIETER IN THE HEARING ROOM
MISTER CHAIR.
BUT I WANT TO UPDATE YOU ALL A
GOOD AFTERNOON AND TO FOR START
OUT BY YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING
SO HARD WITH MYSELF AND MY STAFF
ON A SERIES OF AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKING ALL OF THOSE AMENDMENTS
SO I IMAGINE I'LL BE TAKEN IN
THAT.
IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE -- AS A
MATTER OF FORMALITY -- BUT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT A CHILD'S ABILITY
TO HEAR -- AND THAT SHOULD NOT
BE I'M SURE WE ALL AGREE
DETERMINED BY ONE'S FAMILY
INCOME YET HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES
THAT HAVE TO PAY FOR THEIR
CHILD'S HEARING AIDS OUT OF
POCKET OR SIMPLY HAVE TO FOREGO
THE MALL TOGETHER.
AB FIVE NINETY EIGHT ADDRESSES
THIS GAP IN COVERAGE BY
REQUIRING HEALTH INSURANCE
POLICIES TO INCLUDE COVERAGE FOR
CHILDREN'S HEARING AIDS.
THE COST OF HEARING AIDS IS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO
PARENTS SEEKING TO OBTAIN THEM
FOR THEIR CHILDREN -- THESE --
DEVICES CAN COST UP TO SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A PAIR AND
GROWING CHILDREN NEED THEM TO BE
REPLACED REGULARLY.
WELL CALIFORNIA'S A LEADER ON
MANY ISSUES ON THIS -- ONE SADLY
WE LAGGED BEHIND MORE THAN
TWENTY OTHER STATES THAT REQUIRE
INSURANCE FOR PEDIATRIC HEARING
AIDS.
AB FIVE NINETY EIGHT WILL ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
REGARDLESS OF INCOME OR
BACKGROUND HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE FOR HEARING AIDS.
AND HEARING AID SERVICES AND
BILL ARE KIMBERLY WHEN A MOTHER
OF FOR A HARD OF HEARING CHILD'S
HERE WITH TWO OF HER CHILDREN.
AND THE DOCTOR DILLON CHAN WHO
IS ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR IN
PEDIATRIC OTOLARYNGOLOGY
OTOLARYNGOLOGY.
UC SAN FRANCISCO AND I THINK
THEY ARE -- THE BEST ADVOCATES
FOR WHY THIS BILL IS ESSENTIAL
IT IN ADDITION TO THOSE WHO
YOU'LL BE HEARING FROM FROM THE
PUBLIC.
THANK YOU AND BEFORE WE BEGIN
THE WITNESSES JUST WANNA CLARIFY
AND APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
MINISTER TAKING THEM IN THIS
COMMITTEE CORRECT.
YES OKAY.
THANK YOU SORRY SO I TO CLARIFY
THAT.
THIS IS VERY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
WITH THIS IS A SUPPORT SIX
MINUTES TOTAL FOR ALL THE
WITNESSES SELL [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OUT MY NAME
IS DYLAN CHANNA PEDIATRIC
OTOLARYNGOLOGY SO YOU SEE SAN
FRANCISCO -- I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING OVER FIVE THOUSAND
PEDIATRICIAN STATEWIDE.
IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT MY FIRST ONE I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR ITS
CONTINUED EFFORTS IN MOVING THIS
BILL FORWARD -- SO ONE THOUSAND
CHILDREN ARE BORN EVERY YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA WITH HEARING LOSS.
FOR THESE CHILDREN TO DEVELOP
SPEECH IN SPOKEN LANGUAGE THE
HEARING AIDS ARE AN ABSOLUTE
MEDICAL NECESSITY.
THERE IS OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE
THAT FAILURE TO PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE INTERVENTION TO DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING CHILDREN BY
SIX MONTHS OF AGE.
LEADS TO SPEECH LANGUAGE
COGNITIVE EDUCATIONAL AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL DEFICITS EVERY MONTH
IN DELAY.
IN STARTING HEARING AIDS
DECREASES THEIR LONG TERM
LANGUAGE POTENTIAL. FOR THIS
REASON HEARING LOSS IS
CONSIDERED A DEVELOPMENTAL
EMERGENCY -- THE REQUIRES EARLY
INTERVENTION TO PREVENT
PERMANENT DELAYS -- CALIFORNIA
WE SCREEN 99% OF OUR NEWBORNS
FOR HEARING LOSS -- BUT
SCREENING IS ONLY USEFUL IF IT
CAN BE TO EARLY IN TIMELY
INTERVENTION AND THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE FAILING OUR CHILDREN --
ONLY 10% OF CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
HAVE HEARING A COVERAGE THROUGH
THE PRIVATE HEALTH PLANS.
HEARING AIDS COST UP TO THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS EACH AND IN MY
CLINIC -- I SEE HARD WORKING
FAMILIES WHO SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD
THEM AND I ALSO SEE THE
PERMANENT SPEECH AND LANGUAGE
DELAYS THAT HAPPENED -- WHEN
KIDS DON'T GET HEARING AIDS IN A
TIMELY MANNER WHEN THEY HIT THEM --
THESE PREVENTABLE CONSEQUENCES
ARE NOT ONLY DEVASTATING FOR THE
CHILD IN THE FAMILY THERE ARE
TREMENDOUS COST TO SOCIETY AND
OUR TAXPAYERS.
ON IT'S ESTIMATED THAT A WAS
SINGLE CHILD BORN DEAF OR HARD
OF HEARING -- COST TAXPAYERS UP
TO ONE MILLION DOLLARS -- IN
EDUCATIONAL COSTS FOR SUCH
OCCASIONAL COSTS AND LOST
PRODUCTIVITY -- IF THEY DON'T
INTERVENTION AND TIME.
SO WE NEED TO ACT NOW A
DEVELOPMENTAL EMERGENCY IS
REALLY EVOLVING RIGHT NOW -- FOR
EVERY CHILD IN CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT HEARING AIDS DUE TO
INADEQUATE INSURANCE COVERAGE.
OUR FIRST UP IS THE PAST EIGHTY
FIVE NINETY EIGHT AND ENSURE
THAT OUR DEFINITION HARD OF
HEARING CHILDREN CAN ACCESS
SOUND SO THAT THEY CAN LISTEN
AND TALK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR HAVING US MY
NAME IS KIMBERLY NEW AGAIN I AM
A SINGLE DEAF MOTHER.
WITH TWO CHILDREN THEY'RE BOTH
HERE WITH ME.
BOTH OF THEM ARE HARD OF HEARING
AND THEY BOTH USE HEARING AIDS
ON BOTH EARS.
NOW MY GIRLS HEARING AIDS HAVE A
HUGE IMPACT ON THEIR LIVES IT
PROVIDES THEM WITH EQUAL ACCESS
ALONG WITH SIGN LANGUAGE TO
THEIR FAMILY AND PEERS.
THEY LOVE MUSIC SINGING DANCING
AND WATCHING MOVIES THEY'RE ABLE
TO COMMUNICATE AND DO WELL IN
SCHOOL HEARING AIDS ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR THEIR SUCCESS.
I WORK FULL TIME AND I HAVE
INSURANCE I GUESS I AM
CONSIDERED ONE OF THE LUCKY ONES.
NINE OUT OF TEN INSURANCE
COMPANIES DO NOT COVER HEARING
AIDS AT ALL.
MY CURRENT INSURANCE ONLY COVERS
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS TOTAL WHICH
DOESN'T EVEN COVER THE COST OF
ONE HEARING AID.
MY CHILDREN'S HEARING AIDS CAN
COST UP TO SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR THE TWO THAT THEY EACH NEED.
THAT IS TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR THE TWO OF THEM EVERY TIME
NEW AGE ARE NEEDED.
THIS DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
EXPENSE OF YOUR MOLD AS THEY
GROW OR BATTERIES.
I AM THE SOLE FINANCIAL SUPPORT
PROVIDER FOR MY GIRLS.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT THIS IS A
STRUGGLE FOR ME TO SUPPORT THEM.
PAYING FOR HEARING AIDS IS A
HUGE BUT NECESSARY MEDICAL
NECESSITY FOR THEM.
AB FIVE NINETY EIGHT WOULD BE A
MAJOR HELP FOR MY FAMILY WHEN
THIS BILL PASSES IT WILL LIFT
OFF MY SHOULDERS THIS ENORMOUS
EXPENSE.
AND ALLOW ME TO SPEND MORE
PRECIOUS MOMENTS WITH MY
DAUGHTERS.
MY DAUGHTER SOPHIE WROTE A PAPER
CALLED ALL ABOUT MOM.
SHE WROTE THAT I WORK TOO MUCH
AND I'M ALWAYS TIRED AND
STRESSED.
PLEASE HELP ALL FAMILIES WITH
DEAF OR HARD OF HEARING CHILDREN
BY COVERING HEARING AIDS.
THEY ARE NECESSITY FOR ALL OF
OUR FAMILIES.
THIS IS THE V..
AND THIS IS CHLOE.
AND THEY BOTH WANTED TO SAY.
PLEASE LET CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
HERE.
WELCOME WELCOME SOPHIE AND CHLOE
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
THE OWNER WELCOME.
OKAY WE HEARD THAT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALRIGHT WELL LET'S.
I WELCOME BOTH SOAKING CHLOE
WELCOME.
ALL RIGHT LET'S LET'S MOVE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
INTO THE WITNESSES THAT'S
ALRIGHT THEN.
THANK YOU AND GREAT TO HAVE BOTH
OF YOU HERE ALL RIGHT --
WITNESSES OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT BACK MICROPHONE PLEASE
ESPERANZA ROSS ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR EARLY INTERVENTION ON
DEAFNESS.
THE JOHN TRACY CLINIC.
WEINGARTEN CHILDREN'S CENTER AND
THE CHAT CENTER THEY'RE ALL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS SERVING
AND EDUCATING CHILDREN WHO ARE
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
I'M NANCY SAGER RETIRED -- DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING PROGRAMS
CONSULTANT AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
FOR HANDS AND VOICES.
YOU READY PLEASE SUPPORT AB.
FIVE NINE EIGHT OKAY THANK THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
KATHY HI KATHY HALL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THIRTY ONE
REPRESENTING OUR AMERICAN CAMMY
PEDIATRIC CALIFORNIA DIVISION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JOHN A WONDERFULLY PRESS
RESIDENT OF PLASTER COUNTY IN
THESE ARE MEANT THREE HER
HEARING GIRLS YOU MET KATHY WITH
NANCY CAITLYN.
AND KERA.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
A POLL UNDER A PARENT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LAUREN DANG PARENT IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
STOCKTON ARE MY CAMACHO I'M
IDEOLOGIST REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF IDEOLOGY I
REPRESENTING DOCTORS OF HEARING
INCORPORATED REPRESENTING I LOVE
TO HEAR -- AN ORGANIZATION THAT
HELPS COLLEGE STUDENTS TO HEAR
BETTER.
THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO ERRORS ON BEHALF OF
MARCH OF DIMES AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
FINESCALE HìNH ON BEHALF OF THE
HEARING HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS OF
CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU FEINSTEIN THESE ARE MY
DAUGHTERS RYAN MY HARD OF
HEARING DAUGHTER AMERI AND WE
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DENISE KYLE
JOHNSON I'M A MOM WITH TWO DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING BOYS --
LOGAN.
AND BAILEY WHO IS BEING REALLY
SIDE -- THEY BOTH REALLY NEED
THEIR HEARING AIDS AND I'M ALSO
APPARENTLY EX MENTOR SO I
CONNECT OTHER FAMILIES AS WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH.
WELCOME.
ELIA BUT THE STAFF.
EMELI CAM AND BY THE NEW CAM MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA CALLING ON THE
PARENT TO EMILY ALL THREE ARE
HARD OF HEARING FRIENDS -- WE
ALL ARE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE NINETY EIGHT SO THAT ALL
KIDS CAN HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES THEY DO TO ACCESS
A LANGUAGE AND THE A COGNITIVE
DEVELOPMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
MY NAME ONLY EVER T. STATURE
[inaudible]
AS SUPPORT.
AS PUT A. B..
FIVE NINETY NINETY EIGHT RIGHT
MY NAME IS.
NICE OF PORT EIGHTY B..
FIVE NINETY EIGHT ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU.
AMANDA STUART MORRIS I'M A
TEACHER OF THE DEATH AND AND AN
EDUCATOR AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ELLIE KIM A STUDENT AT DAVIS MY
SISTER'S EMILY KIM AND I SUPPORT
AB FIVE READY.
THANK YOU.
I'M CHERYL S. SENATE TEACHER OF
THE DEATH OF AN INFANT PROGRAM
AND I SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI TORY ROUGH DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING TEACHER AND I SUPPORT AB
FIVE NINETY THANK YOU.
HI I'M CARA CRIED SOME A SPEECH
LANGUAGE PATHOLOGIST WORKING
WITH IN THE PROGRAMS I SEE HOW
ESSENTIAL IT IS TO SUPPORT AB.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU.
KATHLEEN SORIANO WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALICE KESSLER ON BEHALF OF THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION LOCAL
PLANETARY ADMINISTRATORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WERE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LARA CHOTI AMERI SMALL.
WE SUPPORT AB. FIVE NINE EIGHT
THANK YOU.
IF YOU HAD A MEAT IS NOT TO KNOW
WHAT CHILDREN NOW IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AARON OAKS I'M A
MOTHER TO A CHILD WITH --
HEARING AIDS AND I'M ALSO AN
AUDIOLOGY PEDIATRIC AN
EDUCATIONAL AUDIOLOGIST OF
TWENTY FOUR YEARS WITH SANTA
CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
AND SANTA CLARA VALLEY MEDICAL
CENTER IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT OKAY THANK YOU.
HELLO MARANDA MASSA TEACHER FOR
THE DEAF ON BEHALF OF ELK GROVE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND ALSO
A MOTHER OF A HARD OF HEARING
CHILD WHO WEARS HEARING AIDS I
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KHLOE WILLIAMS DEF EDUCATOR HERE
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO DAVID LUBIN I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
KATIE LADEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS WE STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE THE IS THE IS A MOTHER OF
ONE DEATH DAUGHTERS KAMALA.
AND I'M -- DRIVES THEM IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MY NAME IS SANKALP PLEASE.
PLEASE SUPPORT.
FIVE NINE D. [inaudible]
EIGHT THANK.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL WROTE PLEASE
SUPPORT AB.
FIVE NINE EIGHT MY NAME IS ROSE
BY BY ANI I'M A MOTHER OF A
CHILD HIS WHO WEARS HEARING AIDS
AND I SUPPORT FIVE NINETY EIGHT
I'M ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA HAS
INVOICES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MIKE I SUPPORT AB.
FIVE NINETY THANK YOU.
I MAYOR MARTIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
CESSATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE AND THIS
IS MY DAUGHTER MARIE AND I'M A
MOM AND A VOLUNTEER AND A CO
FOUNDER OF LET CALIFORNIA KIDS
HERE WE SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE
THANK YOU.
HI I'M DANIELLA TREVAN THE
PEDIATRIC OTOLARYNGOLOGY LISTEN
ON BEHALF OF READY TO THIS
HOSPITAL SAN DIEGO WE SUPPORT A.
B. FIVE NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS LADY ASSESSMENT I'M A
RETIRED LAUSD DEAF AND HARD OF
HEARING INTENT TEACHER AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
EIGHTY FIVE NINETY EIGHT THANK
YOU.
HI MY NAME'S CAPRICE A MRS.
ONLY THREE AND WE SUPPORT AB.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT HI MY NAME IS.
IN THE FOR MY SISTER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND I'M SHELLEY SINUS AND I'M
GRAMMA THE FREE AND I SUPPORT AB.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT N. HERE IN
SUPPORT OF MY GRANDDAUGHTER AND
ALL CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA OKAY
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS PAMELA HARD THIS
IS BENJAMIN HARD AND I AM A
PARENT OF A HARD OF HEARING
CHILD AND I SUPPORT AB.
FIVE NINETY THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RYAN.
MY SISTER IS STAFF.
I SUPPORT THIS BAN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEPTEMBER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MELANIE GILBERT I'M A
RESEARCH AUDIOLOGIST -- COOK
THEIR PLANTS BASED ORGAN THE
CLINIC.
A HELPING THESE KIDS IS A SUPER
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU LIKE TO VOICE MY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE SAP ACTUAL HUMAN NEED TO
MAKE SOME ROOM FOR THEM UP AT
THE TABLE [inaudible]
THIS
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JENNIFER
ALLEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU FOR YOUR TIME TO
TESTIFY ON THIS BILL TODAY.
WHAT WE SYMPATHIZE WITH HIS
GROUP AND APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS
TO LIMIT THE BENEFIT CAPTORS
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THIS BILL?
UNDER THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT --
STATES REQUIRED TO SELECT AN
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS PLAN.
THAT DEFINES RELATED HEALTH
SERVICES AND EQUIPMENT -- THE
BENCHMARK PLAN SELECTED IN
CALIFORNIA DID NOT INCLUDE
HEARING AIDS -- PCA ALSO REQUIRE
STATES TO COVER BENEFITS THAT
EXCEED THE BENCHMARK PLAN.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFITS REVIEW BOARD
CHIPPER AB DOES EXCEED THE
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS AND
TRIGGERS ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR
THE STATE -- SEVERAL BENEFIT
MANDATES HAVE BEEN PROPOSED IN
THE LEGISLATURE IN RECENT YEARS.
AND THIS ONE HAS RETURNED AGAIN
AND OUR MEMBERS REMAIN CONCERNED
ABOUT THE CUMULATIVE IMPACT.
ON THE COST OF OF PREMIUM CITIES
MANDATE BEEN THESE MANDATES HAVE.
AND MULTIPLE SURVEYS SURVEYS
CONFIRM THAT THE COST OF THE
MONTHLY PREMIUM IS THE NUMBER
ONE CONSUMER.
CONCERN WHEN SELECTING A HEALTH
PLAN.
THUS FAR CALIFORNIA HAS DONE A
BETTER JOB COMPARED TO MOST
OTHER STATES IN KEEPING COVERAGE
AFFORDABLE.
AND WITH THE AVERAGE PREMIUM
INCREASES BELOW OTHER STATES --
MAINTAINING AFFORDABLE PREMIUMS
IS CRITICAL AS CRITICAL AS
POLICY MAKERS STRIVE TO DECREASE
THE NUMBER OF UNINSURED IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND SO AT THIS TIME WE DO NOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
SEVENTY WATKINS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
WOULD FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR I KNOW%
THAT THEY ATTEMPTED.
TO NARROW THE BILL AND OUR
HEARTS GO OUT CERTAINLY TO THE
FAMILIES THAT ARE STRUGGLING IN
THE HARD WORK THAT THEY DO ON
BEHALF OF THEIR CHILDREN.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE HERE TO
TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
I THINK OUR MAIN CONCERN IS
THERE WAS THAT.
THERE WAS A PROCESS THE STATE IS --
CHOSEN A BENCHMARK PLAN TWICE.
OUR OUR PRIMARY INTEREST WOULD
BE TO HAVE THAT PROCESS PLAY OUT
I KNOW THE ANALYSIS DID A
WONDERFUL JOB OF KIND OF
HIGHLIGHTING THAT THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE MOVING
FORWARD TO CHOOSE TO ELECT TO RE
EVALUATE THE BENCHMARK PLAN.
THERE WERE ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS
THAT INCLUDED COVERAGE FOR
HEARING AIDS WE WOULD SUGGEST
THAT THAT HAVING THAT FRAMEWORK
PUT IN PLACE AND UTILIZING THAT
OPTION AS A WAY TO LOOK AT THIS
BENEFIT AS WELL AS OTHERS -- AND
TO CONSIDER THAT OPTION AND
GOING FORWARD I KNOW THE ENOUGH
TO SIT POINT OUT THAT WE HAVE
UNTIL MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY TO
NOTIFY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
ELECT -- FOR AND CONSIDER NEW
BENCHMARK PLAN WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO POINT OUT THAT WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE BILL IS
LIMITED. TO CHILDREN.
WE HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
ANNOUNCES THAT TO BURKE DID
BECAUSE I THINK THAT OUR CONCERN
WOULD BE THAT THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED DISCRIMINATORY AND WE
WOULD HAVE TO COVER.
HEARING AIDS FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
REGARDLESS OF AGE WHICH WOULD
MEAN THAT THAT SUBURBAN ALICE'S
AND THE NUMBERS THAT DENOTED TO
THE PREMIUM IMPACTS WOULD NOT
ACTUALLY BEAR OUT THE COST WOULD
BE MORE SIGNIFICANT IF WE HAD TO
COVER THEM FOR ALL AGE RANGES.
SO WITH THOSE CONCERNS -- WE
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND POTENTIALLY HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION ABOUT
CONSIDERING -- AND I AM A REVIEW
OF THE BENCHMARK PLAN GOING
FORWARD BUT TODAY WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL.
HEY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION JOHN WINGER IBF
AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
AGIS ECHO THE COMMENTS CAPEN
ACKLAND.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY -- SIR MITCHELL I BELIEVE
HE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IF I
MAY -- FIRST OF ALL SHAME ON US
FOR FALLING SHORT IN SELECTING A
BENCHMARK PLAN IT DIDN'T COVER
IT SHAME ON US SO -- WHATEVER
THE OUTCOME OF TODAY'S BILL THAT
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THAT THAT
THAT.
DR PANELED LISTENING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ENGAGED LITTLE
MORE PRO ACTIVELY IN THAT
PROCESS NEXT TIME WELL I FULLY
APPRECIATE.
THE NEED TO CREATE A SENSE OF
BALANCE BETWEEN AFFORDABILITY
AND COVERAGE COVERAGE ALSO HAS
TO BE RELEVANT TO BE RELEVANT.
AND TO A FAR GROUP YOU KNOW TO A
LARGE NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE -- HEARING IMPAIRED BOTH
CHILDREN AND ADULTS -- I THINK
THIS IS A FUNDAMENTAL -- ISSUE
THAT I HOPE THAT WE'LL ALL
ADDRESS.
SECONDLY WITH REGARD TO
pOF ALL LET ME I'M GLAD TO KNOW
THAT IT IS A COVERED BENEFIT
MEDI CAL YOU KNOW I'M ALWAYS THE
FIRST ONE TO SAY THAT MEDI CAL
IS A WONDERFULLY COMPREHENSIVE
BENEFIT PACKAGE -- REGARDLESS OF
THE NEGATIVE -- WRAP IT MAY TAKE
ITS WONDERFULLY COMPREHENSIVE
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE YET AGAIN OF
WHERE IT PROVIDES COVERAGE --
FOR A GOOD NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS WERE PRIVATE
INSURANCE DOES NOT.
BUT YOU DON'T IN MEDI CAL --
WILL BE ELIMINATED MANY OPTIONAL
BENEFITS ONLY BEGAN TO
INCREMENTALLY PUT THEM BACK
OPTICAL WITH SOMETHING WE PUT
BACK FOR CHILDREN FIRST AND JUST
SUCCESSFULLY GOT IT IN FULLY FOR
ADULTS THIS YEAR.
AND SO I YOU KNOW I I QUESTION
THE DISCRIMINATORY YOU KNOW
CLAIM BECAUSE I APPRECIATE WHEN
I TALK ABOUT MEDI CAL TODAY BUT
WE HAVE DONE THAT AS A
LEGISLATURE WE TOOK AND ACTION.
PROVIDED A BENEFIT.
TO A POPULATION AND NOT THE
ENTIRE POPULATION AND SO IF
SOMEONE COULD JUST PROVIDE ME
SOME CLARITY ON ON THE
DISCRIMINATORY CLAIM IF THAT'S
TRULY VALID.
SO -- LET ME IF I'M GONNA LET ME
TRY TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION FOR
SOMETHING THAT YOU AND I HAVE
ONE MORE THAN I'M DONE THANK YOU --
SO.
SO THE NATURE IS SO THAT THERE
ISN'T A LAW -- SO BASICALLY WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT -- THERE CAN BE
A CLAIM THAT IT MIGHT BE
DISCRIMINATORY BECAUSE WE'RE
ONLY DOING CHILDREN SO BECAUSE
UNDER.
BUT WE HAVE TO TREAT ALL BEEN
FISHERIES.
THE SAME AND SO SOMEONE IS OLDER
COULD SAY WELL I'M NOT CHILD BUT
CONSIDERING CURRENT MY POINT IS
WE DID THAT AND MEDICARE WE
PROVIDE RIGHT.
RIGHT EXACTLY YEAH EXACTLY SO
THAT'S MEDI CAL BUT WE'RE NOW
TALKING ABOUT -- DOWN THE
PRIVATE INSURANCE THERE IS A
DIFFERENT.
THERE'S A PUT THERE YES THERE IS
A POSSIBILITY THERE'S A PAUSE
IT'S NOT A CERTAINTY THE
POSSIBILITY AND SO THE CONCERN
IS IS THAT WE HAD SOME SEVERAL
DISCUSSIONS I APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE.
IS IS THAT -- TO STILL SAY THAT
OUR GOAL IS CHILDREN BUT
RECOGNIZING THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY NAY RECOGNIZE THE
OPPOSITION HAS CONCERNS BECAUSE
IF IT'S RULE DISCRIMINATORY BY
THE WITH.
IT BY THE REGULATORS AT IT THEN
ESSENTIALLY IT WOULD
AUTOMATICALLY THEN EXTEND TO
EVERYONE AND THAT WOULD GREATLY
INCREASE THE COST SO LITTLE AND
THEN WE'D HAVE TO COME BACK HERE
AND FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO ABOUT
THAT SO -- SO THAT THERE IS A
RISK OF THAT I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS WE WORKED ON IS ACTUALLY
PUTTING STRONGER INTENT LANGUAGE
TO MAKE CLEAR IT'S NOT CERTAIN
THAT THEY WILL REGULATE THEY
WILL RULE THAT WAY EITHER WITH
OUR SEVERAL STATES THAT HAVE
CHILDREN ONLY.
SO IT'S NOT A CERTAINTY BUT IT'S
A POSSIBILITY GOT IT THANK YOU
FOR THAT OKAY FAKING.
AND MY SECOND FINAL QUESTION
HERE AT ONE ONE COMMENT ON THAT
ISSUE -- IF YOU PLEASE SENATOR
THE FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES IS ALREADY
ISSUED A RULE THAT CLARIFIES
THAT STATE AND FEDERAL MANDATES
WITH H. DISTINCTIONS.
DO NOT CONSTITUTE AGE
DISCRIMINATION.
AND TO A I CAN I CAN QUOTE FROM --
FROM THAT FINAL RULE -- BUT IT'S
IT IT SIR IT'S QUITE CLEAR WELL
I THINK THE THING AND ADDED
WITHOUT GOING TO ATTRACT
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THAT UP.
I THINK THE WAY THE RULES OF THE
LOSS SAID IS ACTUALLY A
DISCUSSION OF OUR STATE
REGULATORS TODAY IT'S THEIR
THEIR TO WANT TO MAKE THE CALL
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE OR
OTHER SIMILAR ISSUES AND THAT'S
THE CHALLENGE.
THANK YOU MY FINAL QUESTION IS --
SOMEONE MENTION COCHLEAR
IMPLANTS IS IT JUST HEARING AIDS
THAT AREN'T COVERED.
OUR OTHER A HEARING -- KIND OF
REMEDIATION CYCLE CLEAR IMPACTS
COVER IN THIS JUST HEARING AIDS
ARE NOT THE IRONY HERE IS THAT
COCHLEAR IMPLANTS ARE.
INCLUDED AS I CENTRAL HEALTH
BENEFIT -- I SHOULD POINT OUT
THAT -- FOR MANY CHILDREN I
THINK -- DOCTOR CHECK AND
PROBABLY BETTER SPEAK TO THIS
BUT MANY CHILDREN WHO RECEIVE
COCHLEAR IMPLANTS START OUT WITH
HEARING AIDS AND THAT'S ACTUALLY
ESSENTIAL TO THEIR DEVELOPMENT.
THANK YOU.
OF THE SUPPORT THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE THE BILL AT THE PERFECT
TIME OKAY ASSN LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM I WANNA
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I I THINK THAT WE CAN
ALWAYS FIND A WAY NOT TO DO
SOMETHING.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
WE DO FIND A WAY TO DO SOMETHING
AND HEARING AIDS -- ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY
FOR YOUNG CHILDREN WHEN I WAS
GRADUATING FROM COLLEGE A VERY
LONG TIME AGO -- AND MY DEGREE
IS IN A COMMUNICATIVE DISORDERS
I WAS GOING TO BE A SPEECH
THERAPIST AND I WAS TAKING A
CLASS AN AUDIOLOGY I WAS ALSO
SIX MONTHS PREGNANT WITH OUR
TWINS.
AND I REMEMBER THINKING THAT.
WHEN MY GIRLS ARE BORN BUT IN
OTHER GIRLS AT THE TIME WHEN MY
CHILDREN ARE BORN?
IF THEY NEED A HEARING AID I
NEED TO KNOW IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE
CHILDREN FALL BEHIND SO QUICKLY
IF THEY CAN'T HEAR AND AND AND
LEARN SOUNDS AND WORDS.
SO.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
ARE PROVIDING IT FOR CHILDREN
UNDER EIGHT ARE UNDER.
EIGHTEEN BUT I ALSO WANT TO PUT
A PLUG IN FOR ADULTS BECAUSE AS
SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTED WORKERS
FOR MANY YEARS.
I HAD A MY CREW GUY -- OF THIRTY
FIVE YEARS IT WAS ABOUT TO LOSE
HIS JOB.
AND I ASKED HIM I SAID YOU KNOW
YOU'RE SO ANGRY ALL THE TIME
WHAT IS THE PROBLEM HE COULDN'T
HEAR SO MANAGEMENT THOUGHT THAT
HE WAS IGNORING THEM HE COULDN'T
HEAR THE INSTRUCTIONS.
AND IT'S SHOCKING TO ME THAT YOU
WERE HERE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND WE'RE STILL ARGUING
OVER WHO'S GOING TO PAY FOR
HEARING AIDS TO MAKE SURE OUR
CHILDREN CAN LEARN. TO MAKE SURE
ADULTS CAN DO THEIR JOB AND BE
EFFECTIVE MEMBERS OF SOCIETY SO
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS FIND A
WAY TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT AND THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER HEARING AID.
SIX THOUSAND FOR ONE CHILD AND
THEY'RE GONNA OUTGROW THOSE
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY I DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY YOU HAVE TO
MAKE TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD THAT.
SO WE NEED TO GET TO A POINT
WHERE INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE
PAYING FOR IT I KNOW YOU HATE TO
HEAR THAT BUT WHAT WE DO DO WE
JUST ALLOW THESE YOUNG CHILDREN.
TO NOT BUILD HERE AND DEVELOP
AND REACH THEIR FULL POTENTIAL --
WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY WE CAN
FIND A WAY TO SAY NO LET'S FIND
A WAY TO SAY YES I AM LOOK FOR
SUPPORTING THE BILL.
HEY SIR GROWTH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I DO
APPRECIATE THE BILL AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS ON
IT AND I DO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES THAT WE DO NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT SOMETHING GETS
DONE FOR CHILDREN -- AND ADULTS
BUT TODAY WE'RE DISCUSSING
CHILDREN BUT I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PROCESS AND
I'M SORRY THAT I DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWER SO BE LOOKING TO ALL OF
YOU TO GIVE THEM.
SO IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA THERE THE A BOMB
ADMINISTRATION WITH THE ACA --
WAS HEARING AIDS OR HEARING
PROTECT HEARING.
AIDS WERE THEY COVERED UNDER THE
GENERAL A CA.
IS THAT WHY WE DIDN'T COVER HIM
OR ARE THERE PLANS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE UNDER THE ACA THAT WE
IS CALIFORNIANS ADOPT.
SO THE PROCESS WHY IS THAT EACH
STATE WAS SORT OF GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PICK A BENCHMARK%
PLAN AND WE WERE GIVEN A
MULTITUDE OF OPTIONS ONE BEING I
THINK THAT.
MOST COMMON SMALL GROUP PLANNED
THE CALPERS PLAN THE FEDERAL
PLAN.
I'M I BELIEVE IT WAS TWENTY
TWELVE WHEN WE ELECTED OUR FIRST
BENCHMARK PLAN.
PART OF THAT WAS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS LOOKING TO STATES --
TO PICK WHAT WAS MOST UTILIZED
IN THEIR OWN STATE WHICH MADE
THE MOST SENSE THAT THEY SET UP
THE CRITERIA OF THE OF THE TEN
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS WHAT
HAD TO BE INCLUDED.
AND THEN YOU CHOSE FROM THE PLAN
OPTIONS THAT YOU HAD AVAILABLE
TO YOU AND SO THERE WAS A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THEIR
CONVERSATIONS THEIR LEGISLATIVE --
BILLS THAT WERE RUN I KNOW THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER HAD
SEVERAL HEARINGS ABOUT WHAT PLAN
MADE THE MOST SENSE FOR
CALIFORNIA OBVIOUSLY WE WERE
VERY PRICE SENSITIVE AT THE TIME
KNOWING THAT THIS WOULD BE
BASICALLY THE STANDARD FOR WHICH
PEOPLE WOULD PURCHASE.
AT THAT TIME THE KAISER THIRTY
PLUS PLAN THAT WAS CHOSEN --
DIDN'T INCLUDE HEARING IT'S AN
ACTUAL EXCLUDED COVERAGE FOR
HEARING AIDS -- AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN WE THEN WENT THROUGH THE
PROCESS AGAIN TO CONSIDER AN
UPDATE THAT BENCHMARK PLANNED
THE KAISER THIRTY PLAN WAS AGAIN
CHOSEN -- WITH REMAINING THAT
SORT OF EXCLUSIONS SO I THINK
FROM OUR OUR PLACE.
AS FAR AS THE PROCESS BE
UNDERSTANDING THAT ONCE WE
EXCEED THE BENCHMARK PLAN WE'VE
SORT OF OPENED THE DOOR TO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THE STATE THE
PHRASE THE COST -- FOR ANY
SERVICE THAT GOES BEYOND WHAT
THE BENCHMARK PLAN IS.
SO WE JUST SORT OF GENERALLY
SUGGESTED THAT IF THE STATE IS
INTERESTED I MEAN CHIROPRACTIC
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS TO IT AND
AND WE'VE SEEN MULTITUDE OF
MANDATES THAT COME BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE.
THAT THAT'S A BETTER PROCESS TO
CONSIDER TO HAVE A STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS TO LOOK AT THE OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO CHOOSE AND
POTENTIALLY CHOOSE A PLAN THAT
INCLUDES COVERAGE FOR HEARING
AIDS ONE SO THAT YOU PROTECT YOU
DON'T EXCEED THE BENCHMARK PLAN.
YOU DON'T ASSUME THE FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT COSTS OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WON'T COVER.
I ALSO GIVE THE STATE
LEGISLATORS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONSIDER WHAT THEY THINK IS THE
BEST OPPORTUNITY FOR STE
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU SO I THINK MY QUESTION
IS BE ACID EFFORT HUESO AYE I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS IS THAT I
DON'T TO DUPLICATE ANYTHING SO
WE'RE ALL SURE THAT THE IN THE
ACA DID NOT COVER.
A HEARING FOR THE THEY LEFT IT
UP TO STATES WHICH WHICH IS KIND
OF SILLY TO ME I THINK BECAUSE I
SHOW I'M SURE CALIFORNIA IS NOT
THE ONLY STATE THAT HAS HEARING
IMPAIRED CHILDREN -- I'M SURE
THAT GOES OVER ALL FIFTY STATES --
I WOULD THINK.
SO I WOULD THINK THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WOULD COVER
THAT BUT I AND I'M NOT TRYING TO
BASH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I'M
JUST TRYING TO SAY THAT.
SO I GUESS MY NEXT QUESTION IS
IS THAT IF IT IS NOT COVERED ON
THE FEDERAL SIDE AND IT IS LEFT
UP TO THE STATE'S THEN MOVED TO
THE BENCHMARK PLAN.
IF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH
LEGISLATORS ADOPT A BENCHMARK
PLAN.
THAT IS COVERED -- BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BUT THEN ADD. TEN
TWELVE TO SIX ITEMS TO THAT PLAN
THAT COULD OR COULD NOT HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT COST.
WHERE IS THAT FUNDING MECHANISM
COMING FROM [inaudible]
SIR.
WELL -- TO THE AT THE ANSWER IS
ACTUALLY THE STATE.
SO IT DOES BECOME A COST TO THE
STATE TO PROVIDE THAT COVERAGE
BEYOND THE BENCHMARK PLAN SO WE
GET TO DECIDE.
WITHIN CERTAIN PARAMETERS WHAT
THE BENCHMARK PLAN IS AND IF WE
HAD ANYTHING BEYOND THAT -- THEN
THE STATE IS. FOR FOR AT LEAST
THE PUBLIC PIECES OF IT RIGHT SO --
THIS UP IT IS ON THE STATE AND
THEN OF COURSE FOR OTHER PRIME
INSURERS IT WOULD GET PASSED ON
TO CONSUMERS RIGHT AS PART OF
AND TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES POINT SO WE DON'T MISS
THINGS LIKE THIS AGAIN.
IS THERE SOME WAY THAT WE STUDY
OR THAT WE HAVE -- YOU KNOW THIS
IS THE BENCHMARK PLAN WE CHOSE
BUT THESE ARE THE TEN ITEMS WE
ADDED TO IT WHICH GIVES US THE
TRUE COST OF WHAT THE ENTIRE.
HEALTH CARE COST IS RIGHT
BECAUSE WE CAN'T JUST GO BACK TO
THE BENCHMARK PLAN AND SAY THIS
WE PAID X..
BECAUSE WE OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T PAY
X. IF WE ADDED TEN MORE ITEMS TO
IT.
IS THERE SOME TYPE OF SOMETHING
SO WE CAN GET A TRUE COSTS FOR
THE HEALTH CARE.
OR NOT [inaudible]
SORRY.
YEAH I'M TIED TO A DEMO SURE YOU
GET YOUR QUESTIONS ANSWERED SO --
DESCRIBE IT THIS BILL IS THE
WOOD WE HAVE NOT GONE BEYOND THE
BENCHMARK PLAN YET SO THIS THIS
IS THE FIRST THIS WOULD BE THE
FIRST OF IT.
SOMEBODY SAID TEN NO WE DO NOT
WE HAVE NOT AND I THINK STEP
PERHAPS IN ASTOPS YOU CAN SPEAK
FOR THEMSELVES -- A UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE CONCERNS
IS THAT THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
WE'RE BREAKING BEYOND THE
BENCHMARK PLAN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SO I GUESS MY NEXT
QUESTION IS FROM THE STATE
PERSPECTIVE I REALIZE THAT WE
WOULD PICK OF OF COSTS FOR
PUBLIC ISSUES.
ON THE PRIVATE PAY ISSUE -- DO
HEALTH PLANS IN ASSESSING TO
HEALTH PLANS WHEN THEY PUT THEIR
POLICY OUT THERE FOR A YEAR YOU
OBVIOUSLY SUBMIT YOUR RATES TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
IS WATER PLAN COVERS THE COST OF
THIS PLAN.
SO YOU SELL PLAN X. THAT COVERS
THESE ESSENTIAL SERVICES
REQUIRED BY THE ACA WHAT WE
ADOPTING CALIFORNIA.
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG.
OKAY THAT THAT COST OR THAT FREE
WORK THAT IS APPROVED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE GOES FOR
WHAT PERIOD OF TIME. ONE YEAR
OKAY SO IF THIS GETS IMPLEMENTED
AND YOUR NEW PROGRAM DOESN'T GET
SUBMITTED WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE.
UNTIL THE FOLLOWING YEAR THE
WERE YOU SUBMIT YOUR PLAN.
AND YOU CAN'T COVER WHAT IS NOW
GOING TO BE MANDATED FREE TO
COVER.
AND I WE YOU NEED COVERAGE OKAY
I'M SORRY I THINK YOU NEED
COVERAGE SO -- BUT IF IF WHERE'S
THIS GAP WHERE DOES THE
RESOURCES COME FOR THIS GAP
WHERE YOU WILL.
YOU HAVE NOT.
YOU HAVE NOT SUBMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE TO COVER
THIS PARTICULAR PRODUCT.
THIS PARTICULAR ITEM.
AND NOW YOU ARE GOING TO BE
REQUIRED TO COVER IT WHERE DOES.
THE RECENT WHERE DOES IT COME
FROM THE FUNDING MECHANISM AND
CAN YOU CHANGE YOUR PLAN PLAN
FOR THE CAN CHANGE PLAN. FOR
THEIR PART OF INSURANCE
MIDSTREAM SO CAPS NUMBERS FILE
WITH THAT COVER CALIFORNIA
HANDED HER MINUTES OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE THAT REGULATE.
THE HMO THOSE AND THEY'RE
ACTIVELY FILING THEIR PRODUCTS
AND THEIR RATES FOR TWENTY
TWENTY OKAY RIGHT NOW.
AND SO THE FISCAL YEAR IT'S A
VISITS AT A SCHOOL RIGHT NOW TO
COUNTY CALENDAR YEAR OKAY THE
END OF DECEMBER SO THOSE FILINGS
ARE OCCURRING NOW. FOR THE
BENEFITS THAT ARE CURRENTLY PART
OF THEIR PLAN DESIGN.
WHICH WE MANDATE AS A STATE
LEGISLATOR RIGHT SO THE
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS IN
OUTLINES WHAT WHAT THEY NEED TO
COVER AND SO THE PLAN SUBMIT
THEIR THEIR PRODUCT IN THEIR
RATES WITH THAT AND THEN THE
REGULATOR GHOSTS OF THEIR
PROCESS AND THEN THOSE PLANS.
TYPICALLY YOU KNOW THROUGH THE
PRIVATE MARKET START ON JANUARY.
FIRST.
AND RUN THROUGH THAT YEAR AND SO
THE PREMIUMS THAT ARE --
DEVELOPED BY THE PLAN ACTUARIES
ARE BASED ON THE PLANS
EXPERIENCE AND THE BENEFIT
PACKAGE.
THAT IS GOING TO BE PROVIDED TO
THE ENROLLEES.
SO IT IS THE RATES ARE SET TO
COVER THE COST OF CARE.
AND THE OPERATIONAL COST
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR THE
PLAN TO OPERATE AND RUN TO
ANSWER PHONES AND SEND THEIR
STUFF OUT AND DO ALL THE THINGS
THAT THAT MY MEMBERS DO SO WELL.
SO THAT'S WHAT'S INCLUDED IN THE
PREMIUM AND SO WHEN WE LOOK AT
BENEFIT MANDATES WE DO CONSIDER
THE COST TO THE PREMIUM THAT
EVERYBODY PAYS BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT [inaudible]
OUR SO YOU KNOW WHEN THE STATE
YOU KNOW MANDATES THAT WE HEARD
A NEW BENEFIT THEN WE HAVE TO
BUILD IT INTO THAT PLAN AND THE
COSTS ARE AT YOU'VE ALREADY
SUBMITTED YOUR PARTIES FOR NEXT
YEAR WE HAVE HEARD SOMEONE ELSE
LICENSE MELENDEZ THIS.
BILL TAKE EFFECT SIR.
IF IT GETS SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR WOMEN IN ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS HAS THAT -- A I THINK
IT'S JULY OF FOR YEAH TWENTY
TWENTY FIRST MAY TWENTY IT WAS
GOING TO BE JANUARY ONE BUT SO
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY WHO
FUNDS THE SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER KID ROUGHLY.
WHO DOES THAT?
I DON'T KNOW THE WOULD.
UNDER THE PLANS.
BUT WHERE DO YOU COME UP WITH
THAT MANY I GUESS IS WHAT I'M
SAYING BECAUSE YOU FILED YOUR
WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET ACROSS TO
JUST VERIFY THAT THE THE WAY THE
AMENDMENTS ARE FRAMES.
IS JUST THAT IT'S AT RENEWAL SO
THE SO THE MOROCCAN SO I AND I
UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTIONS
CONCERNS LIKE IS IT DID WHAT IT
IS.
THAT'S PART IN MINUTES YES OKAY
SO PART OF THE MINUTES IS
PROTECTING THE PLANS OF FILED
FOR THAT.
PART OF THAT.
RIGHT SO THE SO WHAT I'M WORRIED
ABOUT IS I THINK IT SHOULD BE
COVERED I THINK THE PLAN SHOULD
COVER THIS I THINK WE SHOULD
HAVE MADE SURE.
AND THE ESSENTIAL SERVICES THAT --
CENTRAL BENEFITS THAT IT WAS
COVERED I GET I GET THAT BUT
SINCE WE COLLECTIVELY LET THAT
GO.
AND NOW I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
MANDATING THIS AND THERE BE NO
RESOURCES TO PAY FOR IT.
AND HAVING PLANS CONTINUE TO
LEAVE AND NOT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE PLANS A
COVERAGE FOR YOU KNOW.
PEOPLE IN COVERAGE AND IF YOU
DON'T HAVE PLANS TO PROVIDE
COVERAGE IT PUTS US IN A BAD
SPOT AND WE MANDATE THINGS ON
PLANS.
AND THAT ARE OUTSIDE OF THEIR
CONTROL YOU CAN CONTROL THIS
CASE VERY SIMILAR TO RATES
APARTMENT INSURANCE.
MY CONCERN IS WHERE THAT MONEY
COMES FROM BUT THIS WILL NOT
TAKE EFFECT UNTIL PLANS GET TO
SUBMIT THEIR NEW RATES TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
CORRECT UNDER THE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT -- AT
RENEWAL POLICY RATES WILL BE
ADJUSTED -- THE ESTIMATE THAT WE
HAVE FOR WHAT THE COST OF THAT
WILL BE TO CONSUMERS ARE -- TO
PLAN MEMBERS IS THE THE RANGE
WOULD BE FROM SIX CENTS PER
MEMBER PER MONTH IN THE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET. TO TWELVE
CENTS PER MEMBER PER MONTH AND
SMALL GROUP PLANS.
YOU PRICE OUT PLANS IS THAT
ACCURATE I'M QUESTIONING YOU I'M
JUST ASKING FOR SOMEBODY TO GIVE
ME SOME TYPE OF ACCURACY -- I
THINK I MEAN THAT'S BASED ON THE
SUBURBAN DALLAS SAYS I MEAN
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT YOU PURPOSE
SORT OF TASKED WITH THIS COMING
OKAY A GENERAL -- ANALYSIS I
THINK OUR ISSUE OR CONCERN AND
WE BROUGHT THIS UP EARLIER IS.
TO THE DEGREE IF THERE IS IF THE
REGULATORS A TERMINUS TO BE
DISCRIMINATORY AND THEREFORE HAS
TO BE APPLIED TO BOTH CHILDREN
AND ADULTS THE IMPACT COULD BE
GREATER AND NOT SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BURKE DIDN'T ANALYZE FOR
THE ONLY ANALYZE FOR THE BILL
AND PRINT.
IT IN THE CHAIR MENTIONED WHAT
DO YOU THINK THE CHANCES ARE
REGULATORS WILL GO AGAINST THAT
IN INCLUDING DILTS BECAUSE IT'S
DISCRIMINATORY EVEN THOUGH.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
DETERMINED THAT WELL SO JUST TO
BE CLEAR -- IT SAID THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY IT'S IT'S HARD TO
YES THERE ARE STATES THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE COVERAGE IT'S ONLY
KIDS SO IT'S NOT CERTAIN THAT
THEY'LL BE DECLARED
DISCRIMINATORY.
BUT THERE IS A POSSIBILITY AND
WE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND
THEY DO SO THAT'S EITHER
TEAMMATES SEE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE OR DEPARTMENT
SHARON'S.
DECLARES A DISCRIMINATORY.
THEN -- THEN.
BASICALLY BE ON THE HOOK.
FOR BOTH CHILDREN AND ADULTS
AUTOMATICALLY SO.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- SO
THAT'S IT THAT'S STATE STATE
REGULATORS THAT AND THAT'S WHY
ST SO I APPRECIATE -- SUMMER
BLOOM BRING UP.
THE STATEMENT FROM HIS OFFICE OF
CIVIL RIGHTS AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BUT ACTUALLY IT'S
TRIGGERED BY THE STATE
REGULATORS IN SEVERAL STATES BY
THE WAY THE REGULATORS HAVE NOT.
DECLARED DISCRIMINATORY SO THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE COVERAGE JUST FOR
KIDS SO IT'S CERTAINLY KNOWS
THERE'S NO CERTAINTY THAT.
THE REGULATORS WILL DECLARE IT --
DISCRIMINATORY A IN FACT THEM I
THINK WITH THE LAW THE TELLING
WHICH THAT THE AUTHORS PUT IN
THAT WE'VE ALSO TALKED ABOUT.
OUR HOPE IS THEY WOULD NOT --
BUT I IT BUT TO BE FULLY
TRANSPARENT AS ALWAYS THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY.
BUT WE HAVE GONE TO GREAT
LENGTHS TO GUARD RAILS AROUND
THIS I THINK DOCTOR CHAN -- HAD
A COMMENT IF YOU SIR YES.
JUST A BRIEF COMMENT ABOUT THE
AGE DISCRIMINATION -- ISSUE FROM
THE MEDICAL AN IDEOLOGICAL
STANDPOINT HEARING LOSS IN
CHILDREN IS A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT CONDITIONS AND HEARING
LOSS IN ADULTS IN TERMS OF BOTH
THE IN TERMS ABOUT THE CAUSES
AND CONSEQUENCES -- THE PRIMARY
CONCERN FOR HEARING LOSS IN
CHILDREN IS HOW IT AFFECTS UP
PERMANENT -- THAT DEVELOPMENT SO
SPEECH AND LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENTS
AND COGNITIVE DEVELOPMENT WHICH
ARE FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR HEALTH --
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT THERE ARE
NOT HEALTH IMPLICATIONS FOR
HEARING LOSS IN ADULTS -- BUT
THERE ARE NUMEROUS EXAMPLES BOTH
IN A STANDARD CLINICAL PRACTICE
AND IN -- IN -- IN REGULATORY --
EXAMPLES WHERE CHILDREN AND
ADULTS ARE TREATED VERY
DIFFERENTLY AND RULES ARE VERY
DIFFERENCE -- WITH RESPECT TO
HEARING LOSS SO I HAVE YOU KNOW
QUITE A BIT OF CONFIDENCE BASED
ON WHAT'S HAPPENED OTHER STATES
AS WELL AS THE MEDICAL REALITY
IS THAT -- AGE DISCRIMINATION --
SHOULD HOPEFULLY SHOULD NOT BE
AN ISSUE HERE.
AND I MY LAST QUESTION I GUESS
IS THAT IF IT IS A ISSUE IF IT
DID DOES HE HAVE AN ISSUE AND
YOU TAKE THAT TWELVE CENTS
MULTIPLY IT BY HOW MANY ADULTS.
WITH THE ADDITIONAL INCREASE
ESTIMATED COST.
BUT YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
COVER BEFORE YOUR NEW RATES ARE
REAPPLIED IN RENEWED.
I THINK THAT'S THE UNKNOWN I
DON'T WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE AN
EXACT NUMBER AND TO PURPOSE
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THEIR ONLY
PATH TO LOOK AT THE BILL AND
PRINT THAT ISN'T SOMETHING THAT
THEY WERE ANALYZED OR PROVIDING.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
THERE STONE WE GIVE US A JUST A
FOLLOW UP AGAIN WITH THE PLANS --
THE WAY I THINK I SEE IT IS THAT
IF WE WERE TO ENTERTAIN THE BILL.
THAT WOULD BE A SIX MONTH PERIOD
OF TIME THAT YOU BASICALLY WOULD
BE RECEIVING A PREMIUM FOR THIS --
THIS ADDITIONAL SERVICES THAT
CORRECT -- I'M MISSING SOMETHING
SO YOU WOULD BE COVERED IF.
AIDS THEY DID IT.
WE OFTEN ASK FOR DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION OFFICE OF THE
DENNIS TAKE CARE OF THAT PROCESS
OKAY SO -- I'M A I'M A BABY
BOOMER.
AND AND I LIKE GROUPS LIKE --
STUFF AND WILL.
FOR AND YES AND AND I USED TO
BLAST THE MUSIC I CRAZY AND MY
PARENTS WERE ALWAYS WERE WARNING
ME YOU'RE GOING TO LOSE YOUR
HERE.
HERE SOUND AND A NEW TURN THE
MUSIC DOWN WHICH OF COURSE
DIDN'T.
LISTEN TO THEM.
AND THEN I FOUND -- WATCHING TV
AT NIGHT WITH MY LOVELY WIFE --
SHOULD BE -- ABBY'S TELLING HER
TURN THE VOLUME UP I CAN'T HEAR
AND SHE GOES WELL THE NEIGHBORS
ALREADY COMPLAINING THAT THEY
CAN HEAR NEXT DOOR SO.
MY HEARING WAS WAS GOING AND SO --
NEVER.
HAVING THIS ISSUE BEFORE.
YOU FOLLOW YOUR TELEVISION
ADVERTISEMENTS IN A SALE COME
HERE FOR THIS PARTICULAR YEAR.
DEVICE AND GO IN THERE AND I GOT
A I GOT A QUOTE OF LIKE EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND I ABOUT.
THE IN ANY PARTY CHECKER
INSURANCE A SOMEWHAT HOW MUCH IS
INSURANCE GOING TO COVER IT WAS
LIKE A THOUSAND BUCKS.
AND SO LIKE SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS OUT OF POCKET -- AND I
AND I PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT
WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH THE
CENSUS YOU'RE DEALING WITH SITE
YOU'RE DEALING WITH HEARING
ESPECIALLY FOR A CHILD OR AN
ADULT THESE ARE THESE ARE
ESSENTIAL.
TOOLS THAT YOU NEED -- TO
FUNCTION I EVEN IN THE PUBLIC
SAFETY ARENA I WOULD USE THE
ARGUMENT THAT YOU HAVE TO BILL
HEAR SIRENS IF YOU'RE DRIVING A
CAR THERE'S A AN INCIDENT GOING
ON BUT THE POINT I WANT TO MAKE
IS THAT.
TECHNOLOGY IS CHANGING.
AND I WAS ABLE TO GO TO A A
RETAILER AND I WAS ABLE TO GET
WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE QUALITY --
HEARING AIDS FOR ABOUT SIXTEEN
HUNDRED BUCKS.
AND RECENTLY WE'VE SEEN ON SOME
CABLE CHANNELS OF ANOTHER ONE
THAT'S ON THE MARKET THAT YOU
CAN PROGRAM WITH YOUR IPAD IN.
THE RE CHARGEABLE FOR SEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS SO I WOULD SAY
THE TRENDS ARE THAT.
IF YOU PUT A A MAXIMUM ALLOWABLE
COSTS AT THE INSURANCE COMPANY
MAY OR MAY NOT COVER THAT IT
WILL HELP THE PRIVATE SECTOR GO
OUT AND SHOP AROUND AND FIND
SOME OF THESE.
GOOD QUALITY HEARING AIDS THAT
ARE OUT THERE THAT MIGHT BE.
MUCH LESS EXPENSIVE -- BUT BUT I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FROM LOS ANGELES.
AT THE TIME SHAME ON US FOR NOT
PICKING THE THE THE THE PLAN
THAT COVERS THE BASIC ESSENTIALS
TO TO HUMAN HEALTH.
WHICH I THINK THIS IS ONE OF
THEM -- IT SOUNDS LIKE TO ME BE
SOMEONE I'M HEARING THAT THE
PREMIUMS ARE NOT GOING TO BE
EXTRAVAGANTLY LARGER FOR THIS
ADDITIONAL SERVICE ESPECIALLY
WITH LIMITED TO PETE'S -- BUT
I'M SURE THAT THE PLANS WILL
WILL INCORPORATE HOPEFULLY THESE
COST A CERTAIN THE BILL MOVES
OUT TODAY MY PLAN SUPPORTING IT --
THAT WILL GIVE AN INCENTIVE FOR
THOSE IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO
SHOP AROUND BECAUSE THERE IS A
TREMENDOUS DELTA AND WHAT THESE
HEARING AIDS CAN COST.
AND I'M NOT SURE THAT YOU'RE
SACRIFICING MUCH QUALITY BY
GETTING AN EXPENSIVE HEARING AID --
IN COMPARISON TO WHAT I WOULD
CONSIDER THIS THE CADILLAC
BRANDS.
SO -- I'M HAPPY TO TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY SENATOR THE SOME
OF THE BLOOM -- I THINK IT'S
IT'S TIME -- AND I'M SURE THAT
THE THE PLANTS WILL DO THEIR
BEST TO KEEP THE PREMIUMS -- AND
AFFORDABLE LEVEL BUT WE HAVE TO
PROVIDE -- HEARING DEVICES FOR
THE HEARING IMPAIRED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SIR RUBIO.
THANK YOU AM I JUST WANT TO
SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE YOU KNOW I
SHARED WITH THE AUTHOR OF MY
EXPERIENCE AS AN EDUCATOR AND
HOW DETRIMENTAL IT IS FOR OUR
STUDENTS.
DURING THE EARLY YEARS OF THEIR
EDUCATION NOT TO BE ABLE TO HEAR
AND I HAD MANY MANY CASES IN
WHICH YOU KNOW WE TRIED
EVERYTHING AND WE THOUGHT THERE
ARE SPECIAL NEEDS AND JUST
REALIZING THAT JUST NEEDED A
SIMPLE HEARING AID MADE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE WORLD SO.
I'M OWSLEY SUPPORTIVE OF GETTING
THOSE KIDS AND OLDER YOUNGER
ADULTS -- WHAT THEY NEED TO SELL
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FOR
I THINK IT'S ESSENTIAL WITHOUT?
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU IN THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED -- SO SUMMER BLOOM
FIRST VOIGTS -- THAT THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF -- ON
ON ON THIS BILL AND IT'S SO.
YES FIRST OF ALL AS ACM VERY
SENSITIVE WHAT TO WHAT THE
OPPOSITION HAS -- BROUGHT UP --
THIS IS IS THIS WOULD BE THE
FIRST BILL THAT WOULD -- IF IT
BECAME LAW WITH THE EXCEED THE
ESSENTIAL THAT THAT SOMEONE
RECOGNIZE WHAT CENTER MITCHELL
SAID.
ABOUT YOU KNOW WE SHOULD.
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT NOT JUST TO
BE CLEAR -- NO WE PICK A
DIFFERENT PLAN FOR BENCHMARK
PLANNED THAT WILL ALSO HAVE THE
FACTS ON THE OVERALL PREMIUM
RATES ACROSS THE BOARD RIGHT IT
BECOMES AND THE I'M SURE THE
JURORS WOULD SAY.
SIR NOT A YES RIGHT BECAUSE IF
WE PROVIDE A RICHER BENEFIT
PACKAGE IN IN THAT NEGOTIATION
OF THAT WAS ATTENTION RIGHT.
RIGHT YES I AM ITS RIGHT EXACTLY
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT THAT WAS
PART OF THE TENSION WE TRIED TO
DECIDE THE BENCHMARK PLAN AND I
THINK MANY OF US WANTED
SOMETHING A LITTLE.
BROADER -- THEN WE LANDED ON
BECAUSE THERE'S ATTENTION THE
BROADER IT IS THE HIGHER THE
PREMIUMS WILL BE.
AND SO WHEN THAT YOU KNOW AFTER
ALL THE PEOPLE PURCHASE YOUR
PAIN THOSE PREMIUMS AND AND SO
THAT IT THAT WAS THE BACK AND
FORTH AND SO I THINK THAT -- BUT
I THINK WE SHOULD THE NEXT THEN
WE SHOULD BE EXPLORED THAT AND
AND AND SEE EXACTLY WHAT TENSION
IS BECAUSE WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING LIKE HEARING LOSS
PARTICULARLY.
IN KIDS I MEAN THAT DOES BEG THE
QUESTIONS LIKE WHAT THAT
SOMETHING YOU REALLY SHOULD BE
COVERING AND WHY ARE WE NOT
DOING IT SO SO CERTAINLY WE NEED
TO PUT THAT.
TABLE I WOULD I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT IT WAS MENTIONED AND AGAIN
I WANT TO THANK -- THE SEMINAR
FOR WORKING -- WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF YEAH WE DO
PERMITS THE PLANS TO AND GET TO
TO DO SO SOME COST SHARING SO --
TO IT SO THAT THERE IS -- SO
THAT THE PEOPLE BE PRUDENT
PURCHASERS AND JUST NOT TRYING
TO YOU KNOW RUN UP THE LIMITS --
THAT THERE THAT THAT -- SO FORTH --
AND I THINK AGAIN IT'S THOSE ARE
IMPORTANT -- COST MEASURES THAT
HOPEFULLY PROVIDE PEOPLE CHOICE
AND ALLOW THEM TO GET A QUALITY
PRODUCT -- BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
RECOGNIZING WE HAVE TO BE
PRUDENT PURCHASERS WEIRD THE
POLICY COMMITTEE SO I THINK
PROCREATION WE'LL HAVE SOME
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT COST BECAUSE
WE ARE ON THE HOOK.
FOR EVERYONE IN THE INDIVIDUAL
MARKET FOR THE INCREASED COST
AND IN ONE SMALL GROUP MARKET SO
THAT'S GOING TO BE SOMETHING
THAT PROCREATION IS WILL DEAL
WITH.
BUT I WOULD SAY ALSO
FUNDAMENTALLY -- AS A
DEVELOPMENTAL PEDIATRICIAN THE
FIRST QUESTION.
THEY ASK WHEN WE HAVE A CHILD
WHO IS A DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS
CAM DAY HERE AND CAN THEY SEE.
AND IF THE ANSWER IS NO.
AND WE DON'T FIX THAT PROBLEM
AND THEY CAN'T HEAR OR THEY
CAN'T SEE RIGHT IF TROUBLE WITH
THAT.
WE CAN'T GO BEYOND THAT RIGHT WE
IT'S IT'S LIKE -- FIND THE QUEUE
WE KNOW THEY HAVE HEARING LOSS
AND MAYBE THEY HAVE SOME OTHER
THINGS GOING ON BEYOND THAT AND
THAT'S WHY THERE'S DELAYED
SPEECH OR WHATEVER ELSE.
BUT WITHOUT FIXING THE HEARING
YOU JUST CAN'T GO YOU KEEP
THERE'S NOT MUCH MORE.
YOU CAN DO THAT'S GOING TO BE
EFFECTIVE FUNNELED THE HEARING
AND AND SO THAT COST GOES BEYOND
MEDICAL COSTS I MEAN.
AND AND THERE'S CRITICAL PEERS
THE DEVELOPMENT I KNOW THAT --
THE GOOD THAT I DON'T KNOW LIKE
I JUST KNOW THIS IS THAT ONCE A
CRITICAL PERIOD DEVELOPMENT IF
WE DON'T FIX THAT PROBLEM WITHIN
A WINDOW OF TIME IT'S NOT LIKE
WE CAN GO BACK IN TIME AND FIX
IT LATER.
THAT PROBLEM BECOMES MORE
PERMANENT BECAUSE IT ACTUALLY
SHIPS THE WAY THE BRAIN DEVELOPS.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE FIND
THE PROBLEM WE SCREEN FOR THE
PROBLEM WE THAT'S WHAT WE SCREEN
FOR A NEW BUNCH WHEN WE FIND
PROBLEMS SCREEN FRONT OF WE
DON'T ADDRESS IT.
IN A CERTAIN WINDOW OF TIME.
THAT'S A CONSEQUENCE THAT
PERMANENT FOR THAT CHILD IS THE
BECOME AN ADULT THAT.
BECOMES A PERMANENT ISSUE IN
TERMS OF THEIR FUTURE LEARNING
THE PENDULUM NOW OF COURSE
BECOMES A PERMANENT ISSUE BY THE
WAY FOR ALL OF US IS A
COMPASSIONATE SOCIETY.
AND SO THAT'S WHY EVEN THOUGH
I'M VERY RELUCTANT TO GO BEYOND.
THE ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS
THAT -- YOU KNOW I WANTED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
PERHAPS THE REAL SOLUTION IS IN
THE FUTURE IS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO REWORK OUR SEXUAL HEALTH
BENEFITS AND WITH ALL THE
CONSEQUENCES THAT MAY INVOLVE TO
IN TERMS OF COST AND OTHER TYPES
OF THINGS.
SO -- IT MAYBE THAT IS REALLY
AND I APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITE
SAY THAT PRIDE RELEASED THE
BETTER ANSWER IN THE LONG RUN
BUT I FEEL THAT EVEN THE SHORT
RUN WE STILL NEED TO DEAL WITH
THIS AND AND TAKE CARE OF AND
THAT'S WHY I AM GOING.
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY --
SUMMER BLOOM WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU -- ACTUALLY --
MISTER CHAIR YOU HAVE FOR A
REALLY JUST SUMMARIZE SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT -- THAT I WAS
INTENDING TO SAY AND AND CLOSING
COM I THINK THIS ISSUE ABOUT THE
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS AND
KIND OF BREACHING THE THE THE
WALL OPENING UP THE FLOODGATES
AS AS WE HEARD FROM FROM THE
OPPOSITION -- THE LIST -- THE
LEGISLATURE -- AND THE STATE
HAVE BEEN VERY CONSISTENT AND
NOT -- IN IN BEING VERY STRICT
ABOUT -- HOW THESE ITEMS ARE
REVIEWED -- BUT AS YOU SAID
MISTER CHAIR I DOUBT THAT THERE
IS IN YOU WOULD KNOW BTTER THAN
HIGH THAT THERE'S ANYONE ELSE
WHO IS ASKED FOR AN EXCEPTION TO
THE ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFIT ANY
OTHER.
CONDITION THAT WOULD -- INVOLVES
A LIFETIME A POTENTIAL LIFETIME
OF DEVELOPMENTAL DELAY AND
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THIS DIFFERENT
A MATCH IN THESE CHILDREN WHO
ARE HERE TODAY WITH THEIR
PARENTS -- NOT HAVING THE ACCESS
TO HEARING AIDS NOT HAVING THE
AXIS IN THERE ARE -- TWO TO
THREE HUNDRED CHILDREN EVERY
YEAR WHO ARE NOT GETTING HEARING
AIDS HEARING AIDS AT ALL BECAUSE
OF THE COST AND IT'S JUST NOT
HAPPENING -- THOSE CHILDREN.
ARE GOING -- TO BEAR THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT -- DECISION
THAT'S BEING MADE BY US THE
ADULTS IT'S GOING TO AFFECT THEM.
I HAVE.
YES WE MAY BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THIS WHEN THE ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS -- ARE UP FOR REVIEW.
IF WE CHOOSE TO REVIEW THEM.
IF WE DO IT AT A POINT IN TIME
IT'S UNCERTAIN WHEN THAT WOULD.
HAPPEN WE KNOW WHEN IT COULD
START BUT WE DON'T KNOW WHEN IT
WHEN IT ACTUALLY STARTS OR WHEN
IT ACTUALLY FINISHES -- AND THEN
AT THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE A
HUMONGOUS FIGHT OVER WHAT IS
THEN INCLUDED IN THE PLANS AND
THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THIS IS A
THOUSAND CHILDREN THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE.
A RELATIVELY SMALL GROUP OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE -- VERY
LITTLE POLITICAL POWER IN
REALITY COMPARED TO THOSE WHO
WILL BE SEEKING BENEFITS ALL OF
WHICH MAY BE A VERY IMPORTANT
BENEFITS THAT THEY'RE SEEKING SO
THERE'S NO GUARANTEE.
THAT IT WILL HAPPEN THEN AND SO
THEN WHAT FOR ALL OF THOSE
CHILDREN WHO DO NOT.
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ACCESS
HEARING AIDS -- WE NEED TO TAKE
ACTION NOW THIS BILL HAS BEEN
PENDING AS YOU HEARD FOR A LONG
LONG TIME.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THEIR BEHALF.
I THANK YOU CENTER BLOOM SO
DIFFERENT AND IT THAT THOSE BEEN
SET -- MOVED AS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
ACTIVITIES CALL THE ROLL AM I
AND I STONE.
STONE AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROW GROVE I HEARD
TACO.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE MITCHELL
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I'D. SEVEN OF SEVEN VOTES --
THAT'S ENOUGH TO GET THE BILL
OUT WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
I SEE SOMEONE WERE RIVAS HERE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE -- I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
HERE.
BEEN WAITING FOR A WHILE SO WE
HAVE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A. B.
[inaudible]
NINE TWENTY NINE YES.
AT ISSUE WELCOME.
THANK YOU inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
CLOSELY WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS
BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS A MOCK UP
VERSION OF THE LANGUAGE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN PASSED OUT.
I'M EXCITED TO PRESENT AB NINE
TWO NINE WHICH INSURERS COVERED
CALIFORNIA HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
COLLECT THE DATA IT NEEDS TO
FULLY EVALUATE IF THE HEALTH
PLAN IS LOWERING COSTS.
IMPROVING QUALITY AND REDUCING
HEALTH DISPARITIES.
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES THAT THE
DATA IS DISAGGREGATED AND
PUBLISHED BY HEALTH PLAN.
CURRENTLY COVERED CALIFORNIA
DOESN'T HAVE THE ABILITY
DIRECTLY ACCESS THE DATA IT
NEEDS TO SEE OF HEALTH
DISPARITIES ARE ACTUALLY BEING
REDUCED.
THEY ALSO DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DISAGGREGATED DATA BY
HEALTH PLAN.
WHEN THIS LEGISLATOR CREATED
COVERED CALIFORNIA IT GAVE
COVERED CALIFORNIA AUTHORITY TO
BE AN ACTIVE PURCHASER THAT
NEGOTIATED ON COST AND QUALITY?
COVERED CALIFORNIA HAS DONE THIS
ON BEHALF OF CONSUMERS WHO BUY
COVERAGE AS INDIVIDUALS.
LOOKING UP PLANS SPECIFIC DATA
ON COST QUALITY AND HEALTH
DISPARITIES CAN HELP US BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEMS WHETHER
IT'S ACCESS TO CARE OR HEALTH
DISPARITIES BETWEEN GROUPS.
THE PROCESS TO ELIMINATING
HEALTH DISPARITIES AND
INEQUITIES STARTS WITH HIGH
QUALITY DATA AND AB.
NINETY NINE IS THE FIRST STEP --
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE -- BUT TO FURTHER
SPEAK ON THIS BILL I HAVE A FEW
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WITH ME
TODAY FROM HEALTH ACCESS AND
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK.
THANK YOU SIX MINUTES TOTAL YOU
CAN DO LESS OF YOURS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN AND JDS
HERE ON BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE STATE WIDE HEALTH
CARE CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION.
PRACTICAL SPONSOR AB NINETY NINE
WOULD SEE PAN AB NINETY NINE
WOULD ENSURE COVER CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLAN DATA ON COST QUALITY
HEALTH DISPARITIES.
IS COLLECTED AND PUBLISHED.
COVER CALIFORNIA IS UNIQUELY
POSITIONED TO USE ITS.
AUTHORITY AS AN ACTIVE PURCHASE
PURCHASER TO NEGOTIATE WITH
HEALTH PLANS TO ADVANCE DELIVERY
SYSTEMS IMPROVEMENT AND QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT.
SINCE THE CREATION OF COVERED
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO THE
ATTACHMENT SEVEN CONTRACT
PROVISION IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN PUBLIC REPORTING ON
PLAN SPECIFIC CONTRACT
COMPLIANCE WITH REQUIREMENTS ON
COST.
QUALITY AND DISPARITY DATA HAS
BEEN THE STATED GOAL.
RECENT AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
ENSURES COMPLIANCE WITH THESE
CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATIONS THAT THE
HEALTH PLANS ACTUALLY HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH.
AB NINETY NINE DOES NOT CREATE
NEW REPORTING REQUIREMENTS IT
MERELY ENSURES HEALTH PLANS MEET
THEIR EXISTING CONTRACTUAL
OBLIGATIONS.
AB NINETY NINE ALSO AUTHORIZES
COVER CALIFORNIA TO BECOME A
HEALTH OVERSIGHT AND TO T. UNDER
HIPPA.
SO THAT IT CAN SAFE GUARD
IMPORTANT DATA AND PERSONAL
HEALTH INFORMATION.
THIS IS REALLY INTENDED TO
CREATE ANOTHER LEVEL OF
PROTECTION AND SECURITY SO THAT
PERSONAL INFORMATION AND DATA
SHALL ONLY BE USE FOR HIPPA.
PERMITTED OVERSIGHT ACTIVITIES --
LASTLY AB NINETY NINE ALSO
PROTECTS CONFIDENTIAL AND
CONTRACTED RATES BETWEEN HEALTH
PLANS PROVIDERS SUCH AS DOCTORS
AND HOSPITALS AND ANY OTHER
COSTS DETAILED.
SUCH AS COINSURANCE THAT COULD
BE USED TO INFER CONTRACTED
RATES.
COVER CALIFORNIA HAS NOT BEEN
ABLE TO MAKE -- PUBLIC PLAN BY
PLAN COMPARISONS BECAUSE OF THE
PLANTS HAVE ASSERTED THAT DATE
ON QUALITY AND DISPARITIES IS
PROPRIETARY.
BUT BECAUSE THE DATA IS ALSO NOT
AVAILABLE IN A USEFUL MANNER
COVER CALIFORNIA POLICYMAKERS
ADVOCATES AS WELL AS RESEARCHERS
ARE NOT ABLE TO USE THE
INFORMATION TO THE TERM IN WHICH
PLANS ARE ACTUALLY EFFECTIVELY.
WITH IMPROVING QUALITY AND
REDUCING DISPARITIES DATA IS
REALLY ESSENTIAL -- AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE REQUEST FULLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IDOL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS MARKETS
GOT THROUGH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK --
THIS PART OF THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CONTRACTOR GARMENTS
HEALTH PLANS WERE REQUIRED TO
SHOW PROGRESS TOWARDS.
HEALTH DISPARITIES REDUCTION BY
RACE ETHNICITY AND GENDER IN KEY
TARGET AREAS WERE DOCUMENTED
DISPARITIES EXISTED INCLUDING
DIABETES HYPERTENSION ASTHMA AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH -- THE FIRST
SET OF DATA COLLECTED FROM THE
PLANS FOR THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN YEAR WAS DISCLOSED
EARLIER THIS YEAR -- BUT IS
PRESENT IN ACCURATE FASHION AND
STATED FINING SUCH AS THE BEST
PERFORMING PLANNED RANKED ABOVE
THE NINETIETH PERCENTILE IN IT
FOR DIABETES CONTROL NATIONWIDE
WHILE THE LOWEST PERFORMING PLAN
RANKED BELOW THE FIFTIETH
PERCENTILE -- IN TERMS OF
ADDRESSING HEALTH DISPARITIES
THIS IS CONCERNING BECAUSE DATA
SHOWING THAT IN CALIFORNIA A
TINO'S AN AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE.
HAVE TWICE THE PREVALENCE OF
TYPE TWO DIABETES AND ARE TWICE
AS LIKELY TO DIE FROM THE
DISEASE.
RECENT AMENDMENTS -- TAKEN HELP
CLARIFY THE SPECIFIC DATA --
THAT MUST BE REPORTED ON ON A
PLAN BY PLAN BASIS AND ALSO
REQUIRE ALL OFF SIXTEEN SMALL
MARKET.
DATA TO BE REPORTED SO THAT WE
HAVE SUFFICIENT DATA AND CAN --
DO QUALITY IMPROVEMENT WORK IN
THE INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
MARKET -- BREAKING DOWN THE DATA
OF BREAKING DOWN THE ALREADY
COLLECTED DATA FURTHER IT WOULD
ALLOW US TO SEE WHICH PLANS ARE
PERFORMING WELL AND HOW TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE PRACTICES IN THE
FRONT AND THE PLANS ARE LAGGING
BEHIND.
HEALTH DISPARITIES INEQUITIES --
CAN ONLY BE ELIMINATED IF THERE
IS HIGH QUALITY DATA AVAILABLE
TO MORROW -- TO A AND TO MONITOR
THE PROBLEMS WITHIN THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEMS AB
NINETY NINE IT WOULD GIVE US A
BETTER VIEW OF THAT DATA AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR AB NINETY NINE AND
REQUEST DRIVE THOUGH.
AND BEFORE YOU MOVE AND COVER
CALIFORNIA'S ALSO HERE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
OKAY.
TELLING.
YOU INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
AT AT THE CHAIRS PLEASURE AT MR
TEAR MEMBERS KELLY GREEN
DIRECTOR OF EXTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR
COVER CALIFORNIA.
I'VE KATIE RAVEL HERE DIRECTOR
OF POLICY ELIGIBILITY IN
RESEARCH AND BRANDON ROSS OUR
ASSISTANT GENERAL CUNSEL AGAIN
HERE FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THANK YOU JUST.
A HELPFUL TO HAVE THE
INTRODUCTIONS OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES A SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK WINDOWS
WITH THAT CA YOU CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND FLORA ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MORALE IS AGO REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BOUNDING FROM ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT AB
NINETY NINE THANK YOU.
YOUR HUNGER DENNIS ON BEHALF OF
THE LATINO COMMISSION FOR HELP
TO CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HEY THIS IS IN OPPOSITION AND
NEED SOME.
EXTRA ROOM FOR THEM AT THE TABLE
PLEASE.
EITHER SCOOT AROUND -- DOWN.
I THINK THEY NEED TO SUCCEED
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS NICK LOUISE US ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS -- WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED A POSITION
ON THE BILL -- SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME -- YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
POINTS I'D LIKE TO MAKE RIGHT
OUT THE GATE IS THAT -- YOU KNOW
WE DON'T VIEW THIS AS A SIMPLE
TRANSPARENCY BILL WE WE VIEWED
AS AS MUCH MORE -- AB EIGHT NINE
TWO NINE EXPRESSLY CONVERTS
COVER CALIFORNIA INTO A HEALTH
CARE OVERSIGHT AGENCY -- OR
TERMS TO DO THREE SO THREE STATE
LAW.
THIS IS A CHANGE OVER ITS
EXISTING POSITION AS AN ACTIVE
PURCHASER OF HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE -- ANY CHANGES THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN ON THE
EXCHANGE AND A QUALIFIED HEALTH
PLANS.
THIS CHANGE IN AN OF ITSELF MAY
NOT BE INHERENTLY OBJECTIONABLE --
WHICH IS WHY WE ARE NOT -- THE
STREET OPPOSE ON THE BILL ON
THERE COULD BE BENEFITS TO THIS
ARRANGEMENT -- HAVING SAID THAT
WE DO HAVE SEVERAL QUESTIONS AND
CONCERNS ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS
OF THIS POLICY ARE PARTICULARLY
AS IT RELATES TO THE DATA
SUBMISSION COMPONENTS OF THE
BILL -- FIRST CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH PLANS ORAL ALREADY WHO
REGULATED BY A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT STATE ENTITIES -- THAT
CAN REQUEST VARIOUS LEVELS OF
DATA.
INFORMATION FOR MY MEMBERS -- SO
YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS HAVE THAT
CONCERN THAT YOU KNOW
LEGISLATION -- ADDS TO YOU KNOW
UNNECESSARY DUPLICATION
REGULATORY OVERLAP -- WITH OTHER
FUNCTIONS.
I'M SECOND AS A KIND OF ALLUDED
TO EARLIER -- IT'S UNCLEAR --
TEST AT LEAST WITH THE STATE OR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MUST MAKE
THIS NEW OVERSIGHT --
DESIGNATION -- EVEN IF THE STATE
DOES HAVE THIS POWER -- YOU KNOW
OUR PART THE NEXT SET OF
QUESTIONS OVER WHETHER FEDERAL
LAW AND REGULATIONS --
CONTEMPLATE -- FOR OR ALLOW FOR
THE SUBSTANTIAL DATA SUBMISSION
ON THAT IS REQUIRED -- UNDER
THIS BILL.
COME WE HAVE QUESTIONS WITH THE
CONGRESS OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- ENVISIONED A STATE
BASED EXCHANGE COLLECTING ON THE
AMOUNTS OF DETAILED A PERSONAL
HEALTH INFORMATION AND A
PROVIDER RATE INFORMATION ON
THAT IS REQUIRED AND IN THIS
BILL.
UNDER NINE TWO NINE OF THE
DEFINITION OF HEALTH OVERSIGHT
FUNCTIONS INCLUDES A MANDATE FOR
GENERALIZED DATA.
COLLECTION WHICH IS VERY BROAD
INTO THE COULD GO BEYOND THE
RECOGNIZE FUNCTIONS UNDER THE
HIPPA REGULATIONS -- THE HIPPA
REGULATIONS PERMIT LIMITED
DISCLOSURE OF HEALTH OVERSIGHT
AGENCIES -- AND IT ALSO INCLUDES
LANGUAGE AROUND A MINIMUM TO SET
NECESSARY -- STANDARD -- THAT
APPLIES TO DISCLOSURES FROM
PLANS TO V. DESIGNATED HEALTH
OVERSIGHT ENTITY -- INDEED THE
PREAMBLE OF THE HIPPA
REGULATIONS ON THIS MATTER
INCLUDES THE LINE -- WE DO NOT
INTEND FOR THE RULES PERMISSIVE
APPROACH TO HEALTH OVERSIGHT OR
THE ABSENCE OF SPECIFIC
DOCUMENTATION TO PERMIT THE
GOVERNMENT.
TO GATHER LARGE AMOUNTS OF
PROTECTED HEALTH INFORMATION FOR
PURPOSES UNRELATED TO HEALTH
OVERSIGHT -- SO YOU KNOW WE CUT
WERE.
TAKING A LOOK AT THIS BILL IT
WAS JUST AMENDED -- ABOUT A WEEK
AND A HALF AGO.
WE HAVE HAD SOME EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
AND SPONSORS WHICH WE FOUND TO
BE MEANINGFUL HELPFUL BUT YOU
KNOW.
WE DO VIEW AS THE BILL --
REQUIRING A PRETTY EXPANSIVE
COLLECTION OF DETAILED PERSONAL
HEALTH INFORMATION IN PROVIDER
RATES AND THAT ALWAYS MAKES US
UNCOMFORTABLE BECAUSE REVIEW
THAT INFORMATION IS PROPRIETARY
IN NATURE.
SOME.
THE MEASURE ALSO JUST REQUIRES
DISCLOSURE OF X..
AND PUBLIC EXPOSURE OF OFF
EXCHANGE DATA IN INFORMATION
RELATED TO MARKETS THAT ARE
OUTSIDE THE PURVIEW OF COVERED
CALIFORNIA -- INCLUDING DATA
RELATED TO THE EMPLOYER MARKETS
AND MEDI CAL OF COURSE WE WOULD
HAVE REGULATORS OVER MEDI CAL
AND OVER ON THE EMPLOYER MARKETS
AND WE DON'T BELIEVE THERE IS A
CLEAR JUSTIFICATION FOR WHY
COVER CALIFORNIA NEEDS IS DATA.
FOR MARKETS IT DOESN'T OVERSEE
WILL DOESN'T OVERSEE YET --
TECHNICALLY ARE OR HOW THEY WILL
USE IT -- AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT
PORTION OF THE BILL NEEDS TO BE
TAKEN OUT -- MUCH OF THE
INFORMATION THAT WILL BE
TRANSFERRED TO COVER CALIFORNIA --
IS PROPRIETARY NATURE -- WELL
THERE'S AN ATTEMPT IN THE BILL
TO LIMIT THE PUBLIC EXPOSURE OF
PROPRIETARY DATA.
THE BILL STILL REQUIRES A
SUBMISSION OF SENSITIVE DATA TO
THE HEALTH OVERSIGHT AGENCY.
OR ENTITY -- AND NOT ALL OF THE
INFORMATION IS PROTECTED UNDER
THE BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM --
IS THAT WE CONSIDER PROPRIETARY
IS PROTECTED -- UNDER THE BILL --
FOR INSTANCE LIKE TO SPECIFIC
STRATEGIES AND TECHNIQUES OF
PLANS USED TO LOWER COST REDUCE
HEALTH DISPARITIES IN INCREASE
QUALITY.
ON TEMPLE INVOLVE UNIQUE PAYMENT
ARRANGEMENTS BETWEEN THE PLANS
IN THE PROVIDERS -- AND THIS
INVOLVES INCENTIVES AND
DISINCENTIVES USED TO DRIVE A
QUALITY AND DRIVE DOWN ON
DISPARITIES -- THE PLANS OF
COURSE DON'T WANT THEIR
COMPETITORS TO EVER GET A HOLD
OF THIS INFORMATION -- AND WE'RE
NOT SURE THE PROVIDERS WOULD
WANT THIS INFORMATION REVEALED
AS WELL.
HARMS THE MARKET AND COMPLICATES
OUR EFFORTS IN THESE AREAS -- WE
DO UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
COMBATING HEALTH DISPARITIES IN
MAKING QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS --
YOU KNOW THE OTHER POINT WILL
MAKE YOU SOME OF THE DATA
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE ISSUES ARE
NOT CONSISTENT AMONG PLANS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT STANDARDIZED
BY ANY TYPE OF ACCREDITING
ORGANIZATION OR ANYTHING LIKE
THAT.
SO NOT SURE HOW USE LITTLE IT'LL
BE.
AND HE'LL BE A STRUGGLE TO DO AN
APPLES TO APPLES COMPARISON OF
THE DATA ON THAT WOULD BE
REVEALED A PUBLICLY -- FINALLY --
ORGANIZATIONS PARTICIPATING IN
THE HEALTH PAYMENTS DATA REVIEW
COMMITTEE THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
UNDER EIGHTY EIGHT TEN LAST YEAR --
THE PURPOSE OF THIS COMMITTEE IS
TO ESTABLISH A COSTS DATABASE --
USED TO INFORM POLICY DECISIONS
REGARDING THE PROVISION OF OF
QUALITY HEALTHCARE -- INTO --
LOOK AT REDUCING THE COST OF
CARE INTO SUPPORTING GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AMONG ALL MARKET SO
IT TAKES A COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW --
WERE ON THE BOARD OR THE WORK
GROUP IF YOU WILL ON THAT AND SO
WE'RE WORKING -- TO TO THAT IN A
MORE THOUGHTFUL COMPREHENSIVE
MATTER THAT'S BEING CONTEMPLATED
BY THIS BILL.
SO -- YOU KNOW IN SHORTS -- YOU
KNOW THE CONVERSATIONS HAVE BEEN
PRODUCTIVE YOU KNOW THEM IF THE
BILL MOVES TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSOR.
AGAIN WE DON'T VIEW CONCEPTUALLY
THE IDEA OF TRANS.
MAKING COVER CALIFORNIA HEALTH
OVERSIGHT AGENCY IS
OBJECTIONABLE IN AND OF ITSELF.
THE BILL NEEDS TO BE SCALED DOWN
CONSIDERABLY FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE AND WE LIKE TO SHARE
SOME IDEAS MOVING FORWARD ON
THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- WE'RE OUT OF TIME
FOR TESTIMONY CAN INTRODUCE
YOURSELF.
BUTJUST BRIEFLY MR CHECK KIND
OF A A TWEENER WITH CONCERNS --
BRANDON MARCH WITH CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION WE DON'T
HAVE AN OFFICIAL AN OFFICIAL
POSITION N THE BILL -- AS OUR
PROCESS -- ON LOOKING AT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WENT ON THURSDAY
ONLY CONCLUDED TODAY -- WE DO
HAVE A COMMITMENT FROM THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH US TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS -- AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT AND
APOLOGIZE FOR OUR LEE CONCERNS.
OKAY.
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOUR CONCERNS ARE BUT I'M WE
HAVE CONCERNS SHE WORKED WITH
THE AUTHOR ON THE BUT IT'S STILL
IT'S IT WAS THE INTENT WE ARE
TOLD THE INTENT OF THE BILL WAS
NOT TO BRING PROVIDERS IN -- TO
THE REPORTING PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL REGARDING RATES AND THINGS
LIKE THAT -- AND WE ALSO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS IN THE
BILL FOR THAT INFORMATION -- BUT
I THINK THAT THE MARKET THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE GOES A LONG WAY -- IN
ADDRESSING THOSE SO AGAIN JUST
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
BACK MICROPHONE.
SEEING NONE ALL RIGHT QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY A CENTER GROWTH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AT I I DO
HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE BROUGHT FORTH
ARE YOU GOING TO CONTINUE WORK
WITH -- BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A
GOOD BILL I DO BUT NOW THAT IT
IS BECAUSE OF MY ANALYSIS IS NO
OPPOSITION SO DID YOU GET YOUR
OPPOSITION LATE BECAUSE I DON'T
HAVE AN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ON IT.
I'M SORRY WOULD LIKE ME TO DRESS
AT YES YES -- I'D I DO GET IT IN --
HI IN.
YEAH THE BILL WAS SUBSTANTIALLY
AMENDED VERY RECENTLY -- CENTER
WE DID OUR BEST TO DO OUR
ANALYSIS AND GET OUR LETTER IN
ON TIME SO -- I GET IT THIRTEEN
HUNDRED BILLS I MEAN I GET IT OR
MORE IN THE THESE ARE VERY
SUBSTANTIAL AMENDMENTS AND I'M
JUST LOOKING AT NEW AMENDMENTS I
JUST GOT HANDED SO OKAY.
YES I I APOLOGIZE.
BOTH A COMMITMENT THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK AS I WAS SO
THAT WE HAVE -- A REALLY GOOD
BILL MOVING FORWARD BUT I THINK
IT'S A GOOD DEAL NOW BUT I THINK
IT CAN BE A LITTLE BIT BETTER IF
WE ADDRESS THE CONCERNS BECAUSE
THERE ARE CONCERNS.
ABOUT DISCLOSURE HIPPA
VIOLATIONS ALL THESE THINGS THAT
HAVE TO BE AS CLOSE RATE
INFORMATION THAT YOU KNOW WE
DON'T WANT IT'S THE SAME AS A
REAL FORMULAS FOR PERFUME OR OIL
OR ANYTHING ELSE RIGHT
UNDERSTAND WE DON'T WANT. TO
SHARE ANYTHING PROPRIETARY --
FROM THE HEALTH PLANS AND SO WE
ARE -- A CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS
WITH BOTH THE HEALTH PLANS AND
CMA TO ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS
BOTH MY MYSELF AND THE SPONSORS
ARE COMMITTED I'M TO WORKING
WITH THEM.
OKAY THAT SATISFACTORY TO YOU.
WHEN WHEN WE'RE READY TO ENGAGE
SOME IDEAS WILL WE WILL DO THAT
BUT -- IT DOES HAVE SUBSTANTIAL.
QUESTIONS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED BUT YES WE WE LOOK FOR
THOSE CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU
OKAY SIR TO TADA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
SO I JUST WANNA ECHO WITH TWO OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD --
YOU KNOW UNSTATED.
I WANT TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
AT IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S SOME
ISSUES BUT IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE
WORKING -- AT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES IN
THOSE CONCERNS AND YOU KNOW I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT
COMES -- TO US AT YOU KNOW AT
THE FLOOR IF THAT.
ENDS UP HAPPENING AND WE GET IT
OUT TODAY -- BUT IN ALSO ONE AND
PUT IT OUT THERE THAT IF.
THE CITY YOU KNOW THINGS ARE NOT
WORKED ON THEY ALSO RESERVE BY
RIGHT TO TO NOT SUPPORTED WHEN
IT COMES TO THE FLOOR.
BUT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO -- SEEN OTHER -- SUFFERS FIRE
AS A MEMBER OF THE U. S. -- ONE
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THE
AMENDMENTS I THINK -- THOSE WERE
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES I KNOW THERE'S SOME MORE
ISSUES THAT WERE BROUGHT UP HERE
IN THE HEARING APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION'S AND WINNERS ON
THOSE ISSUES -- I DO THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT WE TRY TO GET
INFORMATION OUT -- ABOUT -- YOU
KNOW HEALTH DISPARITIES THAT --
IS THE TERMS OF OVERSIGHT THAT --
WE NEED TO NEEDS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY -- AROUND THAT AS
WELL -- AND CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
SOME ISSUES AROUND --
PROPRIETARY IN PAYMENT BUT IT --
AND AND THOSE ARE IMPORTANT BUT
WE WANT I AND NOW I THINK THE
GOALS YOUR BILL A REALLY
IMPORTANT WELL WE NEED TO SELL
PLEDGING ON THE WORKING WITH THE
OUT OF THE OPPOSITION EARNERS
THE OPPOSITION AND CLEANERS AND
SORT THAT OUT BUT I THE LA
DEPRECIATE AT WHAT.
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO TO BE SURE
THAT -- WE HAVE TO TRANSPARENCY
IN THAT -- IN A VERY DIVERSE
STATE THAT WE HAVE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY IS NECESSARY --
TO BE SURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
ARE BEING SERVICED SO.
WHICH WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION TODAY -- AND I COMMIT
TO WORKING WITH HEALTH PLANS AND
CMA ON THIS BILL ON AND THE
LANGUAGE YOU KNOW AS AN ACTIVE
PURCHASER COVER CALIFORNIA WAS
TASKED WITH HELPING.
INDIVIDUALS ACCESS QUALITY
HEALTH COVERAGE AT AN AFFORDABLE
RATE BUT WITHOUT ACCESS TO THE
DATA -- COVERED CALIFORNIA
CANNOT PROPERLY MEET ITS
RESPONSIBILITIES AS AN ACTIVE
PURCHASER OF YOU TO THE STATE --
CAN GRANT AUTHORITY -- AND THIS
BILL DOES GRANT EXPRESSED OF
THIRTY TO TO BECOME FOR COVER
CALIFORNIA TO BECOME A A HEALTH
OVERSIGHT ENTITY UNDER HAVE BY.
OUR ISN'T IT ALSO CLARIFIES WHAT
TYPE OF DATA THE PLAN SHOULD BE
REPORTING -- TO COVER CALIFORNIA --
THIS IS DATA THE PLANS ARE
ALREADY REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
UNDER THEIR CONTRACTS TO
PARTICIPATE AND SELL THEIR
PRODUCTS IN THE EXCHANGE.
A WITH THIS BILL COVERED
CALIFORNIA WILL BE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE WHICH HEALTH PLANS
ARE DELIVERING ON THEIR PROMISE
SAYS OF QUALITY AND IMPROVE CARE --
TO OUR RESIDENTS -- THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
ISN'T SO THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED --
BY SIR LEYVA AND THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED OR FOR TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS SIX
THREE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AN HI AND I A STONE.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I'D GROW.
HER TADO HER TITLE ON A LEYVA
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL MONNING RUBIO
[inaudible] FOUR EARLIER FOR
BOTH SAVILE BUT THE BILL ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
RIGHT I SEE CENTER KARA HERE AND
I UNDERSTAND IT YOUR DIFFERING
ZERO THREE BILLS UP ANYWAY TO
SOMEONE OVER WOODS WELCOME.
SO THE WITH THE SUMMER WOULD SO
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB.
NINE FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR AND MEMBERS SAYING
WITH ROSS OFFENDERS.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS HOUSE
AT DOCTOR CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO START -- BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE IN THEIR
STAFF FOR THE WORK ON THE BILL
AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE SO SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS.
A NETWORK LEASING ARRANGEMENTS --
PRESENT NUMEROUS PROBLEMS FOR
THE DENTIST AND THEIR PATIENTS
THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO FIX
THESE PROBLEMS WITH THE NUMBERS.
CONTINUING TO GROW -- CURRENTLY
THE ENTITIES THAT LEASE OR
PURCHASE NETWORKS HAVE LIMITED
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE TRANSPARENT
AND IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHICH FEE
SCHEDULES ARE IN EFFECT FOR
PATIENTS.
DENNIS ARE SENSITIVE TO PRICES --
THE PRICE CONCERNS THEIR
PATIENTS HAVE AND THEY NEED THIS
TRANSPARENCY TO BE ABLE TO
CLEARLY DISCUSS TREATMENT
OPTIONS IN OUT OF POCKET COST
WITH THEM.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW FOR
EXAMPLE DENTAL PLANS TO GRANT
THIRD PARTY ACCESS TO PROVIDER
NETWORK SO THAT PROVIDERS
CLEARLY KNOW THEIR CONTRACT
GRANTS THIRD PARTY ACCESS TO THE
PROVIDER NETWORK.
AND THAT.
I IS A PROVIDER HAVE THE RIGHT
TO CHOOSE NOT TO PARTICIPATE
YOUR TESTIFIED SUPPORT MANY AND
ANSWERING QUESTIONS BRANAGH CAM
AND SPENCER WITH CDS.
WELCOME A GOOD AFTERNOON TURN
NUMBERS -- WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING FORWARD THIS
I'M VERY IMPORTANT VERY AND EACH
ISSUE -- AB NINE FIFTY FOUR IS
REALLY JUST GONNA BRING MORE
TRANSPARENCY THE GOAL IS TO MAKE
SURE THE DENNIS KNOW WHAT PLANS
ARE IN CONTRACT WITH.
THAT THEY KNOW WHAT THE TERMS OF
THOSE CONTRACTS ARE AND THAT
THEY CAN OPT OUT IF THEY SO
CHOOSE WE'VE BEEN VERY PLEASED
TO WORK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF DENTALPLANS TO
ADDRESS THEIR TECHNICAL CONCERNS
AND VERY GLAD TO HAVE THEM IN
SUPPORT.
CHRISTY WITH SOME RAP THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF DENTAL
PLANS AND SUPPORT WE SHARE THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS DESIRE TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
ARE CONTRACTED DENNIS UNDERSTAND
ALL THE TERMS OF THE CONTRACT
THEY'VE ENTERED INTO AND WE'VE
BEEN HAPPY TO WORK WITH THEM ON
AMENDMENTS AND SO AFTER I VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
OKAY ME WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU CENTER WOULD
I WILL BACK HE EXPAND THIS BILL
INCLUDE DOCTORS -- LOVE YOU FOR
IT THERE YOU GO OKAY WELL.
THANK YOU I'VE CERTAINLY BEEN
SUPPORT THE BILL WHICH LIKE THE
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
IPHONE OKAY THANK YOU SO THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED THE MOTION IS
TO PASS ASAMENDED AND THANKS SO
MUCH FOR TAKING AMENDMENTS TO
PASS AS AMENDED.
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AND I AND I STONE STONE NINE
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROVE GROVE
I HEARD TOTO. FOR TITLE I LEYVA
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL MONNING RUBIO.
THE BILL HAS SIX VOTES IT'S
ENOUGH TO GET OUT WILL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU.
RIGHT SEVERAL KARA WELCOME SO
WHY SHOULD WE TAKE YOUR BILL YOU
HAVE THREE BILLS WHO WOULD TAKE
THEM AND FOLLOW ORDER NUMBER
THAT'S FINE OKAY SO WE'LL.
START OFF WITH ITEM NUMBER --
TWO EIGHTY THIRTY FIVE THAT'S
WORKER SAFETY PUT.
UP BLOOD LEAD LEVELS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- AB
THIRTY FIVE WOULD IMPROVE HOW
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE MADE
AWARE OF AND HANDLE CASES OF
THAT PLACING AMONG WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WOULD HELP
PREVENT.
REPEATED OR PROLONGED INCIDENTS
OF LEAD POISONING AND WORKPLACES.
AS WE ALL KNOW THAT CAN HAVE
PROFOUND AND PERMANENT ADVERSE
HEALTH EFFECTS OF THE CHILDREN
ADULTS AND HIGH LEVELS LEAD
POISONING CAN BE FATAL.
PROLONGED REPEATED CASES OF LEAD
POISONING ARE ENTIRELY
PREVENTABLE BUT THE PROTOCOLS IN
PLACE CURRENTLY DO NOT WORK.
AT THIS TIME THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH HAS DISCRETION
WHETHER IT'S FOR FOR A CASE OF
THAT PLAYS INTO CAL OSHA.
AS A RESULT MANY EMPLOYEES TO
REMAIN VULNERABLE TO REPEATED
THAT EXPOSURE FOR INDETERMINATE
MASS THE TIME BEFORE THE ISSUE
IS PROPERLY ADDRESS.
THIS LOCKS ADMINISTRATION -- Là
LEASE TO CASES LIKE THE RECENTLY
DISCOVERED GUN RANGE MORE PETERS
WERE SUCH HIGH LEVELS OF LEAD
RIPPING SPREAD INTO THE
SURROUNDING AREA.
OF THE ADJACENT CHILDREN'S
GYMNASTICS CENTER AFTER TESTING
FOR HIGH LEAD LEVELS HOW TO BE
SHATTERED AND THE CHILDREN NOW
BEING TEST FOR LEAD POISONING.
AB THIRTY FIVE IS A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO HELP ENSURE THAT
PROPER NOTIFICATIONS AND FOLLOW
UP BETWEEN DEVIATION THE P. H.
AND CAL OSHA ARE MADE.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT PRESENT AND
FUTURE WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
THIS BILL SIMPLY REQUIRES CAL
OSHA TO INVESTIGATE WORK SIZE TO
HAVE ORKERS WITH ELEVATED BLOOD
LEAD LEVELS UPON RECEIVING SUCH
REPORTS.
FROM DPH WORKER SAFETY SHOULD BE
PARAMOUNT NOT JUST TO BUSINESSES
BUT ALSO TO THE AGENCY TASS WITH
PROTECTING -- THESE WORKERS BUT
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
I THINK YOU IN THIS IS SUPPORT
FARM BILL ALLEY -- SPONSORING
THE BILL -- FOR ENVIRONMENT
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP --
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT BILL
FOR WORKERS SAFETY YES -- THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH'S
OCCUPATIONAL LEAD POISONING
PREVENTION.
PROGRAM HAS SOME AUTHORITY IN
THIS AREA BUT THEY'VE FALLEN
DOWN ON THE JOB WE HAVE REPEATED
HIGH BLOOD THAT LEVELS FOR
WORKERS AT A ARIETY OF
INDUSTRIES.
THE WORST BEING GUN RANGES AND
BATTERY RECYCLERS BUT IT THERE'S
DOZENS OF MORE INDUSTRIES WERE
PEOPLE ARE EXPOSED TO LEAD.
THIS BILL DOESN'T SAY FIND
SOMEONE IN FOR SITE DAMAGES SAYS
HANDOVER TO CAL OSHA GO OUT AND
TAKE A LOOK THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT HELPS --
L. P. P. P. BUT IF NEED BE THEY
COULD FIND THAT SIX MONTHS TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO.
AND WE THINK THAT'S PLENTY OF
TIME TO RESOLVE IT IN A
CONVERSATIONS WITH CAL OSHA.
THEY SAID -- THEY HAVE TO HAVE
STRONG EVIDENCE TO ISSUE A FINER
CITATION ANYWAY THE IMPORTANT
THING IS WE WANT A DIFFERENT
AGENCY LOOKING AT THIS BECAUSE
FRANKLY.
I THE O. L. P. P. P. HAS NOT
DONE A GOOD JOB OF KNOCKING
THESE BY THE LEVELS DOWN ALSO IF
THE LEVELS ARE BELOW TWENTY ONE
MICROGRAMS PER DECILITER THEY
CAN WORK WITH ALL THOSE HUNDREDS
OF WORKERS IF NOT THOUSANDS IN
THE STATE. TO FIND OUT WHY SOME
AS TENER EIGHTEEN BUT NOT THE
ALARM BELL LEVEL OF TWENTY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS MUCH
TIGHTER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THAT WE SEE IS JUST A MEASURE TO
DIRECT ONE AGENCY TO TRANSFER
DATA TO ANOTHER THAT THE LATTER
NEEDS TO ADEQUATELY PERFORM ITS
DUTY OF IN THIS CASE KEEPING
WORKERS SAFE ON THE JOB.
IT'S EXTREMELY HARD TO THINK OF
REASONS TO ESSENTIALLY KEEP.
HIDING THE STATE OF FROM CAL
OSHA WHICH IS ARGUABLY WHAT
HAPPENED UNDER THE CURRENT
SYSTEM WHERE SOMETIMES IS
TRANSFERRED OVER SOMETIMES IT'S
NOT.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN A HAZARDOUS
INSIDIOUS AS LEAD EXPOSURE AND
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT WE'VE GOT
A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM IN THE
WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY WORLD
WITH CALIBRATION NOT.
ALREADY RECEIVING INFORMATION
THAT THEY'RE ENTITLED TO WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR FACILITIES AND
SERIOUS ACCIDENTS CALLUSES
SUPPOSED TO BE NOTIFIED OF THOSE
IN EIGHT HOURS.
ABOUT HALF THE TIME THEY'RE
NEVER NOTIFIED BY THE EMPLOYER
ORTHE FIRST RESPONDER WITH
RESPECT TO COMPLAINTS -- CAN A
WORKERS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
PROTECTED FROM RETALIATION WHEN
THEY REPORT COMPLAINTS BUT IT'S
SO COMMON THAT WE ESSENTIALLY
HAVE TO COUNSEL WORKERS THAT.
VERY POSSIBLY GOING TO GET FIRED
IS COMMITTED AGAINST THE REPORT
THIS SO.
ALL ACROSS THE BOARD IN WORKER
HEALTH AND SAFETY WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO GET MORE
INFORMATION INTO THE HANDS OF
COLLEGE OF RATHER THAN LAST.
AND WITH LEAD EXPOSURE IT'S
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY
ONCE WE GOT A BLOOD LEAD LEVEL
OF OF OF TWENTY MICROGRAMS PER
DECILITER.
THAT'S BY DEFINITION OF A
SERIOUS PHYSICAL AND A SERIOUS
PHYSICAL HARM IN THAT IT MEETS
THE CRITERIA FOR BEING A SERIOUS
VIOLATION OF WHEN THE CALLS FOR
INVESTIGATION BY CAL OSHA.
AND AGAIN AS MENTIONED THIS BILL
DOESN'T REQUIRE AN INSPECTION
ALL IT DOES IS GIVE THE
APPROPRIATE INFORMATION TO THE
APPROPRIATE AGENCIES SO THAT
THEY CAN MAKE A DETERMINATION
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT REQUIRES
A PHYSICAL INSPECTION AND AS IS
OFTEN THE CASE THEY CAN TELL
FROM THEIR INITIAL INSPECTION
WHETHER OR NOT.
THEY NEED TO DO ONE AND WHETHER
OR NOT THERE ARE OTHER
VIOLATIONS HAPPENING AS WELL SO
TO KEEP THIS INFORMATION IN THE
HANDS OF CD PH THEN.
NOT ONLY MAKES IT A LOT MORE
LIKELY THAT THE HAZARD OF LEAD
EXPOSURE CONTINUES BUT THAT A
WIDE VARIETY OF OTHER SAFETY
HAZARDS MAY CONTINUE FURTHER
JEOPARDIZING THOSE WORKERS
HEALTH WE ARE -- SPARK.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS BY HAVING FROM ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA AND BE SUPPORT AB.
THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME UP TO THE TABLE
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR --
MEMBERS ROBERT MACHINE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE IN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION -- SO AT FIRST
TO BE CLEAR OUR POSITION IS NOT
BASED ANYWAY ON A YOU KNOW ON
TRYING TO DIET PREVENTS THE LEAD
REGULATIONS WHICH ARE COMING
DOWN THE PIPE TO TO LOWER
STANDARDS OR TO PROTECT.
NOT PREVENT PROTECTION OUR
WORKERS FROM LEAD OUR VISION IS
MAINLY FOCUSED ON THE TECHNIQUE
THIS BILL USES IN ORDER -- IN
HOW IT DIVIDE THE
RESPONSIBILITIES BETWEEN THE TWO
AGENCIES DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
AND CAL OSHA.
I'M WE BELIEVE THERE IS A BETTER
SET OF AMENDMENTS WHICH WE HAVE
PASSED THE OFTEN WE'VE BEEN
TALKS ABOUT AND WE APPRECIATE
THOSE WITH THAT WORK -- TO
CLARIFY THE ROLE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND CAL
OSHA TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S MORE
EFFICIENT IN PROTECTING WORKERS
EFFICIENT FOR THE BUSINESS AND
AT AND IS AS WE REDID.
EFFICIENT FOR THE COST OF THE
STATE -- SIR TO TO CLARIFY -- AS
JUST STATED WE DO THINK THERE'S
AN ISSUE WITH THE DISCRETION
PRESENTLY ALLOWED TO DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH THEIR DISCRETION WHEN
THEY FOR THE CASE TO CAL OSHA IS --
IS OVER BROUGHT AND THERE HAVE
BEEN ISSUES THERE AND WE
ABSOLUTELY DO NOT YOU MEAN TO
DEFEND THEIR FAILURE TO FORWARD.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE IN OUR
AMENDMENTS THE SOLUTION TO THAT
OVER DISCRETION.
IS TO LIMIT THEIR DISCRETION
WITH GUARD RAILS NOT TO THROW
THEM OUT O THE PROCESS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THEY PROVIDE SOME
VALUABLE -- ROLES IN TIMES OF
THEIR COLLABORATIVE PROCESS.
SO FAR AMENDMENTS AND AND WE ARE
IN TALKS ABOUT THESE WOULD LIMIT
THAT TO A SCHEDULED TO SAY YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE THIS MANY WEEKS TO
DEAL WITH THIS TO PROVIDE A
QUICK SOLUTION IF YOU CAN'T.
THEN KICK IT TO CAL OSHA HAVE
BEEN TREATED SERIOUS VIOLATION
AS THE BILL DOES PRESENTLY --
YEAH I HAVE ONE QUICK EXAMPLE --
TO TO KIND OF CLARIFY SOME OF
THE FACTS ABOUT THIS SO.
BECAUSE BLOOD LEVELS RIGHT RISE
OVER TIME AND FALL OVER TIME ONE
OF THE ISSUES WITH THIS BILL WE
THINK IS THAT -- LET'S SAY YOU
HAVE A WORKER IN A WE HAVE A
MEMBER COMPANY FROM THE BATTERY
COUNSELOR NATIONAL WHO.
WERE HERE BUT I JUST WHICH
COMMITTEES -- AND JOIN US THIS
POSITION.
I LIVE IN PLACE TO HANDLE THE
LEVELS THEY FOUND THE LAST TEST
TO THOSE EMPLOYEES WERE NEW.
THEY INVESTIGATED THE FOUND OUT
FAILURE TO PROPERLY PROPER
INDUSTRIAL HYGIENE IT'S A SIMPLE
AS YOU KNOW WASH YOUR HANDS
BEFORE YOU EAT LUNCH IN WORKING
WITH LET.
THE LEVELS GOING TO GO UP.
RIGHTS THEY PROVIDED ADDITIONAL
TRAINING THOSE EMPLOYEES THEY
TALKED ULTRA P. ABOUT IT.
THOSE WILL BE FIXED OVER TIME
BUT THEY'LL PROBABLY HAVE
MULTIPLE READINGS WITH A MAYBE
ABOUT LEVEL.
UNDER THIS BILL YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE MULTIPLE READINGS
AUTOMATICALLY KICK TO CAL OSHA
CAL OSHA THAN HAS TO
AUTOMATICALLY TREAT A SERIOUS
VIOLATION.
EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW WHAT THE
CAUSES AND IT'S BEING ARE BEING
WORKED ON AND FIX OVER TIME. TO
SITUATIONS LIKE THAT THAT WE
THINK THIS IS KIND OF A AN
OVERLY BLUNT APPROACH AND WE
HELPED ARMAMENTS CAN CLARIFY
THAT -- SO FOR THAT REASON
OPPOSE LESS AMENDED THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NONE COMMITTEE MEMBER
QUESTIONS CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD I DO
HAVE QUESTIONS -- AT THE WITNESS
STATED THAT -- AT SOME MADE THE
AGENCY ISN'T ALWAYS TRANSFERRING
THE INFORMATION TO CALIBRATION --
IT IN IT'S REQUIRED FOR THAT
INFORMATION GO TO CALIFORNIA.
THAT THAT'S WHAT IN IT ELEVATED
LEVELS WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WITH ELEVATED LEVELS OF LEAD
THEN IT WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
TRANSMIT IT TO GET TO CAL OSHA
IS THIS -- WANT SOMEBODY FILES A
WORKERS COMP CLAIM THIS PROCESS
IS GOING TO TAKE PLACE.
NO DIFFERENT WORKERS COMP AND WE%
JUST GOT RECENTLY GOT DATA FROM
THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
HOW OFTEN THEY REFER THESE CASE
OF A CAL OSHA. SIX TIMES IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS WHEN THERE'S
DOZENS AND DOZENS OF CASES PER
YEAR THAT THEY COULD REFER OVER.
SO THEY'VE USER DISCRETION VERY
VERY TO DISCRIMINATE WAY AND
HAVING PASS THEM ON OKAY SO I
GUESS I'M WONDERING SOMEBODY'S
GONNA TO EDUCATE ME LIKE HOW
YOU'RE GONNA OBTAIN THE BLOOD IN
THE FIRST PLACE TO SOMEBODY
FELLOW WORKERS COMP CLAIM AND
SAY.
YOU KNOW I FEEL DIZZY I DON'T
FEEL GOOD WHATEVER THAT WHATEVER
THAT ISSUES ARE RIGHT WHATEVER
THE SIDE EFFECTS ARE THE
SYMPTOMS.
AND AND THEN THE FILE WORKERS
COMP CLAIM AND THEN HOW DO YOU
OBTAIN THE BLOOD OR THE TESTING
FOR THAT.
IS IT SOMEBODY GETS INJURED ON
THE JOB GOD FOR BID AND AND IT
REQUIRES EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
THEN THEY TAKE SOMEONE'S BLOOD
IN THE NEW RELEASE THAT
INFORMATION WITHOUT THE
EMPLOYEES AUTHORIZATION.
I MEAN I'M JUST CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PROCESS OF SOMEBODY COULD
EXPLAIN THAT TO ME I'D REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CHECK FOR A
MOMENT.
YES BILL ALLEY OKAY WITH THE WG --
IN ANY WORK SITE WERE LED-EXPOSURES A CONCERNED YOU MUST
HAVE YOUR EMPLOYEES -- BLOOD
LIKE TESTED AT LEAST TWICE A
YEAR AND THAT DATA IS
AUTOMATICALLY TRANSFERRED TO
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH SO IT
HAS NOTHING TO THE WORKERS COMP.
SO IF YOU WORK WHETHER A BATTERY
RECYCLING SANDBLASTING COATINGS
GUN RANGES YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
SEND ALL THIS DATA.
YOU TOO MUST SEND ALL THE DATA
TO SEE PH TO ACCUMULATE SAID AND
HAS A DATABASE.
SO -- IT'S AUTOMATIC WE DONE BY
LAW I THINK BY REGULATION
ACTUALLY.
THAT'S HOW THEY GET THOSE
NUMBERS AND THE WORKERS THEN CAN
BE TOLD YOU HAVE HIGH BLOOD
LEVELS.
IS IT ESTABLISH A BASELINE IS
THERE A BASS LINE ESTABLISH AND
THEN IT EXCEEDS THE BASS LINE
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED OR JUST.
BUT WHAT IF THEY START MERETE
EXCEED THE BASELINE OF TWENTY IT
WAS WHAT I THOUGHT IT WAS RIGHT
[inaudible]
TWENTY MAYBE.
THIS BILL IS BEEN VERY IT'S A OF
THE ALARM LEVELS OR RIGHT NOW
CAL OSHA'S REDOING THEIR
REGULATIONS BEEN UNDER PROCESS
FOR SEVEN YEARS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK BECAUSE A BILL TO SPEED
THOSE REGULATIONS UP IN ADOPTING
NEXT YEAR -- THE THE CHANGES THE
THE LEVELS IN THE BLOOD IN WHICH
THE WORKER IS AUTOMATICALLY SENT
HOME TAKEN OFF THE WORK SITE
ALSO CHANGES THE AMBIENCE LEAD
LEVELS IN THE AIR BUT IT DOESN'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH AB
THIRTY FIVE THE BILL BEFORE YOUR
COMMITTEE.
WHICH IS ABOUT GETTING THEM
REFERRED TO CAL OSHA FOR
INSPECTION THE INSPECTION
ACTUALLY IT'S CALLED NOT
REFERRAL BUT A COMPLAINT TO
TECHNICALLY AS THAT WOULD CAL
OSHA CALLS IT.
SHOULD BE A COMPLAINT FROM THEY
SAID THEY GET TEN TO THIRTEEN
THOUSAND COMPLAINTS A YEAR FOR
ALL DIFFERENT WORKS WORK THINGS
SO.
THIS LOOKING AT THE DATA WOULD
ADD A FEW DOZEN MORE THIRTY
EIGHTY MORE AND THEY SAID WE CAN
HANDLE THAT AN APPROACH THEY
SAID. SEVEN HUNDRED ABOUT SEVEN
OR EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
TO HANDLE THIS INCREASED
WORKLOAD.
WE JUST SUPPOSE THAT AGAINST YOU
KNOW OF HUNDREDS OF THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN MEDICAL COSTS FOR
PEOPLE WHO LOSE WORK TIME AND
GET SICK TREMORS -- NERVE DAMAGE
HEART DISEASE CAUSED BY HIGH
BLOOD LEVELS.
AND I WOULD ARGUE MILLIONS MORE
TO ADD STAFFING DPH TO ACTUALLY.
DO WHAT IS BEING SUGGESTED BY
OPPOSITION TO BEEF UP FOR THEM
TO FOLLOW UP ON BEFORE SENDING
IT OVER TO OSHA ACTIVATED RIGHT
NOW PART OF THE REASON WHY --
DPH ISN'T FALLING THROUGH
AWESOME THIS THERE'S
UNDERSTAFFED -- THE PUSH TO THE
THE APPROPRIATE INVESTIGATIVE
ARMS OSHA -- AND DPH IS NOT
KICKED OUT OF THE PROCESS TO PHD
AS PART OF THE PROCESS THE WHOLE
TIME TO CONTINUE TO BE PART OF
THE PROCESS.
SO THAT IF AN INVESTIGATION DONE
BY OSHA SHOWS THAT THERE'S SOME
PROCEDURAL ASPECTS OF THE WORK
SITE THAT DON'T REALLY LEND
ITSELF TO A LARGE MINOR CITATION
OR OF BUT WAS STORED AND AT
FIRST THEY CAN WORK WITH DPH TO
PICK SOME OF THOSE ISSUES AS WAS.
REFERRED TO AS THE HAND WASHING
ISSUE OR SOMETHING MINOR LIKE
THAT DPH IS STILL VERY MUCH PART
OF THE PROCESS.
SO THESE EMPLOYER IN A REPORT TO
BOTH AGENCIES CENTERS THERE ONE
BLOOD TESTS THAT SUBMITTED TO
BOTH AGENCIES THE AGAINST AN
ENTITY PH AND THEN DPH WITHOUT
THE TRANSMITTED THAT'S ABOUT THE
ELEVATED LEVEL TO OSHA.
OKAY IF I COULD BRIEFLY CLARIFY --
I'LL BE VERY PRETTY.
LAID THE AFTERNOON -- ONE OF THE
ISSUES WHICH WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS BILL IS THAT THE
PRESENTLY COMING DOWN THE PIPE
LED REGULATIONS -- REFLECT
DIFFERENT LEVELS THAT PRESENTLY
EXISTS AND THIS BILLS TWENTY IS
NOT ACTUALLY TIED TO A NUMBER
THAT RACK ONE OF THE MEN WITH
YOU PROPOSED.
IS TO HAVE THIS BILL REFER TO A
LEVEL IN THE REGULATIONS THAT
HAS THE REGULATIONS CHANGE THIS
BILL WILL SHIFT WITH IT -- I
THINK THAT SOME THE TWENTY OTHER
IS PRIMARY LANGUAGE AND IN HERE
SUCH THAT IF COLLISON THE FUTURE
DOES ADOPT STRICTER REGULATIONS
PURSUANT TO THEIR OF ON GOING.
PROCESS THAT THIS WOULD THIS
WOULD CHANGE ALONG WITH CAL
OSHA'S RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
CENTER STONE THANK YOU -- THANK
YOU MISTER CARR OF IN MY REPORT
IS SHOWS OVER THE PAST EIGHTEEN
YEARS THERE'S BEEN A 54%
DECREASE IN THE NATIONAL
PREVALENCE OF BLOOD LEAD LEVELS
THE GREAT OF AN EQUAL TO TWENTY
FIVE MICROGRAMS.
PER DECILITER [inaudible]
AND DO YOU WANT TO LOWER THAT
THRESHOLD.
TO TWENTY MICROGRAMS PER
DECILITER FROM FIFTY WHICH IS A
A 60% DECREASE IN THAT HAVE OVER
TO OSHA -- I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
SUCH A DRACONIAN -- THRESHOLD
DECREASE -- AND IN LIGHT OF ALSO --
THIS BILL WAS -- SUBMITTED TO
ALMOST THE EXACT SAME BILL AB.
TWENTY NINE SIXTY THREE AND
GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED IT --
CLAIMING THIS DEPARTMENT HEALTH
WORKS FOR QUIET CORNER
COLLABORATIVELY WITH EMPLOYERS
TO REDUCE.
WORKER EXPOSURE TO LETTER REFERS
EMPLOYERS TO THE DEPARTMENT FOR
ENFORCEMENT UPDATED ON A CASE BY
CASE BASIS SO WE SEE A DECREASE
INCIDENCE A HIGHER SENSITIVITY.
AND SYSTEM SEEMS TO BE WORKING
IN THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH.
WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT THIS BILL.
I DON'T BELIEVE THE SYSTEM HAS
BEEN WORKING IN A BIG DROP IN
THOSE CASES REPORTED CASES THE
FACT THAT EXCITE WAS CLOSED.
THAT WAS A BIG BUT A NUMBER OF
THOSE CASES THE TWENTY
MICROGRAMS IS WHAT OSHA IS
RECOMMENDING SWIRL THAT WERE
BURGER LYING ON OUR EXPERTS TO
TELL US WHAT.
THAT NUMBER SHOULD BE A WHAT IS
OUR SCIENTIFIC BASIS FOR THAT
ONE OF THE OTHER RECORDING
SUSPENDED AND CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL.
DATA YES THE FEDERAL -- LEVEL OF
RESPONSE I BELIEVE IS TWENTY
FIVE MAY BE STAFFERS THIS TWENTY
FIVE PIC CALLOW SHOULD TOLD US
LAST YEAR WHEN WE'RE DING AB
TWENTY NINE SIXTY THREE THAT.%
USE TWENTY WERE COMFORTABLE WITH
THAT IT'S A BETTER LEVEL MORE
PROTECTIVE OF WORKER HEALTH.
THAT SO THAT'S WHERE THE COMES
FROM SO FEDERAL ACTION LEVELS
TWENTY FIVE CALIFORNIA BE TWENTY
OTHER STATES HE'S TWENTY ALSO.
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE SERVER.
I JUST LIKE THAT I JUST HAVE ONE
MORE QUESTION SO IT SAYS IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT THE BILL WOULD
FURTHER PROVIDE THAT THE ABOVE
DESCRIBED REPORT WOULD CAN TO
CONSTITUTE A SERIOUS VIOLATION
WITH OSHA -- IS A SERIOUS
VIOLATION WITH OSHO WITHOUT AN
INVESTIGATION TO SHOW THAT THE
GUY STARTED -- WITH YOU KNOW
HIGH BLOOD LEVELS OR IS IT JUST
AN AUTOMATIC SERIOUS VIOLATION
FIND WHICH COULD BE THOUSANDS
UPON THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS AND
AND AS IT CAME OUT WITH IS THAT
THE TERM OF ART THAT ACTUALLY
TRIGGERS.
THE THE INVESTIGATION IT DOESN'T
REQUIRE A CONCLUSION OF THE
INVESTIGATION TO BE ANY
WORDS.
IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T BUT
BECAUSE OF THAT THIS YEAR'S
VIOLATIONS THE TRIGGERING A
TRIGGERING TERM.
BY TRIGGERING IT NOW -- CHICKEN
BASKET THEY CAN DO BUT THERE'S
NOTHING WRONG WITH THE INDIAN
THAT THERE WAS A ONE OFF THAT
PARTICULAR DAY THAT'S NOT
RELATED TO THE OPERATION OF THE
BUSINESS.
BY NATE BY LABELING A SERIOUS
VIOLATION IN NO WAY DOES THAT
PREJUDICE -- THE EMPLOYER WHAT
IT DOES IT TRIGGERS A TRIGGERS
INVESTIGATION.
SO I HAVE TO PICK A DIFFERENT
BECAUSE I'M EMPLOYER AND DIVERT
IN TWENTY SIX YEARS -- SHOULD ON
RIDERSHIP ONE TIME FOR AN INJURY
THAT TOOK PLACE IN IN IN IN
INDUSTRY -- THAT WE WERE DEEMED
NOT RESPONSIBLE BUT AN BUT TO
HAVE A SERIOUS VIOLATION AGAINST
YOU UNDER CAL OSHA PROHIBITS YOU
FROM HAVING CONTRACTS.
PROHIBIT YOU FROM GAINING
CONTRACTS ESPECIALLY IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY THE AG INDUSTRY THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS THAT AFFECT
EMPLOYERS AND IF THERE'S IS AN
AUTOMATIC SERIOUS VIOLATION
ATTACHED TO THIS.
WHEN THERE?
COULD BE A FINDING OF NO GUILT
WHATSOEVER THAT THAT'S A HUGE
CONCERN.
AND THAT COULD VERY WELL BE THE
CONCLUSION OF THOSE SHOWS THAT
THERE IS NO VIOLATION IT IT'S
IT'SLABELING ISSUES VIOLATION
FOR THE PURPOSE OF TRICKING THE
INVESTIGATION.
BUT THEN OCEAN WILL DO THE
INVESTIGATION AT THE CONCLUSION
OF THE INVESTIGATION -- SHALL
DECIDE WHAT -- WHAT WE'LL DO
WHAT WILL BUT THE CONCLUSION OF
THAT INVESTIGATION WILL BE?
THE DON'T YOU THINK IT SHOULD
SAY AS IT WOULD THIS THAT THE
BILL WOULD FURTHER PROVIDE THAT
THE ABOVE -- DESCRIBE REPORT
WOULD CONSTITUTE A SERIOUS
ALLEGED VIOLATION INSTEAD OF A
MANDATED SERIOUS VIOLATION.
THIS MIMICS FEDERAL LANGUAGE AS
TO HOW AN INVESTIGATION IS
TRIGGERED BUT ONCE AGAIN -- THAT
THE THE DEEMING A BIT OF A
SERIOUS VIOLATION IS FOR THE
PURPOSE THE TRIGGERING THE
INVESTIGATION -- SECOND TEAM
THAT THERE IS NO VIOLATION THE
CONDITION THAT THERE'S NO
CITATION THEY CONTEND THAT THE
COULD BE A REALLY QUICK FIX --
AND SO AGAIN IT'S A TERM OF ART --
NOT SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO
BE ON A PERMANENT RECORD
BUSINESS THE EXTENT THAT OSHO
DEEMED A SERIOUS VIOLATION.
THAT TRIGGERS THE INVESTIGATION
AND AGAIN THIS ISN'T THIS MIMICS
FEDERAL LAW -- IN TERMS WHAT
WOULD REQUIRE -- BUT LAUNCH AN
INVESTIGATION ACCORDING TO
FEDERAL LAW AS WELL.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS [inaudible]
OKAY SO.
SOME OF HER AYE -- JEFF FISHER
YOU BRING THIS BILL FORD.
YEAH I I THINK WAS AS WE
DISCUSSED BEFORE -- AND AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT THE OPPOSITION
SAYING BUT FRANKLY THE THE PART
OF PUBLIC HEALTH -- AT LEAST
RIGHT NOW DOESN'T REALLY HAVE
THE STAFF TO DO MUCH OF AN
INVESTIGATION BEYOND WE RECEIVED
THE BLOOD LOVE LEVEL TEST AND
REVIEW THEM AND SAY.
AND SO FORTH AND AND ACTUALLY
YOU KNOW SINCE I CHAIR THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AYE I ACTUALLY
HOPE THAT PERHAPS THE CHAMBER
AND OTHERS MIGHT ACTUALLY PUT IN
A BUDGET REQUEST FOR MORE STAFF
FOR THE LEAD.
THAT FOR THE OCCUPATIONAL LED
THE VISION.
FOR THE FARM PUBLIC HEALTH --
BEYOND WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED TO FAR SO -- OUR WORK
WITH THE GOVERNOR TO TO INCREASE
THE STAFFING SO THAT THEY COULD
HAVE MORE CAPACITY TO DO SO BUT
I THINK IN THE ABSENCE OF THAT.
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO DO ON SITE
INVESTIGATIONS TO FIGURE OUT AND
CAL OSHA IS THE AGENCY THAT'S
CHARGED WITH THE LEAST ONSITE
INVESTIGATIONS -- SO -- TO ME
WELL IT'S NOT IDEAL -- IT IT DID
GIVEN THE REALITIES WHAT WE'RE
FACING RIGHT NOW I DATE AND AND
THE SERIOUSNESS OF LEAD --
POISONING THAT I THINK -- THIS
IS A REASONABLE SOLUTION TO THE
TO THE CURRENT PROBLEM -- AND
AND ENSURE INVESTIGATION I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT -- AS YOU SAID
IT'S IT'S REALLY AN ALLOCATION
OF THIS YEAR'S VIOLATION OF
COURSE HAS.
TO THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S AN
INVESTIGATION AND THE BUSINESS
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DEMONSTRATE ITS THERE AND
THEY'RE NOT THE ONES WHERE THE
AT FAULT RIGHT AND AND SO.
SO WE CERTAINLY WE DO NOT WANT
TO PRESUME.
IT BUSINESSES IS CAUSING
SOMETHING BUT WE NEED TO FIND
WE'D HAVE A RESULT THAT SHOWS A
PROBLEM THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
INVESTIGATION TO IDENTIFY WHAT
THE CAUSES.
AND THAT'S ALSO FOR THE SAFETY
AND HEALTH OF THAT WORKER AND
ALSO THEIR FAMILY BY THE WAY I
MEAN I'M A PEDIATRICIAN SO THERE
HAS THERE'S BLOOD LEVELS THAT
HIGH.
WHAT A BRING HOME FROM WORK
CA HOURS A COMING FROM
SOMEWHERE ELSE IS ACTING FOR THE
WORKPLACE WE NEED TO KNOW WHERE
IT'S COMING FROM SO?
WITH THAT -- IS THERE A MOTION
ON THE BILL IT'S BEEN MOVED --
SO RICARDO JULY CLOSE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS MISTER CHAIR AND-AGREE THAT THE STOCKS COULD BE A
COST SAVING TO EMPLOYERS THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO IDENTIFY AND
ISSUE EARLIER RATHER THAN THREE
FOUR FIVE YEARS ON THE LINE --
WAS GONNA COST MILLIONS ARE MUCH
MORE POTENTIALLY TO MITIGATE
THIS IS ACTUALLY I CAN BE VERY
GOOD FROM PLAYERS AS WELL AS
WITH THAT RESPECT YES WHEN I
BOUGHT.
I THANK YOU SO THE MOTION IS --
DO PASS REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT SO SAID
GOING TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE AND I
GUESS I'LL SEE IT THERE -- TOO
SAYS OCCURRED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CAN HI AND I STONE STONE NO
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
GROUP KNOWN HER TADO LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL MONNING RUBIO.
THE BILL CURRENTLY IS THREE TO
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU ALL RIGHT --
NEXT BILL.
IS ITEM NUMBER THREE AB.
FIFTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AB
FIFTY EXPANDS THE ASSISTED THE
WAITING LIST CURRENTLY ONLY
FIFTEEN COUNTIES ARE ALLOWED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM.
AB FIFTY WOULD EXPAND THE
PROGRAM TO ALL COUNTIES
INCLUDING PROVIDING ACCESS TO
RURAL COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T
HAVE AS MANY THESE FACILITIES.
AB FIFTY ALSO SETS OUT NEEDED
ADJUSTMENTS FOR FAIR PROVIDER
REIMBURSEMENT AND REQUIRES
ENGAGE MISTAKE ORDERS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
THE ASSISTANT LIVING WAIVER
PROGRAM PROVIDES A CRITICAL
COMMUNITY BASED ALTERNATIVES. TO
INSTITUTIONALIZATION FOR
ELIGIBLE OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES I MEDI CAL.
THE WAIVER PROGRAM ALSO ALIGNS
WITH THE STATE'S COMMITMENT OF
THE OLMSTEAD DECISION.
BUYING THAT THE UNNECESSARY
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES IS A VIOLATION
OF THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACT.
THEREBY ESTABLISHING THE RIGHT
OF INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
TO RECEIVE SERVICES IN THE MOST
INTEGRATED SETTING.
EVEN THOUGH THE DEPARTMENT RENEW
THE WAIVER PROGRAM FOR ANOTHER
FIVE YEARS.
THERE HAS BEEN DISCUSSION TO
INTEGRATE THE PROGRAM AT THE
HOME AND COMMUNITY BOARD SERVICE
BASED SERVICES WAIVER.
AND AB FIFTY INCLUDES LANGUAGE
ACCOUNT FOR THAT TRANSITION
ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT TO RAMP UP
SERVICES PRIOR TO THAT OCCURRING.
UP WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IS GEORGE COULD MERION
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF SIX
BEDS AND LISA COLEMAN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND YOU
HEARD THIS WE HAVE SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES DON'T JEOPARDIZE THAT
WOULD LIKE.
FIGURE THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
MY NAME IS GEORGE CAN YOUR NAME
HERE WAS EXPENSE WHICH IS A
STATE WIDE TRADE ASSOCIATION THE
REPRESENTS BOARDING CARE HOMES A
SERVE ADULTS AND OLDER ADULTS.
I LIKE TO START BY THINKING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA FOR
CONTINUING TO CHAMPION
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE LW PROGRAM --
THIS PROGRAM JUST STARTING TO
SCRATCH THE SURFACE OF OF ITS
POTENTIAL AS A CAN HELP
SIMULTANEOUSLY ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES OF AN AGING
POPULATION HOMELESSNESS AND
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS.
WE ARE TERMS SUCH AS LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS AND
CONTINUUM OF CARE -- BUT GIVEN
THE SAN FRANCISCO'S LAS 34% OF
HIS ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
AND 26% OF HIS RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY SINCE
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE REALLY BIG
BEGS THE QUESTION WHETHER WE
TRULY HAVE A CONTINUUM OF CARE.
I'D ARGUE THAT FROM A MEDIC
HEALTH FUNDING PERSPECTIVE THERE
IS NO TRUE CONTINUE ON WHAT WE
HAVE INSTEAD IS A PATCHWORK OF
SERVICES ON ONE HAND WE HAVE A
PROGRAM SUCH AS I HSS TO PROVIDE
SERVICES AT HOME.
AND ON THE OTHER END OF THE
SPECTRUM WE HAVE INSTITUTIONS
SUCH AS SNAPS.
AND BE IN BETWEEN THE TWO WE
HAVE A L. W. THIS TRYING TO FILL
A GAPING HOLE -- SO.
THIS PROGRAM CAN HELP DO THAT BY
PROVIDING MORE ACCESS FOR
CONSUMERS AND RESPECT LAST RIGHT
BUT IT'S GOOD AFTERNOON LISA
COLEMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION
I DID HAVE A PREPARED STATEMENT
BUT GIVEN THE TIME OF THE DAY
AND THAT I HAVE PRESENTED BEFORE.
A CENTER PAN AND SENATOR STONE
WHO HAVE BOTH AND SUPPORTIVE.
THIS IS AN AWESOME PROGRAM.
AS EVIDENCED BY THE FACT THAT
EVERY TIME WE GET AN ADDITIONAL
BAD ADDED TO THE PROGRAM THE
WEIGHTLESS GROWS SO I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. TWO OTHER
WITNESSES REPORT.
AND FLORA ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION ON THE BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS.
OF LOS ANGELES SANTA CLARA AND
THEN TRY COUNTIES.
THANK YOU IN SUPPORT OF HIS OF
WE BY ENEMY TO W. ASKS ME IN
SUPPORT.
MODEL COOPER ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THE ONLY OTHER WILLIAMS ON
BEHALF OF SEMEN SEMANA CARE AND
I SUPPORTED THANK YOU -- CHILD
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HEATHER HARRISON WITH A
CALIFORNIA ASSISTED LIVING
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT YOU.
SO MY AND HER ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF ALAMEDA AND SUPPORT Q..
JOE RODRIGUEZ CALIFORNIA STATE
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
JERRY DEVON BY REPRESENTING A A.
R. P. AND OUR THREE POINT THREE
MILLION MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA WE
DID SEND A LETTER OF SUPPORT
ALTHOUGH IT DID NOT MAKE IT ON
TO THE COPY FOR TODAY.
BUT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
RESIDENTS ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BARBER GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU OKAY.
YES I WAS ASKED BY GARY PASS
MORE FOR THE CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS THAT THEIR ME
TO WOULD BE PUT ON THE RECORD
OKAY THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
FILLS BEEN MOVED.
GREAT BILL I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THAT'S WHEN I BOUGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER KARA ALRIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARIES CALL THE ROLL.
AM I AND I STONE AYE STONE AYE
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROVE.
HER TADO LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE MONNING
RUBIO.
THE BILL IS FIVE VOTES THAT'S
ENOUGH TO GET OUT -- WE'RE GOING
TO HOLD OPEN ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND FINALLY WE
HAVE OR KALRA.
STRAIGHT.
AND IT IS THE ITEM NUMBER SIX
EIGHTY FIVE A SIX WHICH
UNDERSTAND ALSO HAS SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES.
OKAY SO YOU HAVE SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES AND NO FORMAL OPPOSITION
THAT WE RECEIVE THE UNDERSTAND
SO.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU A THANK YOU
MISTER AB FIVE OR SIX TO PLACE
AN OUTDATED AND INCONSISTENT
CAUSATION TESTER TERMINATE CLASS
DOUBLE A CITATION. FOR A LONG
TERM CARE FACILITY WHERE BUT THE
MORE CURRENT STANDARD IN THE
TRIMMING NEGLIGENCE SUBSTANTIAL
FACTOR.
THE PART ABOUT KILL THIS IS A
CLASS DOUBLY AFTER UNDERGOING A
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION OF
SUSPENSE SUSPICIOUS DEATH AND
DETERMINES A REGULATION DESIGNED
TO KEEP THE RESIDENT ALIVE AND
SAFE WAS NOT FOLLOW DUE TO
FACILITY NEGLIGENCE THE
NEGLIGENCE WAS THE LEADING CAUSE.
THE RESULTED IN THE DEATH OF
THAT RESIDENT.
CURRENTLY THE LOSS IS A MUST BE
A DIRECT PROXIMATE CAUSE OF THE
DEATH WHICH IS THE STANDARD HAS
BEEN REJECTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT.
BECAUSE IT IS A CONFUSING
STANDARD THE BURDEN OF PROOF IS
STILL ON THE DEPARTMENT A
SUBSTANTIALLY THE CITATION AND
RECENT MMS REQUIRES A VIOLATION
BE A FORESEEABLE RESULT.
GIVEN THE FACTS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THAT THE
OCCURRENCES TIED TO A REGULATORY
VIOLATION.
WITH THESE RECENT AMENDMENTS AND
A NUMBER OF CONCESSIONS MADE
PRIOR TO THE TO THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING WE HAVE REMOVED
OPPOSITION.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
FACILITY SENSATION CALIFORNIA
HOSTILE CESSATION DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES NETWORK AND LEADING
EDGE CALIFORNIA -- AN ADDITIONAL
EIGHTY FIVE US AT THE TOP STATE
AUDITOR RECOMMENDATIONS TO
INCREASE LONG TERM CARE FACILITY
CITATION AMOUNTS WHICH HAVE NOT
CHANGED IN EIGHT YEARS -- THE
INCREASES IN COUNTY ABOUT CLOSE
TO ABOUT THE CONSUMER PRICE
INDEX AS REQUESTED BY INDUSTRY.
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE BAD PERFORMING SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AND OTHER
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES ARE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS ESPECIALLY WHEN I TALK
ABOUT THE FACILITIES NEGLIGENCE
WAS RESPONSIBLE. FOR RESIDENTS
DEATH.
THE DEPARTMENT TAKES EXTREME
CARE IN APPLYING THE CITATIONS
IN THE PRIMARY USE.
IS TO PLACE A BAD POINT FACILITY
ON WATCH SO THAT THE QUALITY OF
THE CARE CAN BE IMPROVED FOR
FUTURE RESIDENTS THE INTENT IS
NOT TO CLOSE DOWN THESE
FACILITIES.
OF AB FIVE OR SIX CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT THE TO
PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF THE THOUSANDS OF AGE
DEVELOPING DISABLED OTHER
MEDICALLY BONE RESIDENTS.
BY HOLDING ACCOUNTABLE THOSE FEW
BAD ACTORS FOUND TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR RESIDENTS HARM
OR DEATH WOULD BE TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES MARIA EVA
GARCIA.
WHO LOST HER MOTHER DUE TO
NEGLIGENCE AND NURSING HOME CARE
AND GILES DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA?
OKAY THANK YOU WITNESSES SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN PAN AND
ALL OF YOU ON THE STATE AND THE
SENATE HALTH COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR DEDICATED
SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE OF THIS
GREAT STATE AND THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY.
ON THIS IMPORTANT THAT
LEGISLATION BEFORE YOU.
SENATOR PAN.
MY TESTIMONY TODAY SEEMS NOTE
WERE SEAT TO ME AS I AM THANKFUL.
TO LIVE IN YOUR DISTRICT AND TO
BE YOUR CONSTITUENT.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK SENATOR
GROVE. FOR REPRESENTING MY
HOMETOWN OF BY SALLY ARE WHERE
MY MOTHER LIVED MY MOTHER RAISED
HER FAMILY AND WHERE MY MOTHER
TOOK HER LAST BREATH.
THANK YOU TO MY BROTHER AND
SISTERS FROM BY SELLER HERE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FIVE OR SIX MY NAME IS MARIA
EVER GARCIA.
I STAND HERE TODAY NOT ONLY TO
TALK ABOUT AN AMAZING MEXICAN
WOMAN ME MAMA.
MY THE OTHER GARCIA.
BUT TO BE HER VOICE AND THE BOYS
FOR THOUSANDS OF DISABLED
RESIDENTS AND HUNDREDS WHO HAVE
LOST THEIR LIVES DUE TO LACK OF
PROPER CARE.
MY MOTHER WAS BORN IN MEXICO
APRIL TWENTY SIX NINETEEN THIRTY
SIX AND DIED ON SEPTEMBER FOURTH.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY SEVENTEEN MY MOTHER
SUFFERED A MASSIVE STROKE THAT
LEFT HER WITH BRAIN DAMAGE.
A WEEK LATER HER DOCTOR CAME TO
ME TOLD ME.
YOUR MOM WILL NOT RECOVER MUCH
MOVEMENT ON HER LEFT SIDE.
OF HER BODY TERRIFIED MY
RESPONSE WAS HE MICHELLE BE
PARALYZED FOR THE REST OF HER
LIFE.
DOCTOR SAID YES.
MY MOTHER WAS A STRONG
INDEPENDENT WOMAN SCARED AND
CONFUSED AFTER MASSIVE STROKE
SHE WAS EXTREMELY DEVASTATED
WORRIED SHE WOULD NO LONGER BE
ABLE TO BE HERE FOR HER CHILDREN.
GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN SHE BECAME VERY
DETERMINED TO OVERCOME.
SHE REPEATED TO ME MANY TIMES.
NO MAKE IT A MONIES I DO NOT
WANT TO DIE.
IN MARCH OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AFTER LONG THOUGHT WE HER NINE
CHILDREN DECIDED TO ADMIT HER TO
REDWOOD SPRINGS HEALTH CARE
FACILITY.
A LONG TERM HEALTH CARE FACILITY
IN BY SONYA WITH HOPES OF
RECOVERY AND BRINGING HER BACK
HOME.
WEEKS PASSED WE CAME TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE BRAIN DAMAGE
SHE HAD SUFFERED HAD VERY MUCH
DISABLED FOR HIS STRONG PROUD
WOMAN IN DIAPERS IN IN A
WHEELCHAIR.
ON AUGUST. TWENTY NINE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN A NURSE AT REDWOOD
SPRINGS ASSISTANT MY MOTHER OUT
OF HER WHEELCHAIR AND LEFT
UNATTENDED ON THE COMMODE CHAIR.
LEFT ALONE AND WITHOUT THE
ABILITY TO SUPPORT OR CONTROL
HER OWN BODY.
ME MAMA FELL HEAD FIRST.
ONTO THE HARD TILE FLOOR.
WITHOUT ANYTHING TO BREAK HER
FALL.
SHE SUSTAIN TO MASSIVE HEAD
INJURIES RESULTING IN NUMBERS
STITCHES AND BRUISING. SIX DAYS
LATER THE WOMAN I'VE KNOWN ALL
MY LIFE. TO BE A HARD WORKING
LABOR DIED ON LABOR DAY.
IT TOOK LARGE AMOUNTS OF MAKE UP
ON A BEAUTIFUL WOMAN WHO NEVER
WORE MAKEUP. TO COVER THE NINE
STATES WANT IN MASS OF BRUISES
ON THE LEFT SIDE OF HER FACE.
IN ORDER TO GIVE MY FAMILY AND I
A CHANCE TO SAY GOODBYE WITH AN
OPEN CASKET [inaudible]
SIDE RIGHT.
TODAY YOU HAVE THE POWER.
THE POWER TO CHANGE THIS
CONFUSING LAW.
TODAY I AM BEGGING YOU PLEASE
VOTE YES ON AB FIVE OR SIX ON
BEHALF OF ME MAMA.
IN THOUSANDS OF DISABLED
RESIDENTS.
LET'S CHANGE THIS LAW THAT HAS
CREATED CONFUSION FOR MANY YEARS
AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
MY MOM DID NOT WANT TO DIE.
MY MOM DID NOT DESERVE TO DIE
THIS WAY -- USED TO THE SENATE
FOR THEIR THEY COME DENTIST
ACCOMPLISHED YOUNG TEXAS THE THE
PUT MUCHO SONYA'S.
BUT POPULOUS REBELLED WITHIN SEE
AVE KING INTO SET OF CITIES YES
YES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR CHECKER CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
KALRA AND OF THE OPPOSITION AS
WELL FOR ALL COMING TOGETHER AND
WORKING VERY HARD ON A SLIPPERY
AREA OF THE LAW TOLD MOLLY FIND
AT A SWEET SPOT FOR THIS VERY
DIFFICULT -- ISSUE OF TRYING --
TO FIND -- COMPROMISE -- FOR
ESTABLISHING CAUSATION IN THIS
CASE IN THESE CASES AND WE URGE
YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT BACK
MY GIVEN.
NAME IN ORDER TO LIVING IS HE A
UP A US TO BE A THANK YOU CRISIS.
MY NAME IS OKAY LEAH GARCIA SO
YOU HAVE A MUDDY OTHER GARCIA.
YOU UP FOR YOUR HIGHEST BE A
GOOD IDEA THANK YOU CRISIS.
WHEN I STARTED THIS ME NUMBER SO
LEVY AYE GARCIA?
BECAUSE THERE MIGHT BE OTHER
GUYS SCEA YEP FOR U. S. THE V.
[inaudible]
OKAY CRISIS.
MY NAME IS ALEXANDER DOMINGUEZ
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
WHAT IS THAT IS ME NUMBERS
WITHIN THE GARCIA IT WITH MY
DEAR THEY GOT A SENIOR THE
EMPLOYERS TO THE?
ADDRESSES BASIS.
LAKE BYNUM UW ASKED ME ALSO
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TIFFANY ONE WITH AS THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TO RODRIGUEZ CALIFORNIA STATE
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JERRY DEAFENED BY A A RP IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THESE ARE COMMON WITH CALIFORNIA
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY -- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION --
TWEETERS SIR NOT NOT POSITION A
BLOOMBERG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH FACILITIES
OR NEUTRAL NOW WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR SPONSOR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US.
THANK YOU.
BARBARA GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE WERE OPPOSE BUT WE ARE NORMAL
NO LONGER OPPOSED AGAIN THANK
YOU ALL FOR WORKING SO HARD WITH
US THANK YOU.
MEMBERS CUT THE MUSTER WITH THE
BILL MAIL SERVICES NETWORK IN
THE SAME BOAT AS MY COLLEAGUES
AND THANK THE AUTHOR AND STAFF
AND SPONSORS FOR WORKING WITH US.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TRANSMIT ON
BEHALF OF THE TRINITY COUNTY
HOSPITAL LONG TERM CARE FACILITY
WE ARE NOT OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BUT I WAS ASKED TO JUST SHARE
SOME POLICY CONCERNS FOR A
FACILITY LIKE.
TRINITY COUNTY HOSPITAL IN A
VERY SMALL -- RULE COUNTY --
THEIR FACILITY ALMOST CLOSE TO
YEARS AGO I WAS LOSING MONEY BUT
THROUGH EFFORTS BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE THEY DID.
REMAIN OPEN AS A BASICALLY A
COMMUNITY SERVICE AND THEIR BIG
FEAR AS ADULT AT AS WE CONSIDER
BILLS THAT INCREASED FINES FOR
ALL TYPES OF THINGS -- FINE FOR
A FACILITY LIKE THERE IS COULD
BE ULTIMATELY THE LAST STRAW
THAT ENDS UP CLOSING THE
FACILITY THAT SERVES A COMMUNITY
FOR HUNDREDS OF MILES.
SO IT'S DIFFERENT THAN GETTING A
FINE IF YOU'RE A DIFFERENT TYPE
OF A FACILITY AND SILICON VALLEY
OR ELSEWHERE I DON'T KNOW IF WE
HAVE A SUGGESTION OR A SOLUTION
BUT IT'S SOMETHING IN OUR CLIENT
ASKED TO SHARE WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER.
ON THESE TYPES OF MEASURES GOING
FORWARD ON SOME SORT OF
CONSIDERATION -- FOR FOR
DIFFERENT TYPES OF FACILITIES IN
DIFFERENT AREAS THAT SERVE
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I QUESTIONS YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CENTER STONE.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
WITNESSES FOR BEING HERE I'M
SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS AND I'M SURE
THAT YOUR MOTHER IS VERY PROUD
OF YOU BEING HERE TODAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
WE ADDRESS THIS IN THE FUTURE
FOR OTHER VICTIMS AND THANK YOU
WHAT I'M OF THE BILL.
AT THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED -- SEEN
OTHER QUESTIONS I JUST WANT SOME
RICARDO -- CAR RIDES FIRST OF
ALL I WANNA THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR WORKING ON MY STAFF BUT EVEN
MORE THE FACT THAT I MEAN WE'RE
HERE TALKING ABOUT NO OPPOSITION
AND WE HEAR ALL THE PEOPLE
TAKING OUT THE OPPOSITION.
THAT WAS NOT WHERE WE STARTED
AND I THINK THAT -- TIMMONS
WORKED WITH THAT YOU'VE DONE
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS TO SAY
LET'S LAND ON A REASONABLE
SOLUTION THAT ADDRESSES THIS
VERY IMPORTANT PROBLEM.
AND CAN BRING EVERYONE TO
AGREEMENT I THINK IT IS IS
CERTAINLY -- I WANT RECOGNIZE
THAT THE WORK THAT YOU DID ON
YOUR PART TO TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN
TO ADDRESSES IMPORTANT ISSUE AND
CERTAINLY -- STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL WHICH I CLOSE.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
I CERTAINLY WANT TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF -- I WANT TO
THANK THE OPPOSITION TO IT WAS
NUMEROUS AND AND A LOT OF WORK
WENT INTO THIS I WANT TO THANK
MISTER GILES HAS BEEN A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK ALONG
WITH MY STAFF. TO GET TO WHERE
WE ARE -- AND SO I APPRECIATE
THE RECOGNITION TO MISTER SMITH
POINTS CERTAINLY -- AND AND I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY TO TALK TO
ESPECIALLY IF SUCH A LEGISLATION
COULD BE SOMETHING THAT COULD BE
HELPFUL TO SOME THOSE MARCHERS
SMALLER FACILITIES THAT AGAIN
THE INTENTIONS.
IS IS NOT -- TO CLOSE ANY OF
THEM DOWN BUT THERE'S SOME
UNIQUE SITUATION YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE AND AND AND GETTING AS
MUCH SUPPORT POSSIBILITIES.
AND FINALLY I WANT TO THANK THEM
IS GARCIA FOR ONCE AGAIN THIS IS
NOT THE FIRST TIME HE'S
TESTIFIED IN AND I KNOW HOW HARD
IT IS FOR HER TO DO IT.
UP FOR HER TO BE HERE WITH HER
FAMILY -- AND SHARE THEIR VERY
VERY PERSONAL STORY I'M VERY
GRATEFUL AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THANK YOU NINETY ONE MISS GARCIA
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING
YOUR OTHER STORY IN YOUR FAMILY
BEING HERE I KNOW THAT'S NOT
EASY THANK YOU.
I CAN SAY TO SOMETHING AND VERY
FAST.
MY INTENTION IS IS NOT TO CLOSE
DOWN SMALL BUSINESS OF MY
BUSINESS I'M A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER MYSELF.
BUT IF WE CAN PROVIDE BETTER
CARE I THINK EVERY BUSINESS HAS
THE RIGHT TO STAY IN BUSINESS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE'S.
BRIDGES TO PROVIDE BETTER CARE
FOR ELDERLY FOR OURSELVES FOR US
HERE PRESENT TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU --
SO THE MOTIONS TO PASS REFERS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY --
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN NIGHT AN ONLINE STONE STONE
AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROW.
HER TADO LEYVA LEYVA HI MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING RUBIO.
RUBIO I SIX THE BILL HAS SIX
VOTES IT'S ENOUGH TO GET OUT OF
ALL THE ROLE OF AND FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS -- WHICH THE WAY FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO AND I
SEE HERE OKAY WELL COME.
COME ON UP ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
A. B. C..
TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE ABOUT AS
CLOSE.
YEAH SIX EIGHT YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY WELCOME AND I UNDERSTAND
THIS BILL HAS SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES SO.
MOVE THE BILL AND IT'S EASY.
THANK YOU MISTER ABOUT WHO
RESPECTFULLY WOULD ASK -- YOU I
VOTE FOR A. B. -- TWELVE SEVENTY
FIVE WHICH REQUIRED DH CS TO
ESTABLISH OUT REACH TEAMS.
OF FOR ALMOST POPULOUS BEST BUY
HOMELESS POPULATION BECOMES
CHAIR.
A KEY WITNESSES SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT HARRIS ON BEHALF LC I
YOU CALIFORNIA AND GETTING
HOMELESS PEOPLE WONDER JUST
BECOMING HOMELESS.
IN SUPPORT OKAY THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT BACK
MICROPHONE.
SEE NINE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEND IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER STONE A YES.
SENATE IS ALWAYS I JUST WANTED
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR THIS --
THIS IS A BIG HUGE DEAL OF
COURSE ALL OVER THE STATE BUT
SPECIFICALLY FOR LA COUNTY THANK
YOU SIMPLY MEMBER AND THANK YOU
FOR BEING.
OKAY ANY OTHER.
BEEN SECONDED WOULD YOU
CLOSE I THINK MISTER
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER OKAY
THANK YOU THE MOTION IS TO PASS
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND BY AYE STONE STONE AYE
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROW HER
TADO.
LEYVA [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
I MONNING MONNING AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I SIX THE BILL HAS SIX
VOTES WILL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ACTUALLY SINCE OKAY NEXT UP WE
HAVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE
HAVE FOUR ENDS IN CONSENT
CALENDAR IS.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY I AND NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY
THREE FIVE TWENTY SIX I INNER
THIRTEEN AB TEN THIRTY SEVEN
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TEN
NINETY EIGHT IS OUR MOTION FOR A
CALENDAR.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER MONEY
SECTOR THESE CALL THE ROLL AND I
AND I STONE.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROW.
FURTADO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE RUBIO RUBIO AYE.
HEY WE HAVE FIVE FIVE VOTES FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
OKAY SO LET'S SO.
MOVE -- WE HAVE ACTUALLY
CONCLUDE OR JANICE OVER TO KERN
CO STAR FROM AND FOLLOW ORDERS
SO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE THEY'RE NOT COMING BACK OKAY.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER ONE AB -- ONE
SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND THE
SACRED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS SIGNING.
MONNING AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
RUBIO HI.
OKAY THAT BILL WAS OUT.
NINE ZERO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY THIRTY FIVE
FACE SOME OF THE CAR -- SIXTY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
HER TANO.
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING I
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE -- SIX ACTUALLY NOT
NOLAN WHICH FALLS ON A CHáVEZ
CONSENT CELLS TO OKAY SO THAT'S
CURRENTLY SIX TO HOLD THE ROLE
OF AN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
ACTUALLY I'M GOING TO SKIP TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR -- SEC
RIPLEY'S CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
STONE THANK YOU.
STONE I GROW HER TADO LEYVA.
IN THIS CONSENT TO ACTUALLY CAN
YOU CALL THE ROLL AGAIN ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
GROVE HER TADO HER TITLE I AND
LEYVA. SEVEN OKAY SO CURRENTLY
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SEVEN VOTES
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN.
CASE I'M GOING TO GO BACK NOW --
TO ITEM NUMBER. THREE TWO OKAY
SO I SAID LET'S DO ITEM NUMBER.
TWO I AB THIRTY FIVE BY SUMMER
KALRA AYE NUMBER TWO SIX EIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS SENTADO.
HER TITLE HI.
THEN THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN TWO
RIGHT NEXT TIME IS ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB FIFTY BY SUMMER CAR US
ACTIVITY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS THROW.
HER TADO HER TOTAL I MONNING
MONNING AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I SIX EIGHT BILLS OUT --
EIGHT ZERO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
ONE BY SOME MEMBER ARAMBULA
SIXTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS RUBIO
[inaudible]
RUBIO I THAT BILLS OUT NINE IS
ZERO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB FIVE A SIX BY SUMMER
KALRA SICKLY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS GROW.
HER TADO HER TOTAL AYE MONNING
MONNING AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO NEXT ITEMS ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN
BY SUMMER CALDERON SEPARATE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS RUBIO.
RUBIO I'D.
THAT BILLS OUT.
EIGHT ONE NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER NINE EIGHTY FIVE NINETY
EIGHT BY SOME A MEMBER BLOOM SIX
FIFTIES CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS.
SIR VOTING II -- TACO HER TOTAL
AYE MONNING [inaudible]
OKAY SO THAT BILLS OUT -- EIGHT
ZERO NEXT ITEMS I AND NUMBER TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTY THREE BY SOME
OF EVER GRAY SIX FIFTIES CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS ARE
TAUGHT -- HER TITLE I RUBIO
[inaudible]
I STEP THOSE OUT NINE ZERO EXT
ITEMS I NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY
NINE TWENTY NINE BY SUMMER LOSE
RATE RIVAS ACIDITY SO THE ROLE
THAT SOME MEMBERS STONE
[inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
SO I MONNING MONNING I RUBIO.
RUBIO I THAT BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO OKAY NEXT BILLS ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE EIGHTY NINE FIFTY
FOUR BY SOME MEMBER WOULD SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING AYE
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE IF THAT BILLS OUT NINE
IS -- ZERO NEXT ITEMS I NUMBER
FIFTEEN A. B. TWELVE SEVENTY
FIVE BY SOME MEMBERS SANTIAGO
SOCRATES CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS GROVE HER TADO.
IT'S ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES COUNTY PILOT
PROGRAM.
CHAIR VOTING II [inaudible]
I FOR TITLE I LEYVA.
IT'S ELEVEN NOT COMING BACK.
OKAY YEAH OKAY SO I'M GONNA KEEP
THAT ROLE OPEN AT SCULLY --
SEVEN ZERO AND THEN ITEMS OVER
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WERE
ALL HELD BACK BY THE AUTHORS --
ANYONE ELSE DOES.
LATE CHECK PAYCHECK WITH NUMBER.
ONE IS THAT OF A SLAVE.
OKAY.
OKAY I THINK EVERYONE SHOULD BE
GOOD -- CAN WE JUST FIND OUT
OKAY ARTS COMING BACK SO I THINK
THERE'S TWO ITEMS FOR HER --
CONSENT.
THANK YOU. FOR THE CHANCE
CONSENT AND THEN SHE SAYS
.
THE STATION WITHOUT SYSTEM BY.
OKAY SO LET'S -- WE HAVE -- THE
REMAINING ITEMS ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE
BY SEVEN MEMBER SANTIAGO SIX IF
THESE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS LEYVA.
LEYVA HI.
OKAY AND THEN THE NEXT TIME IS
THE CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS LEYVA.
LEYVA.
OKAY SO THAT'S OUT EIGHT ZERO
THE CLEAR SANTIAGO.
I MEAN THE THING STRAIGHT
ANNOUNCED THAT EVIDENCE THAT WAS.
THE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN IS OUT
EIGHT ZERO THAT'S AB TWELVE
SEVENTY FIVE AND A GOOD CELL AT
CALENDARS OUT. EIGHT ZERO OKAY.
THAT'S RIGHT OKAY SO THIS
CONCLUDES THE AGENDA.
OF THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED THANK YOU